BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ONE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
TODAY IS WEDNESDAY MARCH
TWENTIETH.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN WITH ISSUE --
ONE WITH THE PANELISTS PLEASE
COME FORWARD
.
JEFF SAID PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
JUST KIDDING AND BEFORE WE BEGAN
I DO WANT TO FIRST THANK ALL OF
YOU WHO ARE PARTICIPATING IN WHO
WILL PARTICIPATE.
IN TODAY'S HEARING AND A FEW
NOTES BEFORE WE DO BEGIN.
I DO WANT TO ASK ALL PANEL IS TO
PLEASE BE SUCCINCT.
AND BRIEF.
YOU PRESENTATIONS TWO TO THREE
MINUTES A SUGGESTED.
IN ORDER TO FACILITATE
FACILITATE THE FLOW OF THE
HEARING.
SECOND DO BOTH TO THE VOLUME OF
ISSUES WE NEED TO COVER TODAY AS
WELL AS THE LARGE TURNOUT WE'RE
ASKING FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR
EACH PERSON NOW AT THE LAST
HEARING I HAD SAID TO MINUTES
AND I WAS VERY PLEASED THAT.
UP ALMOST EVERY SINGLE PERSON
WHO COMMENTED WAS UNDER ONE
MINUTE SO I WILL ASK THAT YOU
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO ONE
MINUTE.
WE DO WANT TO HEAR FROM EVERYONE
AND THAT IS THE ONE WAY THAT WE
CAN BE ASSURED THAT WE WILL HEAR
FROM EVERYONE.
IF NECESSARY WE WILL A STAFF
WILL GIVE US A GENTLE REMINDER
THAT WE ARE GOING OVER.
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE.
I WANT.
TO WELCOME ACTING DIRECTOR PAT
LEARY AND CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
PETE [inaudible]
CHARANGA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CALORIE
ACTING DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
TO HONOR YOUR REQUEST WE ARE
GOING TO KEEP OUR OPENING
REMARKS EXTREMELY BRIEF --
WE KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THIS THIS
PROGRAM IS TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS IS A LIVE IN
HOME SUPPORT SERVICES IS THE
LARGEST --
LONG TERM SERVICES FOR PROGRAM
IN THE NATION --
AND AS WE GO THIS IS AN EXTRA --
AND FOR THE STATE WITHOUT I'M
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO FUTURE
BEEN CUT TO GET POSTS THE REST.
YEAH THANK YOU MANAGE
[inaudible]
IT BACK.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TO BE BACK
BEFORE YOU TO TALK ABOUT THE
PROGRAM TODAY --
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO DO
INTRODUCTIONS DOWN THE PANEL OR
I CAN DIVE RIGHT IN --
A DIVE RIGHT AND SO TO TWO
THINGS -- WE
WERE BEFORE THE SENATE ON THE
SAME ISSUES LAST LAST WEEK AND I
WANT TO MAKE TWO POINTS --
FOR THE PUBLIC BEHIND US SO THAT
THERE'S NO CONFUSION --
ABOUT --
WHAT WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TODAY?
IN THE DEPTHS OF THE DAY GREAT
RECESSION --
IT BUDGET REDUCTIONS WERE MADE
TO THE AYE CHOI SAYS PROGRAM
INCLUDING A 7% REDUCTION IN
AUTHORIZED HOURS FOR RECIPIENTS.
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION AS
THE LAST HAS PROPOSED A GENERAL
FUND BACK FILL OF THAT SO THAT
THAT REDUCTION IS NOT
IMPLEMENTED.
THERE IS NO PROPOSAL TO MAKE A
BUDGET REDUCTION TO THE I. HSS
PROGRAM BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE.
THE ISSUE IN THE AGENDA FOR YOU
TODAY IS SIMPLY WHETHER THAT
REDUCTION IS --
REPEALED OR SUSPENDED Vì ã
LÏNG A CHANGE TO THE
UNDERLYING STATUTE OF THE
PROGRAM BUT I WANT TO BE CRYSTAL
CLEAR THERE IS NO PROPOSED
REDUCTION --
TO SERVICES IN THE AYE HSS
PROGRAM THE SECOND THING THAT I
WANT TO MENTION IS FOR US A
SUBSEQUENT ITEM IN THE AGENDA
RELATED TO ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A A
MOVEMENT NATIONALLY TO OPPOSE
THE EMPLOYMENT AND UNTIL
IMPLEMENTATION OF ELECTRONIC
VISIT VERIFICATION.
HOWEVER WHAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA AN OBLIGATION TO
COMPLY WITH A FEDERAL LAW.
THE LAW ALSO REQUIRES THAT THERE
BE STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE V. V. AS WELL
AS THAT THE V. V. SOLUTION THAT
IS IMPLEMENTED AS MINIMALLY
BURDENSOME TO CONSUMERS IN THE
PROGRAM.
A WE'VE ENGAGE WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS IN CALIFORNIA AND
ESSENTIALLY ARE PROPOSED
IMPLEMENTATION OF ELECTRONIC
VISIT VERIFICATION.
SIMPLY MOVES THE CURRENT PAPER
TIME SHEETS TO EITHER AN
INTERNET BASED OR TELEPHONE --
THE SOLUTION.
OF FOR TIME SHEET AND CONSUMERS
AND PROVIDERS WILL HAVE THE
CHOICE OF EITHER THE INTERNET OR
THE PHONE --
AT THEIR DISCRETION TO TO USE
THAT THERE ARE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
ADDED TO THE TIME SHEET
REGARDING --
START TIME AND STOPPED TIME EACH
DAY -- AND
ALSO THE LOCATION OF WHERE THE
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED WHICH HAS
BEEN THE MOST CONTROVERSIAL WORD
BUT IN IN ESSENCE --
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING IS THAT
PEOPLE BE ALLOWED TO SAY
SERVICES WERE PROVIDED AT HOME
IN THE COMMUNITY OR BOTH?
WE ARE NOT PROPOSING GLOBAL
POSITIONING ELECTRONIC LEASH ON
PEOPLE AND I WANT TO SAY THAT
FOR THE RECORD SO THAT THE
AUDIENCE UNDERSTANDS.
THE PROPOSAL BEFORE US TODAY --
WITH RESPECT TO THE FIRST ITEM
ON YOUR AGENDA THE RESTORATION
OF THE 7% REDUCTION YOUR AGENDA
IS VERY CLEAR ON PAGE FIVE WHAT
THE PROPOSAL IS WE PROPOSED A
GENERAL FUND.
ROUGHLY THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR --
AUGMENTATION TO THE PROGRAM AND
WE PROPOSED BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE --
THAT WOULD SUSPEND --
THAT IN ANY IMPOSITION OF A OF A
COT -- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU HAVE A
PROPOSAL FROM A NUMBER OF
PARTIES --
THAT WERE PART OF THAT REDUCTION
THAT WOULD CODIFY --
THE ELIMINATION OF THAT
REDUCTION --
RATHER THAN DO IT IN THE ANNUAL
BUDGET ACT AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
MERITS ONE WAY OR THE OTHER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA BOSS HAMILTON AND I'M
HERE REPRESENTING YOU W. ASKED
ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY WE
REPRESENT A HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND
I JUST US WORKERS.
AND I'M HERE TO INTRODUCE ELAINE
QUEEN WHO IS AN AYE HSS WORKER
AND YOU W. MEMBER FROM MERCED
COUNTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ELAINE QUEEN
AND I AM HOME CARE PROVIDER FROM
MERCED.
I CARE FOR MY MOTHER.
MY MOTHER HAS IMMENSE DIABETES
AND HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE AND SHE
IS.
SEVERELY OBESE.
SO WHEN HER MS IS PLANNING SHE'S
NOT ABLE TO DO MUCH OF THE WORK.
BECAUSE OF HER PAIN SO SHE
COUNTS ON ME TO DO A LOT OF THE
THINGS AROUND HER HOUSE.
BUT WE DO NOT LIVE TOGETHER SO I
TRAVEL TO HER HOME.
I HAVE MY OWN EXPENSES AND SHE
AND MY FATHER HAD THERE'S HER I.
HSS HOURS ALLOW ME TO MAINTAIN
MY INTEGRITY AS HER PROVIDER.
CARE FOR MY HOME AS WELL AS
LETTING MY MOTHER.
MAINTAIN HER OWN INTEGRITY.
WHEN THE SEVENTH PERCENT CUTS
WERE IN FACT MIGHT MANY FAMILY
PROVIDERS LIKE ME LIKELY DID THE
SAME WORK?
THEY WERE JUST PAID LESS.
OR THEY HAD TO TAKE OTHER JOBS
AND WEREN'T THERE EVERY TIME
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS NEEDED THEM.
NOW CLIENTS WITH NON FAMILY
PROVIDERS JUST DIDN'T GET ALL
THE CARE THAT THEY NEED IT.
IMAGINE YOU'RE AN OLDER PERSON
OR SOMEONE WITH A DISABILITY
SOMEONE WHO LIVES ALONE WHO
NEEDS PERSONAL CARE HELP TO GET
THROUGH YOUR DAY.
THEN IMAGINE YOU HAVE A 7% CUT
OF THAT CARE WHAT WHAT CARE
SERVICES DO YOU CUT.
GOING TO THE BATHROOM.
TAKING ABOUT ARE BEING DRIVEN TO
DIALYSIS.
CUTTING HOURS MEANS CUTTING CARE
AND CUTTING CARE MEANS PUTTING
PEOPLE'S LIVES IN DANGER.
THANKFULLY DUE TO THE HARD WORK
OF CARE GIVERS AND OUR UNION.
THE TWENTY FIFTEEN BUDGET
RESTORED THOSE CUTS AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THAT AND FOR EVERY
BUDGET THAT'S BEEN PASSED SINCE
BEEN THAT RESTORES THE CUTS.
BUT WE NEED THAT RESTORATION
ENCODED INTO LAW.
KNOWING THAT CUT STILL EXIST IS
TERRIFYING TO US WE CAN'T KEEP
COMING BACK HERE YEAR AFTER YEAR.
AND GETTING A ONE YEAR BANDAID
FIX IT'S LIKE HAVING AN AXE OVER
YOUR HEAD.
THAT COULD FALL AT THE WORST
POSSIBLE MOON SHE ATE THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATORS
PROMISED TO FUND THAT 7%.
WE KNOW THAT THEY THERE ARE MANY
DEMANDS ON THE STATE'S FINANCES.
AND AND THE RESTORATION THE
RESTORING OF THE CUT FROM YEAR
TO YEAR SHOWS A COMMITMENT TO
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES IN OUR STATE.
BUT PLEASE THIS YEAR MAKE THE
RESTORATION PERMANENTS.
WE NEED THAT PEACE OF MIND
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SYDNEY TEMO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WHILE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DOES NOT ASSUME EXTENSION
THE MANAGED CARE ORGANIZATION
TAX THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES
TO RESTORE THE 7% THE BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE ON AN ONGOING
BASIS.
THE COST TO STORE THE SOMERSET
AS PETER.
HAD PREVIOUSLY TOUCHED ON IS
ESTIMATED TO BE THREE HUNDRED
AND FORTY TWO POINT THREE
MILLION GENERAL FUND.
AND TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY WE
HAVE ENGAGE IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS CONCERN TRAIL
OF OUR LANGUAGE AND LOOK TAKE
THEIR CONCERNS INTO
CONSIDERATION AS WE GO INTO MAY
REVISION.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHECK IN BRAZIL LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AS THE
DEPARTMENT MENTIONED --
IT FOR THIS PARTICULAR CHANGE
THEY'RE PURSUING BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
LANGUAGE BUT ONCE IT'S RELEASED
WERE HAPPY TO PROVIDE ANY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO STAFF
AND INVOLVED IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS AS WELL IN TERMS
OF THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
BUDGET BALANCED AUDITORY CHANGES.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT --
TO PANEL THIS IS MICHELLE ROUSEY.
ESTABLISH.
WOULD YOU PLEASE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM [inaudible]
MISS REYES.
HERE BECAUSE OF FRAZIER
[inaudible]
MATHIS.
PATTERSON RAMOS.
RUBIO.
DOCTOR WOULD [inaudible]
QUORUM.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE WELCOME.
HI MY NAME'S MICHELLE ROSY RED
HSS CONSUMER FOREVER HSS
PROVIDER --
I COME TO YOU TODAY TO TALK
ABOUT TWO SUBJECTS THE FIRST ONE
IS ABOUT THE 7% CUT IN YOUR
START RESTORING THAT CUT
PERMANENTLY.
OF WHEN WHEN WE'RE IN THE MIDST
OF HAVING THOSE CUTS AS A
CONSUMER I'M HAVING TO DECIDE
WHICH ITEM OF MY SERVICES THAT I
HAVE FOR HSS THAT I'VE GOT TO
NOT HAVE THAT DAY.
OR CUT THAT DAY WHETHER IT'S
ABOUT CRUCIAL TO MY CARE.
OF I DO NOT HAVE FULL CARE I
AGENTS IS NOT FULL CARE BUT IT
GIVES US ENOUGH CARE TO KEEP US
IN THE COMMUNITY AND STABLE AND
ENOUGH THAT WE DON'T WE DON'T
CLASSES STAY IN AN INSTITUTION.
CUTS FOR ME WHAT WERE BRUTAL AS
AN ANYBODY THAT HAS A
SIGNIFICANT ABOUT HOURS CUTS ARE
ALWAYS BUREAU BRUTAL BECAUSE IT
IT JUST.
IT'S IN HUMANA THINK OF THINGS
NOT BEING DONE.
THOSE SERVICES ARE CRUCIAL TO
LIKE CARRY IT KEEPING ME IN THE
COMMUNITY.
I HOPE THAT YOU GUYS WILL FIND A
WAY TO RESTORE THE 7% NOT JUST
THIS ONE YEAR SHE SAID ABANDONED
IF THAT'S JUST A BAD DAY FOR
THIS YEAR WE NEED TO KNOW YEAR
AFTER YEAR THAT YOU HAVE THAT
COMMITMENT TO US.
AND THAT THAT SERVICE IS GOING
TO BE THERE YEAR TO YEAR AND NOT
HAVE CONTINUE CUTS.
BECAUSE EVERY YEAR I COME HERE
AND I ASK YOU PLEASE NO MORE
CUTS PLEASE RESTORE THE CUT IT
YEAH AND I'M THINKING IN THE
BACK OF MY HEAD.
IF WE HAVE TO HAVE THOSE CUTS
AGAIN WHY.
WHY IT IN AND THERE'S NO REASON
FOR IT OTHER THAN YOU GUYS
HAVING TO FIGURE OUT NOT TO HAVE
IT?
AND I URGE YOU GUYS TO CONTINUE
TO DO THAT TO CONTINUE TO HAVE.
OF THAT COMMITMENT TO THIS
PROGRAM THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'D LIKE TO NOW OPEN IT UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT.
PANELISTS DON'T LEAVE YET
[inaudible]
AFTERNOON.
I KEVIN AS THEIR COALITION
CALIFORNIA WATER RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS.
WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO
REPEAL THE 7% THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
JOHN ROW CONTRA COSTA COUNTY I
AM AND I JUST AS PROVIDER.
AND I STRONGLY URGE TRAILER BILL
ADOPTION THE PERMANENTLY FIXED.
WHAT EVERY OTHER AGENCY OF
ALREADY HAD WHICH IS PERMANENT
RESTORATION OF THE?
CUTS THAT WE ALL WE SEE THERE NO
WAIT.
IT'S LONG PAST DUE TO GET THIS
OFF THE AGENDA.
YEAR AFTER YEAR AND WASTING YOUR
TIME AND OUR TIME ON THE SAME
ISSUE.
IT'S INEFFICIENT.
WE'RE ASKING FOR THE SAME
TREATMENT AS EVERY OTHER STATE
AGENCY WE WANT THE STATE NAME
RESPECT.
AND DIGNITY AND EQUITY OF EVERY
OTHER WORKER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO PARALYSIS I'M A HOME CARE
PROVIDERS.
STANISLAUS COUNTY.
HOW THIS 7% REDUCTION COULD
POSSIBLY AFFECT MY GRANDSON
[inaudible]
WOULD BE.
MY DAUGHTER HAS EXHAUSTED ALL
THAT THE MEDICAL.
COMMUNITY HAS TO OFFER MY
GRANDSON.
HE SUSTAINED A TBI.
DRAMATIC BRAIN INJURY.
WHICH LEFT HIM IN A WHEELCHAIR
NONVERBAL.
SHE SIX OUT ALTERNATIVE MEDICINE
AND THAT 7% WOULD REALLY.
CUT INTO HER BUDGET [inaudible]
CURRENTLY SHE'S.
HAVING HIM TAKE COURSE THERAPY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE MAY THINK THAT'S
JUST FUN AND GAMES BUT NOT TO MY
GRANDSON.
THAT IS HELPING HIM WITH HIS
CORE STRENGTH IN HIS BODY.
SO PLEASE.
TAKE THE 7% REDUCTION OFF THE
TABLE.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
RUSSELL RAWLINGS I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF ADVOCATE BECAUSE SEE
AT RESOURCES FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING.
THE INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTER
SERVING SACRAMENTO AND YOLO
COUNTIES.
I AM ALSO AND I HSS RECIPIENT
THROUGH THE MEDICAID --
CALIFORNIA WORKING DISABLED
PROGRAM.
AS YOU ALL KNOW THIS IS BEEN
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE HAD TO
TIRELESSLY SPEND --
MANY WEEKS MONTHS YEARS WORKING
ON AND AS IT WAS SO ADEQUATELY
DESCRIBED IT'S YOU KNOW IT IT'S
A CONSTANT DANGER.
THE 7% WRIST --
CUT THAT WE SUFFERED AND IT WAS --
QUITE CATASTROPHIC --
THE IHS HAS PROGRAM IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF PROGRAM THAT
ENABLES SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES TO LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY.
AND PART OF UP PROGRAM THAT
SUPPORTS THE HOME SAID HOMESTEAD
DECISION --
PLEASE KEEP THIS PROGRAM HOLE
AND WE ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO
MAKE A WHOLE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO ALL.
HI MY NAME IS DOLLY CAM AND
THEY'RE FROM SUN MATEO COUNTY.
I TAKE CARE OF MY SISTER OVER
DARES THEY CAN DRAW SECOND SEED.
US IS DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED.
IT MANY OF ITS ERA SICKNESS
MANIFESTED BEEN SINCE THE AIDS A
DONE SINCE THE AGE OF SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND SO FORTH
SO USED TO BE A MODEL IN A WELL
KNOWN.
OF OF COURSE MANY COMPANIES.
THE DENSITY BECAME SEAT NOBODY
IN OUR PLUMMETED --
AN ADDER PLACED WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE CARE OF HER BECAUSE THEY
SAID IT PAYS TO LET ALL OF THAT
IS NOT ENOUGH TO SUSTAIN THEM.
SO NOW WE COME TO YOU WE WOULD
LIKE TO REQUEST YOU TO PLEASE.
THERE'S A PROPOSED TO THE STORE
27%.
BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO BE STUCK TO
REQUEST YOU TO PLEASE MAKE IT
PERMANENT.
PUT IT DOWN IN WRITING.
NOT YEAR TWO YEARS.
THE MOST LESSEN OUR NECK
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
IT SHOULDN'T WE MEANT NOT BE YOU.
FOR YEARS YOU KNOW ALL WE LIKE.
AND CALIFORNIA'S THE BET IS THE
SEVENTH LEAD TO THIS COUNTRY IN
THE WORD THAT DIDN'T KNOW WORK
NOT ONLY IN THE UNITED STATES
YOU.
THE 7% THE ALL THIS ABLE.
ALL THE MOST.
WHAT IN THAT WERE SOCIETY?
NOW WE HAVE THE DEMOCRATS WE HAD
NEWS.
IT WAS PROPOSED THAT THEY REALLY
PUT BACK THE 7% BUT PLEASE WE DO
NOT NEED JUST A PROPOSAL WE NEED.
YEAH NOT YET BUT THAT BY MOMENT.
TO ONE YOU KNOW IT WAS TAKEN.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET.
YOU'RE A COOPER.
YOU MAY TO GET IN [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WHAT IS YOUR NAME WHAT.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT AS
YOU'RE SPEAKING WE DON'T HAVE
ANY APPLAUSE BUT EVERYBODY'S
APPLAUDING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LEE HERE --
WITH SENIOR IN DISABILITY
ACTIONS OF FRANCISCO.
AM I HAVE A QUESTION HOW MANY.
OTHER PROGRAMS HAVE.
HE KNOWS THIS TYPE OF CUTS
PENDING CATS.
EVERY YEAR.
I THINK IT'S ONLY HSS.
IS THAT.
A SIGN THAT THIS IS WRONG.
SO -- PLEASE
MAKE SURE THAT.
THIS YEAR.
THAT WE DON'T ON TO YOU KNOW
CONTINUE --
TO MAY.
THE WRONG DECISIONS AND AND
INFORM.
THEM.
GOVERNOR NUISANCE NOW NO NO I
KNOW BUT I'M I'M SAYING THAT WE
DON'T HAVE BROWN AND DEAD IT WAS
ALWAYS IN FORCE AND WHAT SHOWS
ARE NAY YOU'RE DEAD.
SO MAYBE NOW YOU CAN MAKE IT
PERMANENT.
THANK YOU.
THE NAME IS JEFF TORTILLA AN
ADVOCATE --
I'M HERE TO SAY DITTO.
AND I'M ALSO HERE TO SAVE IT YES
I REPRESENT DOG FIGHT.
HI REPRESENT HOW I REPRESENT
KERA.
AND THERE'S A FEW OTHER PEOPLE
AND ORGANIZATIONS SO I WILL
REPORT BACK AND SEE WHAT THIS
COMMITTEE DOES DO.
IN ITS FUTURE AND
CONGRATULATIONS AND SEE HOW YOU
DO ON THIS TASK.
THANK YOU.
IF ANYONE WITH THAT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL TO RESTORE THE 7%
PERMANENTLY THROUGH --
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
LIBBY SANTOS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES FOR IN HOME SUPPORT
OF A SOURCE SERVICES ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF PERMANENT
RESTORATION OF THE 7% CUT THINK
THANK YOU CAN WE MOVE THE
MICROPHONE.
SIR THIS WAY BECAUSE EVERYBODY'S
IN THE DARK AND I CAN'T SEE WHO
IT IS IT'S COMING UP OKAY NOW I
SEE.
THANK YOU I AM IN THE LIGHT.
THE LIGHT.
MARTY MOTO --
FAMILY MEMBER CALIFORNIA
DISPLACING YOUR COMMITTEE ACTION
NETWORK CITY CAN PROVIDE ONE
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
OF ALL THIS IS ADVOCATES ON ON A
LOT OF COMPLICATED ISSUES OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
APPRECIATE THIS ADMINISTRATION
BUT THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
RESTORING THE THE 7% REDUCTION
BUT WE NEED TO IN PERMANENT --
WE SHOULD MAKE REDUCTIONS THAT
HARM PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
AND SENIORS A MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS HARD TO IMPOSE.
AND LASTLY JUST WANT TO SAY.
THAT -- TO
THE LAST ONE OF THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS ABOUT IS THERE A CUT
LIKE THIS --
BEING IMPOSED ON PEOPLE --
WITH DISABILITIES AND YES THERE
IS ONE THERE'S THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE --
IN THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM
THAT IS ACTUALLY PENDING I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE SUBCOMMITTEE
STAFF IN THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR
HOPEFULLY TAKING THE ACTION. TO
RESTORE THE 7% REDUCTION EMILY
THANK YOU.
THE THE BIRD FLU.
A MEMBER OF RENDON MADE THE TO
MOVE TO TO MOVE THE NED WILK.
SASHA BITTNER A MEMBER OF HAND
IN HAND THE DOMESTIC EMPLOYERS
NOW AND THEY'RE BREWING DB.
THE WICKED TO THE GROUP PHONE
YEAH.
THE MOVE COULD PHONE I HAVE.
AND I HAPPENED TO BE A DELEGATE
TO THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY THE THE HAVE GOOD FOR YOU
NEED TO WE YOU NEED.
TO GO DO FOR YOU.
IN.
THE ROOM TO GROW AND BLOOM AND
THEN.
IF THE BOAT [inaudible]
INDEPENDENCE.
THE GM PEOPLE WITH THROUGH THE
BROUGH REVIEW.
WE NEED TO DO WE REVENUE
COMMUNITY.
AND TO LEAVE FOR AND PRODUCTIVE.
FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF SEE
HOW IDEA --
OF COURSE WITH THE SYSTEM WE
NEED TO RESTORE THE 7% BUT WE
ALSO NEED A CODIFIED INTO LAW TO
MAKE IT PERMANENT --
THIS IS ABOUT INDEPENDENCE THIS
IS ABOUT MOVES A FIFTY THIS IS
ABOUT PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
LIVING IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOING GO BORN AND
BEING ABLE TO LEAD A FULL AND
PRODUCTIVE LIVES DAILY YOU FEEL
RIGHT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LUCIA LITTLE I
WORK FOR AYE HSS I TAKE CARE OF
MY MOTHER SHE SAID MY CLIENT OR
ONE OF MY CLIENTS I TAKE CARE OF
SOMEONE ELSE ALSO.
I AM REQUESTING THAT YOU DO
RESTORE RESTORE THE 7%.
BECAUSE WE DO NEED THAT AND IF
IT'S NOT RESTORED THIS YEAR WILL
BE BACK HERE EVERY YEAR UNTIL IT
IS RESTORED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
BRENDA GARDNER SACRAMENTO HOME
CARE EXECUTIVE V. BOARD MEMBER.
AND I JUST WANNA SAY ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT JUST TESTIFY THIS IS
SEARS BUSINESS WE NEED TO COME
HERE AND STOP THIS ONCE AND FOR
ALL ONCE AND FOR ALL BECAUSE
EVERY YEAR HOME CARE PROVIDERS
ARE COMING BACK ACTON FOR THE
SAME THING.
WHY IS IT THAT WE CAN GET
ANYTHING THAT'S --
SITUATED AS HOME CARE PROVIDERS
WE NEED THAT 7% AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AND WE NEEDED TO TO BE
MANDATED.
EVERY.
NOT NOT TO COME BACK I WILL
FIGHT THIS WE DON'T WANT TO KNOW
MORE WE WANT TO MAKE IT PART OF
THE LEE.
WE DON'T HAVE TO COME BACK HERE
ANOTHER YEAR WE WANT IT STOPPED
AND WE WANT IT NOW [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS IS TO TELL ONE HERE'S MY
CLIENT ALSO MY SON AND HE WANTED
TO SAY SOMETHING [inaudible]
SEVEN TEN NOW.
YEAH WE ALL HEARD THE NOW
[inaudible]
WHAT?
JUST BECAUSE YOU CUT 7% FROM OUR
CLIENTS DON'T MEAN THERE'S 7%
BETTER WE STILL HAVE TO TAKE
CARE OF THEM THAT 7% WHETHER WE
GET PAID OR NOT.
AND WITH ME I TAKE CARE OF MY
SON.
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN AND WE NEED TO
HAVE.
THE LANGUAGE THE TRAILER BILL
THAT WAS PUT IN PLACE BY THE
UNIONS SO THAT WE CAN GET OUR 7%.
BACK PERMANENTLY.
SO WE DON'T HAVE TO KEEP COMING
AND FIGHTING YEAR AFTER YEAR.
SO WHEN I COME EVERY YEAR AND WE
FIGHT THE SAME ISSUE AND HE'S
ASKING YOU TO GIVE HIS7% BACK
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO OPEN
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIRMAN.
AND LEGISLATOR.
MY NAME IS TO REACH RUSSIAN YOUR
AND DISABILITY ACTION.
FROM SAN FRANCISCO I'M HERE TO
US YOU. TO PREACH INFUSION
INCREASE THE S. S..
WE ARE LIVING UNDER THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LINE.
CAN YOU HELP US I GET THIS A LOT
BY LIZ.
DIALYSIS.
SPECIAL NEEDS BECAUSE OF FISH
NEED SPECIAL FOOD NICK SPECIAL
SHOES AND OTHERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME
IS BRENDA OKOLI.
SEIU LOCAL.
TWENTY FIFTEEN THAT LASTED HERE
LAND.
I WAS LOOKING AT ARE YOU GUYS
SPACES.
HE LOOKS SO HAPPY [inaudible]
SO CHEERFUL.
NOW WE'RE IN ABOUT A SEPARATE.
BUT WE DO.
A ONE O'CLOCK STRIFE FOUR
O'CLOCK IN ESTABLISHED TO GO
HOME WE DON'T.
WE STILL TAKE THEIR CRAP TO THE
REST ROLE WE STILLGIVE THEM
THEIR DINNERS WE STILL PUT THEM
TO BED.
WE'RE SHORT SO WHAT WE SHORTEN
OUR SALES.
WHICH SHORTEN OUR CLIENTS.
IT'S NOT EASY. 7% MIGHT NOT SEEM
A LOT TO YOU GUYS.
I'M SIXTY FOUR YEARS OLD.
THE FIRST TIME I STARTED WITH I
YOU JUST SAY IF I WAS.
TWENTY THREE I CENTERS ON THE
COLLEGE.
AND I WON'T BREAK A LITTLE BIT
HARVARD GRAY [inaudible]
PHD.
OKAY THAT WAS FORTY YEARS AGO.
AND WE'RE STILL FIGHTING THE
SAME BATTLES.
IT'S A WIN WIN IF NOT NOW WE
NGUYEN IF NOT NOW THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
EVERYBODY I'M PHYLLIS HOFFMAN.
SEIU TWENTY FIFTEEN LAKE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA.
I TAKE CARE OF MY MOTHER.
AND I USED TO TAKE CARE OF A
LADY WHO HAD A STROKE.
WHO WAS A HUNDRED YEARS OLD?
SHE MAY HAVE BEEN.
IN A WHEELCHAIR.
SHE MAY HAVE HAD TO BE LIFTED
WITH THE WHOLE OIL LEFT.
BUT SHE HAD A MIND.
AND SHE WAS ENERGETIC AND SHE
MADE ME LOVE GOING TO WORK
BECAUSE I NEVER KNEW.
WHAT WE WOULD DO?
IT WAS HARD TO GET HER IN AND
OUT OF BED.
BUT I DID IT BECAUSE I LOVED
GOING TO WORK.
BUT THIS 7%.
THAT YOU CONSTANTLY WANTING.
GIVE US SIR TAKE AWAY.
HURTS EVERYONE.
AND I ASK THAT YOU USE THIS
TRAILER BILL LEGISLATION.
AND KEEP THE 7%.
PERMANENTLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CONNIE BARKER.
I'M A HOME CARE WORKER IN BOTH
IRAN AND SANTA CLARA COUNTIES
AND A C. R. U. TWENTY FIFTEEN
EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER.
AND I JUST WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO REMIND ALL OF US WHAT THIS 7%
CUT REALLY MEANS EVERY YEAR.
OUR CLIENTS IN THIS PROGRAM GET
REASSESSED BY THEIR SOCIAL
WORKERS AND THEIR SOCIAL WORKERS
DECIDE HOW MANY HOURS.
SERVICES THEY NEED TO REMAIN
SAFE AND WHAT THE 7% MEANS THAT
THE MOMENT THEY'VE SIGNED THAT
PAPER HERE THIS IS HOW MUCH YOU
NEED -- BUT
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE 7% ABOUT
AWAY DOES THAT MAKE SENSE.
REALLY I MEAN DOESN'T JUST MAKES
NO SENSE AND THE ONLY REASON IT
CAME IN THE FIRST PLACE WAS TO
DEAL WITH A FISCAL EMERGENCY.
QUITE AWHILE BACK BUT BY LEAVING
IT IN PLACE THIS WAY YOU ALSO DO
SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY NOT
RIGHT.
THE THE EFFECT OF THIS THING IS
THAT ANYTIME THAT THERE IS
ANOTHER WILL SHORTFALL SOMEWHERE
THERE'S ANOTHER EMERGENCY GUESS
WHO IS DE FACTO ON THE CHOPPING
BLOCK.
IT'S OUR CLIENTS IN OUR WAGES
IT'S THEIR HEALTH AND OUR
LIVELIHOOD BECAUSE NOBODY HAS TO
CUT ANYTHING ALL YOU HAVE TO DO
IS DO NOTHING AND IT JUST
AUTOMATICALLY GOES AWAY.
WHICH MEANS THAT THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO PAY FIRST FREDDIE
PROBLEM THAT THE STATE HAS AND
THESE ARE NOT THE PEOPLE WHO
SHOULD BE DOING THAT IT'S WRONG
AND THAT'S WHY YOU NEED TO
ELIMINATE IT.
PERMANENTLY [inaudible]
HELLO EVERYBODY.
MY NAME IS DOUG ALREADY.
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO.
AT THE CORE OF MY SON.
AND I'M HERE TO PLEAD THEIR
BODIES 7% [inaudible]
BACK BECAUSE WITH THE 7%.
WHO WOULD BE EASIER EASIER FOR
THE MY DEATH? TO BE DEBT TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN FOR THE CHILDREN
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA BECOME VERY
EXPENSIVE.
AND THEY LIVE IN BECOME SO HOT
THAT.
YOU HAVE TO GO OUT TO WALK.
INSTEAD OF YOU WILL BE THERE FOR
YOUR CHILD ALL THE TIME BECAUSE
FOR EXAMPLE MY SON GOES TO
SCHOOL.
FROM EIGHT THIRTY TO THREE
THAT'S FIVE HOURS.
SO THE REST OF THE HOURS ARE
MINE.
AND WE'VE.
SEVEN I CAN GO TO WALK BY
SOMETIME.
I'M SO MUCH UNDER PRESSURE
BECAUSE WHEN THIS.
THE TRANSPORTATION DEPARTMENT
CALLED ME.
YOU NEED TO COME AND PICK UP
YOUR CHILD BECAUSE WE ALREADY
YEAR.
AND I'M ONE DO ROAD.
IN THE TROPICS LAST TIME I
NEARLY GET INTO IT BY ACCIDENT.
SO BUT IF I HAVE ENOUGH HOURS.
WOULD BE DEAD TWENTY FOUR HOURS
TO TAKE OFF MY JUDGMENT
BAKERSFIELD I THINK HE'S.
WELL ABOVE FOR OTHER MATTERS SO
OTHER PEOPLE WHAT THEY CAN GO
FOR THEIR PARENTS BUT HE'S.
VERY VERY CRITICAL ALSO PLEASE.
WE NEED 27% BACH AND LET IT BE A
PERMANENT [inaudible]
SO.
EVERYTHING CAN BE WELL FOR
EVERYBODY THANK YOU AND GOD
BLESS YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SHE SHY.
I'M CARL JONES PROVIDER AND I
WANT TO SAY THAT --
I NEVER PLANNED ON BEING A
PROVIDER AND LORRAINE NEVER
PLANNED ON HAVING A STROKE BUT
SHE HAD ONE THREE YEARS AGO JUST
ABOUT.
APRIL TWENTY ONE WHICH LEFT HER.
DISABLED UNDER LEFT SIDE AND SO
SHE NEEDS TO HAVE SOMEBODY WITH
THEIR TWENTY FOUR SEVEN AND WE
BOTH.
LEFT GOOD PROFESSIONS.
SO THAT WE COULD WORK ON
REHABILITATING THE RAIN AND
GETTING OR THROUGH EACH DAY.
AND I WANT TO SAY THAT THE
PROGRAM HAS BEEN A GODSEND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT WE DO WITHOUT IT.
NO ONE EVER PLANS ON BEING
DISABLED BUT THERE IS A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OF THE POPULATION
THAT WILL BECOME DISABLED.
YOU NEVER THINK IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN TO YOU BUT IT COULD.
SO PRESERVING THE PROGRAM
PRESERVING THE SEVEN YOU MIGHT
NEED TO PROGRAM SOME DAY
YOURSELF [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY MUST ADDRESS ME NUMBER IS
MARKED THAT FREEZE.
THEY THEY IT ALONE THIS OUR
ACCOUNTING.
MARTHA REEVES UNITED DOMESTIC
WORKERS I HSS PROVIDER SUTTER
COUNTY.
JUST A KEEP IT UP PROVIDED SEAT
THE PERCY AND DON'T.
FORGET BUT I'M ALSO THROWS NOISE
FAST SEATED IS THAT HARMFUL
PERSONAS.
DISCREPANCY DOES.
HE READ MANTECA MUST BE THIS
YEAR PHYLLIS BROKE HIS PERSONA
SKIP ANIMAL PSYCHE.
IN A LIST OF THEM BECUSE
ENCUENTRA BUT FOLLOWED UP FOR
YOU KNOWS HE CAN NOTHING ALMOST
MASS GIVEN NEED A LINE YOU'LL
CAME THROUGH A PORTAL TO SEE IF
THE POOR SANDEL.
WAS THERE IS NO SEVEN ON THE
CITY THAT IS GET THE IN IN A
YOU'LL SEE COMMON ALSO CLOSE
CAMILLUS WITHOUT MOST.
I ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT THE
PERMANENT RESTORATION OF THE 7%
TO THE I JUST AS PROGRAM AS A
PROVIDER.
STANDING HERE IN HEARING THE
TESTIMONIES OF OTHER PROVIDERS
THAT THESE HOURS ARE DETRIMENTAL
TO OUR RECIPIENTS AND SO WE ASK
THAT YOU REALLY TAKE THIS IN
CONSIDERATION AND PERMANENTLY
RESTORING THIS. FOR US PROVIDERS
WHO HAVE TO COME BACK HERE YEAR
AFTER YEAR FOR THE 7%
RESTORATION THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS COLONEL MARKS
AND I AM NOT HSS PROVIDER IN THE
COUNTY OF BUTTE AND I'M ALSO A
MOTHER.
AT THE NICEST SAYS WORKER.
WE BUY DAILY FOR RESPECT AND
DIGNITY.
AS AN AYE CHECKS AS WORKER WILL
PERFORM THE MOST PASSIONATE JOB.
AS A MOTHER I'VE HAD TO MAKE A
SACRIFICE TO REMAIN AT THE EIGHT
OF MY CLIENT.
OR TO BE HOME AT WORK UP TO BE
HOME ON TIME TO SEE IF MY KIDS.
WITH HOMEWORK.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE I WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH --
AT THE RADISSON MUST FIND THE
DOCTOR TOLD ME I SHOULD SHOULD
BE WALKING STANDING STRAIGHT UP.
SO ONE DAY I'M GONNA NEED ONE OF
THESE LADIES SITTING HERE OUR
WHOLE MILK WHO WHOEVER ELSE COME
BEHIND US AS AND I JUST AS
PROVIDER.
SO I WILL BE HERE TO FIGHT.
BUT I JUST AS PROVIDERS TO GET
WHAT THEY NEED.
I'M ASKING THAT YOU RESTORE THE
7% PERMANENTLY.
SO WE THE PEOPLE THE PORTION OF
WE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE AYE CHECKS
AS PROVIDERS.
CAN BY OTHER I'M JUST AND
DISCRIMINATORY ISSUES WE FACE
BECAUSE WE CHOOSE TO BE
CALIFORNIA I CHECKS AS PROVIDERS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SWAN
ASANO AND I'M FROM SANTA CLARA
COUNTY SAN JOSE.
I HAVE BEEN A IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES PROVIDER. FOR SOME TIME
NOW AND I WISH TO CONTINUE.
HELPING PEOPLE.
THE REST OF MY LIFE.
AND I'M ASKING THE STATE TO
SUPPORT PROTECTIONS RELATED TO
EVEY TO ENSURE FLEXIBILITY. FOR
ALL CONSUMERS AND TRAINING FOR
PROVIDERS LIKE ME.
BECAUSE EVERY MINUTE.
IS VERY PRECIOUS FOR BOTH.
THE PEOPLE AND US.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JEFF AT A GREGORY.
I'M GONNA HIATUS SAYS PROVIDER
AND CONTRA COSTA AND ALSO.
ALAMEDA COUNTY I TAKE CARE OF MY
BROTHER HI HE NEEDS TWENTY FOUR
HOUR CARE [inaudible]
AND I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
TWO GUYS --
RESTORED THE 7% [inaudible]
PERMANENTLY.
THANK YOU.
WELL I DIDN'T EXPECT THAT.
SHE ORGAN CUSHMAN I. S..
I. H. S. S. RECIPIENT CAN EVEN
SAY IT STRAIGHT --
I'VE BEEN IN THESE FIGHTS SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY THREE AND MOST
PEOPLE AREN'T IN THEIR JOBS THAT
LONG.
I'M GETTING SICK AND TIRED OF IT --
SO CODIFY THIS RESTORATION OF
OUR LIFE SUPPORT AND SAFETY NET.
THE MORE WE COME BACK HERE THE
MEANER WILL GET BECAUSE WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO BE HERE.
AND EVERY TIME THAT WE GET CUT.
IT RISKS OUR LIVES AND I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT YOU BUT IF I GET IF
SOMETHING HAMMERS ON ME REALLY
HARD I GET MEAN AND I GET NASTY
AND I GET CRANKY.
AND I'LL BET THAT YOU WOULD.
TO AND SO HASH TAG NO MORE CUTS.
HASH TAG NO MORE SORT OF
DAMOCLES.
YES D. O. M. A. C. L. E. S..
SO I'M WITH HAND IN HAND I'M
ALSO WITH OTHER ORGANIZATIONS MY
AGE MY AYE HSS WORKER.
IS NOT A FAMILY MEMBER SHE'S A
PERSON OF COLOR SINGLE MOM TWO
KIDS.
ONE'S GOING INTO COLLEGE.
SHE'S GOT TO SURVIVE AND SO DO I
THANKS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS OF SAYS.
MY NAME IS REBECCA MULLER I'M UP
HERE ADVOCATE WAS SENIOR AND
DISABILITY ACTION.
DUE TO BRAIN SURGERY I HAVE WHEN
I WAS TWELVE I ALSO HAVE SEVERAL
PHYSICAL.
DISABILITIES.
I BELIEVE THAT.
IN HOME SUPPORT SERVICES.
IS A FUNDAMENTAL PROGRAMS TO
KEEP OUR SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
AT HOME PLEASE RESTORE.
THE 70% CUTS PERMANENTLY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GET.
THAT CONCLUDES --
PUBLIC COMMENT.
I DO WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
APPEARANCE AND TO THANK.
OUR S. YEAH YOU AND YOU D. W.
MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE.
I THINK YOUR YOUR PRESENCE IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT YOUR
ADVOCATING NOT JUST FOR
YOURSELVES BUT FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT YOU'RE SERVING.
BUT YOU KNOW OFTENTIMES DON'T
HAVE A VOICE SITE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE AND BEING
THEIR VOICE.
WE KNOW THAT THE RESTORATION
FUNDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
REMOS FEAR FOR AYE HSS PROVIDERS
AND CONSUMERS THAT THEY WILL
LOSE VITAL HOURS OF PERSONAL
CARE SERVICES.
I THINK THE ONE WITNESS WHO
TALKED ABOUT.
WHO JUST LAID IT OUT JUST
PERFECTLY SOMEBODY IS ALREADY
EVALUATED DETERMINE HOW MANY
HOURS ARE NEEDED?
SO THAT YOU CAN LIVE WITH
DIGNITY AND THEN UNDER THE LAW
SAID 7% IS CUT.
AND YES AS ALL OF YOU SAID
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO REMOVE 7% OF
THE SERVICE YOU'RE PROVIDING TO
SOMEONE THAT YOU CARE ABOUT.
THE TO PROVIDING SERVICE.
TO BUT YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE TO DO
IT FOR FREE.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE THAT WE
DO WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE AT THIS
POINT -- I
WOULD LIKE TO OPEN IT UP TO MY
MEMBERS FOR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
MS RUBIO.
HE WAS FIRST BUT I WAS GOING TO
MOVE THE ITEM FOR FOR THE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT MISTER MATHIS.
HAS MOVED THE ITEM.
SO THE MOTION IS NOW SECOND THAT.
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO ADOPT A PLACE
HOLDER TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT REMOVES STATUTORY REFERENCE
TO THE 7% OUR REDUCTION FOR I.
H. I. H. SS IS SUCH A MOTION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU KNOW YOU HAD A
QUESTION NO JUST A COMMENT ON
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR FOR COMING
HERE -- I
KNOW IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR
SOME OF YOU --
TO GET ALL THE WAY DOWN. TO THE
STATE CAPITOL SIDE REALLY IS
APPRECIATED AND THANK YOU FRED
AND AGAIN I AS A SOMETHING WOMAN --
STATED YOU'RE NOT ADVOCATING
JUST FOR YOURSELF TO ADVOCATING
FOR FOR PATIENTS AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU MS REVIEW MISTER RAMOS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND AND
YES I ECHO THOSE SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES AS FAR AS COMING HERE
AND AND SHOWING --
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS IS ACTION
AND GETTING IT BACK TO WHERE
WE'RE AT AND WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE WITH THIS TRAILER
BILL BUT ALSO BRINGING UP THE
TOPIC OF PERMANENT --
THE MONEY'S GOING INTO THIS AREA
NOT HAVING TO COME BACK I KNOW
SOME IT'S BEEN VITAL ESPECIALLY
IN SAN MARINO COUNTY WHICH WE'VE
BEEN.
INTIMATELY ENGAGED IN THIS ISSUE
HAS SEEN THE WORK THAT'S BEING
DONE SO KNOW THAT YOUR WORK
ISN'T BEING DONE WITHOUT PEOPLE
SEEING THE HARD WORK THAT YOU DO.
AND I WOULD HAPPILY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER RAMOS.
WELL AGAIN I DO WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR FOR WHAT TO FOR
COMING IN TO PROVIDE THIS
TESTIMONY I THINK THAT --
IN THEDISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS I KNOW THE S. YEAH
YOU AND YOUR D. W. WILL BE
INVOLVED IN THAT.
IN THE VERY SPECIFIC LANGUAGE WE
DON'T WANT YOU TO HAVE TO COME
BACK EVERY YEAR --
IF THERE IS A CHANGE IT SHOULD
BE SOMETHING THAT IS ANNOUNCED
LATER AND THEN WE COME BACK BUT
IT SHOULD BE.
JUST AS YOU HAVE REQUESTED AND
THAT IS CLEARLY WHAT --
BY THE MOTION AND BY THE SECOND
THIS IS WHAT WE WANT TO SEE DONE
WE DON'T WANT YOU TO HAVE TO
COME UP HERE EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
THIS IS.
THIS IS UNFAIR.
ALL RIGHT WOULD YOU PLEASE TAKE
THE ROLE.
MISS REYES HI MISTER FRAZIER.
NO VOTING MR MATHIS BY.
SAMANTHA SIGN MISTER PATTERSON.
MISTER PATTERSON NINE MISTER
RAMOS.
MR ALMOST SIGN MISS RUBIO.
MISS RUBIO I DOCTOR WOULD.
WE HAVE.
FIVE THE MOTION PASSES.
THIS IS STEP.
ONE BUT IT'S AN IMPORTANT STEP
AND PLEASE KNOW THAT IT HAPPENS
BECAUSE OF ALL OF YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT PANEL IS NO.
YOU ARE EXCUSED UNLESS YOU'RE ON
THE NEXT PANEL.
SO IS YOUR NUMBER TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL ON
CHANGES THROUGHOUT THE AYE HSS
COUNTY MAINTENANCE OF EFFORTS
THE M. O. U. M. O. E..
TRAILER BRITT TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE PROPOSAL AND ASSOCIATED
ADVOCACY PROPOSALS.
WITH THE PANELISTS PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
AND IF WE COULD TAKE YOU IN THE
ORDER IN WHICH THEY YOU ALL ARE
LISTED.
PAT LEERING SYDNEY TOWN EMOTO.
JACQUI PAROCHIAL.
BELLY OUT RAMOS.
CRISTINA BASS HAMILTON
[inaudible]
TIFFANY WHITEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR PROBABLY
REACTING DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES AND I THINK I'M
JUST GOING TO PASS IT QUICKLY TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
SITTING TAMAKO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE AGENDA DOES A NICE
JOB OF OUTLINING THE I IT JUST
SAYS MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE PROPOSAL.
THAN HAPPY TO PROVIDE A HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW AS IT PERTAINS TO
AYE HSS.
AS A RESULT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES SB NINETY NINETEEN
NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT REPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO REPLACE
THE STATE WHY COUNTY I HSS
MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT AND TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY FROM TWO BILLION
TO APPROXIMATELY. ONE POINT FIVE
SIX BILLION A REDUCTION OF FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION.
THE REVISED MOE REFLECTS THE
PROJECTED LEVEL OF COUNTIES I IT
JUST ASK COSTS THAT CAN BE
FUNDED WITH THE NINETEEN NINETY
ONE REALIGNMENT AND THE BUDGET
YEAR.
THE BUDGET ALSO PROPOSES TO
REDUCE THE ANNUAL AND THOUGH WE
INFLATION FACTOR FROM 7% 24%
BEGAN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND ELIMINATE THAT ARE OFTEN
MEDICATION.
THANK YOU AND HAVE BEEN
ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
AS THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
OUTLINED THEIR SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO I'D JUST SAYS --
THESE ARE THE MORE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES BEING PROPOSED IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT
BROADLY --
OUR OFFICE IN OCTOBER WE DID A
REPORT IN WHICH WE LOOKED AT
NINETEEN NINETY ONE REALIGNMENTS
TO ASSESS WHETHER IT'S MEETING
CERTAIN CORE PRINCIPLES FOR ANY
REALIGNMENT AND WE REACH SUMMER
CONCLUSIONS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE DID IN THEIR JANUARY
REPORT THAT THERE IS A
MISALIGNMENT TODAY.
MAINLY WORK AND REGARDING
REVENUE WHEN IT COMES TO I JUST
US BUT ALSO COUNTY COST AND I
JUST AS REFLECTING THEIR ABILITY
TO CONTROL THOSE COSTS --
SO WE SEE THAT THE PROPOSED
CHANGES TO THE IHS US COUNTY
COSTS IS A MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO MEETING THESE CORE
PRINCIPLES.
BUT TWO THINGS WE DID FLAG IN
OUR REPORT --
ONE THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE WE RECOMMEND
THAT THROUGH THE ANNUAL BUDGET
YEAR PROCESS JUST MONITORING
REVENUES TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
COVERING COST OVER TIME BUT ALSO.
BY REDUCING I JUST AS COUNTY
COST THAT THEN SHIFTS I HIGHER
SHARE OF COSTS TO THE STATE
WHILE THIS IS APPROPRIATE THIS
DOES BRING UP QUESTIONS FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION AROUND.
HOW ARE WE PLANNING FOR THE
AGING POPULATION POTENTIAL COST
PRESSURES ON RIGHTEOUS AS BUT
ALSO MORE BROADLY --
AGAIN THE AGING POPULATION IN
THE STATE BUDGET [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR GOMEZ REYES
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS BELLA RAMOS AND IT IS A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF.
OF ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES OF
THE GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
ARE THANKFUL FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
INCREASE IN THE STATE GENERAL
FUND COMMITMENT TO AYE HSS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE TO THE GOVERNOR AND
THE LEGISLATURE FOR ADDRESSING
THIS ISSUE.
TO BRING UP CLOSE TO THIS GAP
THAT IS LOOMING OVER EVERY
SINGLE COUNTY AND OUR STATE.
WE'RE PROUD TO PARTNER WITH THE
STATE TO ADMINISTER THIS FEDERAL
ENTITLEMENT WHICH HAS NO CAP
WHICH AS YOU HEARD EARLIER FROM
PUBLIC TESTIMONY WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO BE ABLE TO SERVE
THESE HALF MILLION SENIORS AND
DISABLED INDIVIDUALS.
SO THAT THEY MAY AGE WITH
DIGNITY IN PLACE AT HOME.
CURRENTLY COSTS ARE HIGHER THAN
THE REVENUES ANTICIPATED FROM
REALIGNMENT REVENUES.
WE ARE HAVING TO RE DIRECT FUNDS
FROM VERY VITAL PUBLIC AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AT OUR
COUNTIES TO BE ABLE TO SHOULDER
THE COST FOR THOSE COUNTY.
THE COUNTY ADDITIONAL AYE HSS
COST SHARE THIS IS SIMPLY NOT
SUSTAINABLE FOR YOUR FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES NOR IS IT SUSTAINABLE
FOR THE INDIVIDUALS THAT WE
SERVE.
UNDER THIS VERY VITAL PROGRAM
PUZZLE SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASES
THIS COMMITMENT FROM THE GENERAL
FUND BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AND TO AND INTO TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY AND WHAT IT
REALLY DOES IS IT PROVIDES IS
THAT FINANCIAL SUSTAINABILITY TO
BE ABLE. TO NEGOTIATE THESE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENTS
TO BE ABLE TOMOVE FORWARD AND
WHILE THERE ISN'T A COP IT
CERTAINLY PROVIDES AS THE FISCAL
CERTAINTY THAT WE NEED TO ALL OF
US TO BE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD
WHETHER IT'S ON THE COUNTY SIDE
OR ON THE BARGAINING SIDE.
BY LOWERING THE MOE BASED AND
REDUCING THE ANNUAL INFLATION
FACTOR FROM 724% WE SEE A
RECOGNITION OF THE TWO GREATEST
FACTORS THAT ARE DRIVING THE
SITE JUST ASK COSTS ONE IS THE
STATE MINIMUM WAGE.
AND THE OTHER IS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF FEDERAL
OVERTIME RULES.
BOTH OF THESE ARE OUTSIDE OF THE
CONTROL OF EACH OF YOUR FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES.
THESE REALIGNMENT REVENUES
SIMPLY ARE NOT ENOUGH WITHOUT
THIS PROPOSAL IN PLACE.
REDUCING THE INFLATION FACTOR
24% IS ESSENTIAL TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE STRUCTURAL
SUSTAINABILITY IS FOR COUNTIES
TO MOVE FORWARD.
THAT ALIGNS ITSELF WITH
HISTORICAL REALIGNMENT REVENUE
GROWTH AND IS IN THE BALLPARK OF
THE ANNUAL PROGRAM CASE LOAD
GROWTH.
THIS ENSURES THAT WE CAN PLACE
VITAL DOLLARS FOR PUBLIC AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES RESTORING
THOSE SERVICES TO ALL OF OUR
RESIDENTS.
THIS PROPOSAL WHILE IT DOES NOT
ELIMINATE THE RISK OF
REALIGNMENT
AND IT DOES NOT PROVIDE A CAP IT
CERTAINLY DOES PROVIDE AN
IMPROVED OUTLOOK FOR THOSE
CRITICAL SOCIAL SERVICES HEALTH
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS FOR THE
RESIDENTS WE SERVE AND
HSS SUPPORT SERVICE PROGRAMS TO
ALLOW THEM. TO AGE WITH DIGNITY
AND PLACE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO PARTNER WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. TO PROVIDE WHAT
NECESSARY TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
IS NECESSARY AND TO ENSURE THE
AYE HSS A SUSTAINABLE INTO THE
FUTURE THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AGAIN
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA BOSS
HAMILTON I'M HERE.
REPRESENTING YOU W. ASKED ME.
WE REPRESENT A HUNDRED TEN
THOUSAND I JUST US WORKERS IN
TWENTY ONE COUNTIES.
I THINK ALL OF US IN THIS ROOM
COULD AGREE THAT I HSS IS A
LIFESAVING CRITICAL PROGRAM FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE HERE OUT OF DESPERATION
BECAUSE WHAT WE HAVE IN AYE HSS
IS THE WORK FORCE.
PROBLEM WE CANNOT HIRE ANOTHER
FOR WORKERS TO DO THIS JOB
BECAUSE IT PAYS VERY VERY LITTLE.
SPECIFICALLY WHAT WE ARE
PROPOSING IS THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
TO ADD ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT TO OFFSET COUNTY COSTS
THAT IT BE DIRECTLY RELATED TO
THE ABILITY OF A COUNTY TO REACH
A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT WITH ITS WORKERS.
WE HAVE BEEN TO THIS BUDGET CAN
TIMES IN THE LAST FIVE TO TEN
YEARS TO DISCUSS THE PROBLEMS
THAT WE HAVE HAD WITH LOCAL
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AND OUR
INABILITY TO GET RESOLUTION AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY FORCES US TO COME TO
THE STATE. TO SEEK INTERVENTION
THIS IS A PUBLIC POLICY ISSUE
THAT THE STATE MUST INTERVENE ON
BECAUSE WE SIMPLY CAN'T AFFORD
TO KEEP PAYING THESE WORKERS.
MINIMUM WAGE WHEN THEY CAN GO
AND WORK IN FAST FOOD AND GET
PAID MORE AND GET HEALTH
BENEFITS.
I PASSED --
I ASKED THE SERGEANT TO PASS OUT
A CHART.
YOU YOU SHOULD HOPEFULLY HAVE IT
IN FRONT OF YOU IT LISTS ARE
TWENTY ONE COUNTIES.
JUST TO GIVE YOU A REALLY QUICK
SNAPSHOT THE COUNTIES THAT ARE
IN YELLOW ARE ALL OPEN CONTRACTS.
THAT MEANS OUT OF THE TWENTY ONE
COUNTIES ONLY SEVEN HAVE
AGREEMENTS IN PLACE RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE COLUMN THAT
SAYS TIME SINCE EXPIRATION THAT
IS THE AMOUNT OF TIME SINCE THE
LAST CONTRACT EXPIRES THE
AVERAGE TIME IS THIRTY FIVE
MONTHS.
THAT MEANS THE AVERAGE CONTRACT
HAS BEEN OPEN FOR ALMOST THREE
YEARS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE GREEN.
THE GREEN ARE THE ONLY COUNTIES
THAT EVEN PAY ABOVE THE MINIMUM
WAGE AND RIGHT NOW.
YOU CAN SEE THERE'S ONLY SEVEN
THAT PAY ABOVE THE MINIMUM WAGE.
THAT IS A DISGRACE.
SO WE ARE ASKING THE STATE IS
THAT BEFORE THE SAVINGS THAT YOU
ARE PROPOSING WHICH ARE IN
GENERAL A REALLY GOOD THING.
THAT IT BE LINKED TO THE ABILITY
OF A COUNTY TO BARGAIN CONTRACTS
WE HAVE BEEN TO THIS BODY BEFORE.
AND TO GIVE YOU REALLY QUICK
TIMELINE GOING BACK TO TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN WE PETITIONED
THE STATE TO APPLY FOR COMMUNITY
FIRST CHOICE OPTION EXTRA
FEDERAL FUNDING WHICH INCREASE
THE FEDERAL OF PORTION THAT PAY
TOWARD I JUST SAYS.
THAT RESULTED IN A REFUND TO ALL
THE COUNTIES FOR THE AMOUNT THAT
THEY HAD EXPENDED ON THE PROGRAM
WE HAD DONE THAT IN ORDER.
TO REDUCE COSTS AND HAVE THAT
MONEY BE PUT BACK INTO I JUST AS
WAGES AND THAT IDN'T HAPPEN.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU THAT THE
COLUMN AS LAST NEGOTIATED WAGE
INCREASE YOU CAN SEE THAT THAT'S
THE THOSE ARE THE DATES OF THE
LAST TIME THAT.
COUNTIES AGREED TO INCREASE
WAGES AS YOU CAN SEE THE AVERAGE
THERE'S ABOUT FOUR YEARS THAT
MEANS THAT THESE WAGES ARE ONLY
INCREASING BECAUSE THE MINIMUM
WAGE IS INCREASING.
AND UNLESS WERE ABLE TO RESOLVE
THIS LOCALLY IT WILL BRING US
BACK TO THE STATE AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
FOR RESOLUTION.
IT IN THE WHEN YOU OF AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT WAS PASSED AND MEDICAID
EXPANSION HAPPENED.
THE ONLY WAY WE WERE ABLE TO GET
WAGE INCREASES AT THAT TIME WAS
BECAUSE WE AGREE TO SHIP THE
DOLLARS AND CENTS THAT WERE
BEING PUT INTO HEALTH BENEFITS.
TO ADD THAT TO WAGES BECAUSE ALL
THOSE WORKERS QUALIFY FOR MEDI
CAL.
AND SO THERE WAS NO NET COST TO
THAT BUT IT WAS THE ONLY WAY TO
SEE ANY DOLLAR AND SENT INCREASE
FOR THESE WORKERS.
IN TWENTY TWELVE WHEN THE MO YOU
WAS PASSED THAT ESSENTIALLY
RENDERED COUNTIES OF A NEUTRAL
FOR ANY OTHER COSTS IN THE
PROGRAM ASIDE FOR THE GROWTH
FACTOR.
IN FOR WHATEVER THEY BARGAINED
IN CONTRACTS THAT RESULTED IN
NOTHING THAT RESULTED IN NO NAY
INCREASES EXCEPT FOR A FEW OF
THE GOOD COUNTIES THAT HAVE BEEN
DOING THEIR DUE DILIGENCE.
AND THEN FINALLY IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE HELP TO PASS AS
BEING NINETY WHICH INCLUDED
OTHER INCENTIVES FOR BARGAINING
SUCH AS MANDATORY MEDIATION.
BECAUSE THAT WAS NOT BINDING.
THERE WAS NO WAY FOR US TO GET
THE COUNTY TO ADOPT WHATEVER IT
WAS THAT A MEDIATOR WOULD AGREE
TO OR WOULD RECOMMEND AS AS
BEING A NEUTRAL.
OF RESOLUTION.
AND FINALLY WE ASK FOR
XCELERATED A CASE LOAD GROWTH
FUNDS TO BE SO THAT WHATEVER
THAT MONIES THAT WERE OUTWEIGHED
BY THE COUNTY WILL GET REFUNDED
BACK TO THEM AS QUICK AS
POSSIBLE.
THE REALIGNMENT DOLLARS AND NOT
DIDN'T MAKE A DIFFERENCE EITHER.
SO WE'RE NOT HERE SAYING THAT.
ALL COUNTIES ARE ARE BAD ACTORS
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME THAT
DO THE RIGHT BY THE PROGRAM AND
BELIEVE THAT IT IS A GOOD
PROGRAM TO INVEST IN.
BUT IN OTHER COUNTIES WE SIMPLY
AREN'T SEEING THAT HAPPEN AND SO
WE'RE COMING TO YOU OUT OF
DESPERATION AND ASKING FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TIFFANY WHITEN WITH AT THE ARE
YOU CALIFORNIA I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND I'D JUST AS
PROVIDERS IN THIRTY SEVEN
COUNTIES I WOULD LIKE TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUE --
AT UT W..
THERE'S TWENTY THREE OF OUR
THIRTY SEVEN COUNTIES THAT DO
NOT HAVE A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT.
SAMBAR NAY DINO HAS NOT HAD A
BARGAINING AGREEMENT SINCE
TWENTY FOURTEEN FRESNO SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN HUMBOLDT
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN
LASSEN COUNTY HAS NEVER HAD A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT --
CRISTINA MENTIONED MANDATORY
MEDIATION LASSEN WENT TO
MANDATORY MEDIATION THE FINDINGS
WERE IN FAVOR OF THE UNION.
LASSEN JUST DOES NOT DO ANYTHING
THEY HAVE NOT INCORPORATED
ANYTHING THEY HAVE NOT MOVE
FORWARD ON ANYTHING AND TO THIS
DAY WE HAVE NEVER HAD A CONTRACT
IN LASSEN COUNTY.
THAT'S THAT'S NOT OKAY --
THIS WILL NOT HAPPEN IN ANY LINE
OF WORK IF YOU WERE STATE
EMPLOYEES THERE WOULD BE OUTRAGE
IF.
A HOSPITAL DID NOT HAVE A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
THERE WOULD BE OUTRAGE IF I JUST
AS PROVIDERS DO NOT HAVE A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
NOBODY BATS AN EYE.
THAT'S NOT OKAY THERE'S NO
RECOURSE THERE'S NO BINDING
ARBITRATION SIMILAR TO A PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICIALS ARE PROVIDERS
CAN'T STRIKE NOR WHAT THEY WANT
TO STRIKE BECAUSE THEY LOVE THE
WORK THAT THEY DO.
SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE AND
THERE NEEDS TO BE ACCOUNTABILITY.
NOT HAVING A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT IS A
DISMISSAL OF I IT JUST AS
PROVIDERS IT IS THE DISMISSAL OF
THE CLIENTS THAT THEY SERVE AND
IT'S A DISMISSAL OF THE PROGRAM
AS A WHOLE.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY WITH
THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU AND WE
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THEY'RE CLAPPING --
OUR FIRST PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS PAUL YOUR
SHUTTER INTO A ON BEHALF OF
MISSY NO PLASTER SAN JOAQUIN
FRESNO KERN AND SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY IS.
VERY MUCH IN FAVOR OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO REDUCE
THEM A WEEK --
FOR THE COUNTY STATEWIDE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU A GOOD MANAGER MEMBERS
TOM RENT FREE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
ARE WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S --
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR ALL OF THE
REASONS ARTICULATED BY C. SACK
FIGURE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER REPRESENTED THE COUNTY
ALAMEDA AND WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND THANK HIM.
AND HIS ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
WORK ON THIS OF THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FRANK
MECCA WITH THE COUNTY WILL FOR
DIRECTORS ARE --
MEMBERS ADMINISTER THE ACCESS
PROGRAM ON YOUR BEHALF --
WITH GRATITUDE WE'RE HERE TO
REQUEST YOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU --
NOW I CAN SEE TIFFANY.
GET ALLOW YOUR THEIR GOOD
AFTERNOON --
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS FLORENCE
CLOSE IN.
I AM A HOME CARE PROVIDER FOR
AYE HSS IN MERCED COUNTY.
MY CLOSE ENOUGH [inaudible]
AND MERCED COUNTY HAVEN'T HAD A
COLLECTIVE --
BARGAINING AGREEMENT IN PLACE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN
AND MINIMUM WAGE IS NOT.
A LIVABLE WAGE.
SO I WOULD LIKE YOU TO SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL.
THE EMOJIS.
I'M FOR ONLY COUNTIES THAT HAVE
BARGAINING --
AGREEMENTS IN PLACE.
AND IN GOOD FAITH AND TO MAKE
THEIR COUNTIES ACCOUNTABLE AND
NOT GIVE THEM A A BREAK BECAUSE
THEY'RE OF NOT BARGAINING IN
GOOD FAITH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TO
MURATSUCHI CAMERA I'M AN IN HOME
CARE PROVIDER I'M ALSO AN
EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER WITH SEIU.
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND A BARGAINING
COMMITTEE MEMBER FOR THE FOR
ALAMEDA COUNTY --
I WOULD LIKE --
TO I WOULD LIKE THE THE BOARD TO
ADOPT THE GOVERNOR'S --
SUGGESTION --
TO FOR THE MOA FOR ALL COUNTIES
HOWEVER I ASKED THAT --
THAT.
WE TIE --
BARGAINING TO THE TO THIS SO
THAT COUNTIES WHO DO NOT HAVE A
CURRENT AGREEMENT WITH WORKERS I
JUST THIS PROVIDERS.
ARE NOT GRANTED THAT REDUCTION
SO THAT --
THAT WAY --
THOSE COUNTIES WILL HAVE A LARGE
AND AND GET HOME CARE WORKERS
ABOVE MINIMUM WAGE I TAKE CARE
OF MY MY EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD SON
WHO HAS AUTISM.
AND IT'S A VERY --
I'M HIS PRIMARY PROVIDER RIGHT
NOW BUT I WOULD LIKE TO DO MORE --
AS AN NOW THAT HE'S AN ADULT SO.
FOR DISABLED PEOPLE IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT ESPECIALLY IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY TO BE ABLE.
TO HIRE PEOPLE WHEN IT'S A LOT
EASIER TO WORK AT MCDONALD'S AND
GET BENEFITS THAN IT IS --
TO BE AT ALL BE A HOME CARE
PROVIDER SO FOR HOME CARE
PROVIDERS WHO ARE MAKING MINIMUM
WAGE -- I
DON'T SEE HOW WITH SUSTAINABLE
FOR OUR STATE HAVING SO MANY
PEOPLE --
AGING INTO.
BEING ENIOR CITIZENS AND ALSO
ARTISTIC CHILDREN WHO ARE NOW
BECOMING ADULTS REQUIRING AYE
HSS.
THEY WILL ALL NEED TO HIRE --
STATE BE A CHAMPION FOR JOB
CREATION AND BY --
BY ADOPTING THIS IN ONLY TYING
IT SO THAT COUNTIES WHO --
HAVE A A BARGAINING AGREEMENT
AND KEEP MINIMUM WAGE KEEP --
HSS.
PROVIDERS ABOVE MINIMUM WAGE
THAT WAY --
I DISABLED SIT ON BROTHERS AND
SISTERS WILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO
HIRE --
QUALIFIED PEOPLE AND AND KEEP
AND RETAIN THEM THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DEVIN ANDERSON ON BEHALF THE SAN
MATEO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AUDREY RETIRED CHECK FROM CREE
STRATEGIES ON WE HAVE A
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S I'D JUST AS
PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
SAY HI WITH MY GLASSES ON CAN
READ WITH MY GLASSES OFF --
I AM MY NAME IS KATHY AND I'M
HOME CARE PROVIDER IN PLASTER
COUNTY --
WHO DOES NOT CURRENTLY HAVE A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING?
AGREEMENT IN PLACE AND PROBABLY
NOT FOR THE PAST THREE YEARS.
AND I'M AND IT AFFECTS ME IN A
WAY THAT I I FEEL LIKE LIKE I'M
NOT BEING RESPECTED FOR THE
VALUE.
OF MY JOB.
BECAUSE I AM NOT JUST A DOMESTIC
WORKER I AM A TRANSPORTER I AM
AND MEDICAL CARE ADVOCATE FOR MY
SON SITTING OVER THERE PLAYING
ON THE PHONE --
AND AND IS SO I MY JOB I
CONSIDER MYSELF A PROFESSIONAL I
HAVE MANY CERTIFICATES TO SAY SO.
SO --
BECAUSE I I TAKE TRAINING SO
THAT I SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO
REDUCE THE COUNTY MOE IN PLASTER
COUNTY UNTIL THEY DECIDE TO SIT
WITH US AT THE TABLE AND GIVE US
A AN AGREEMENT.
NO CONTRACT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JOYCE DALE AND I
AM AND I JUST AS HOME CARE
PROVIDER AS WELL AS A MEMBER OF
OUR OF BARGAINING COMMITTEE FOR
MERCED COUNTY --
AND CURRENTLY WE ARE.
WE DO HAVE WE DO NOT HAVE A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
AND I DO SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO
REDUCE.
THE COUNTY MOE ONLY AND COUNTIES
THAT DO HAVE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS IN PLACE.
THANK YOU.
NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AN ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S AYE HSS MOE
PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
ENTER LANGLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTIES OF SAN DIEGO MORAN AND
CONTRA CUSTOMER SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LAURIE SCHRADER AND
I'M AND I JUST AS PROVIDER I
DON'T PROVIDE FOR FAMILY MEMBERS
LIKE.
PROVIDE FOR OTHER CLIENTS I'M
ALSO SEIU LOCAL TWENTY FIFTEEN
I'M VERY PROUD TO BE IN THAT
UNION.
SINCE WHEN DID WE REWARD BAD
BEHAVIOR.
THESE BORDERS SUPERVISOR MEMBERS
THAT ARE NOT BARGAINING IN GOOD
FAITH REFUSED TO COME TO THE
TABLE REFUSED TO ACT UPON
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE GIVEN TO
THEM BY MEDIATORS ETCETERA.
THEY'RE NOT DOING A GOOD JOB
THEY'RE NOT ACTING IN A IN A
GOOD FAITH MANNER SO WE SHOULD
REWARD THEIR BAD BEHAVIOR WE
NEED TO START.
GIVING PEOPLE THAT DO THIS LINE
OF WORK AND ITS MANY JOBS THAT
WE TAKE ON THAT WE GIVE THEM
WERE THE RESPECT THAT HAS TO DO
ALL OF US.
I WOULD NOT EVER WORK FOR A
COMPANY.
THAT'S WHAT I'M DOING NOW.
ON MY QUEST TO BECOME A MUCH
BETTER.
INDIVIDUAL A BETTER CITIZEN FOR
OUR COMMUNITY I DECIDED TO
RETIRE FROM MY OTHER JOB AND DO
THIS AND IT'S GOING TO BE A
FIGHT I THINK.
EL IT SHOULDN'T BE THAT WAY WE
NEED TO REWARD PEOPLE FOR DOING
GOOD.
AND WE NEED TO PUNISH THOSE
THEY'RE DOING THAT SO I APPLAUD
THEM AWAY BUT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE COUNTIES ARE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
AND STOP GIVING THEM REWARDS FOR
THEIR BAD BEHAVIOR THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA THE
ROLE COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA THE COUNTY.
HEALTH EXECUTIVES OF CALIFORNIA
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS AND THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF COLUSA.
SANTA CLARA SANTA CRUZ AND THE
TRI COUNTIES HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S HSS EMILY
PROPOSAL AND JUST LIKE TO REMIND
THE COMMITTEE HOW IMPORTANT
HEALTH REALIGNMENT FUNDS ARE
BOTH FOR A PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AS A SOURCE.
OF NON FEDERAL SHARE FOR THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
AB SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES FOR IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES HERE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S.
HSS AMMO YOU PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SUSAN DAILY I AM
AN HSS PROVIDER.
IN GLENN COUNTY AND SUPPORTING
THE GOVERNOR'S MOE.
OF PROPOSAL.
I TAKE CARE OF NOT ONLY MY
FATHER IF IT ANOTHER MOTHER THAT
IS MY SAME AGE SO THAT SHE CAN
TAKE CARE OF HER CHILDREN
[inaudible]
AND IT.
IT'S NOT A GLAMOROUS WAGE IT'S
NOT -- WE
HAVE TO STRESS OVER HOW WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE THE THE BILLS.
THAT WE DO IT OUT OF LOVE FOR
OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS AS YOU'VE
HEARD EVERYBODY HIS TESTIFIED.
SO WE SUPPORT THIS.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S KURT YEP THOSE
FROM -- VIEW
COUNTY.
THIRTY NINE THIRTY LIKE ANY
OTHER FEDERAL STATE COUNTY
WORKERS FIRE TEACHER OR POLICE
WE ALSO NEED THE STABILITY AND
SUPPORT OF A WELL EARNED LIVABLE
WAGE.
THAT WOULD STILL SAVE CALIFORNIA
THE COST OF TAKING THE JOB.
UPON THE STATE WHICH WOULD
PROBABLY GO TO PRIVATE
CORPORATIONS LIKE TO PRISONS.
YOU KNOW IF NOT NOW WHEN.
WHAT IS A SELF RATIONALIZATION
SELF JUSTIFICATION?
IS PENNY WISE POUND FOOLISH.
IF NOT NOW WHEN.
OUR LIVES SHOULD NOT BE A BEAN
COUNTERS WET DREAM.
DON'T JUST BE --
ON A COMMITTEE READER OR READER
OR WE GO TO A FEW AYE HSS
CLIENTS AND HOSPICES YOU SEE AND
HEAR IN PERSON.
WHAT IS REALLY LIGHT?
AND WHAT'S WITH --
LASSEN COUNTY GOING LIKE THIS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
LINDSAY EMI HONG I'M THE
CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR FOR HAND IN
HAND THE DOMESTIC EMPLOYERS
NETWORK.
WE INCLUDE EMPLOYERS OF NANNY'S
HOUSE CLEANERS AND HOME CARE
WORKERS IN SUPPORT OF THE RIGHTS
AND THE DIGNITY OF BOTH THE
WORKER AND THE EMPLOYER SLASH
CONSUMER.
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS ARE AYE HSS
CONSUMERS AND MANY OF THEM ARE
IN THE BAY AREA.
AND AS YOU KNOW THE COST OF
LIVING THEY ARE JUST AS UP.
AND MANY STRUGGLE TO BE ABLE --
TO FIND I JUST AS PROVIDERS WHO
CAN LIVE.
IN THE SAME CITY.
THAT THEY LIVE IN.
SO IT'S A REAL STRUGGLE AND SO
I'M STANDING HERE TO ADD.
JUST.
BRING SUPPORT TO THE PROPOSAL
THAT BOTH THE MOE --
PROPOSAL IS IS --
IS MADE FULL BUT THAT ALSO IT
GOES JUST TO THE COUNTIES WHERE
THERE IS A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
YOU KNOW WE THINK THAT THE WAGES
FOR I JUST WORK AS WORKERS.
NEEDS TO INCREASE AND IF THIS IS
GONNA BE THE STICK THAT'S NEEDED
TO MAKE IT HAPPEN THEN SO BE IT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MIGHT THE GUERRERO
REPRESENTED LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ON THE AYE HSS MOE.
DEFINITELY SUPPORTED AS WELL
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I WANT TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
PANELISTS --
AND VERY SPECIFICALLY I'D LIKE
TO ASK --
THE ADMINISTRATION'S TO SACK. TO
PLEASE RESPOND TO THE ADVOCATES
PROPOSALS HERE --
WHAT ARE THE CONSIDERATIONS WE
SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT IN
TERMS OF COUNTY IN PROGRAM
IMPACT?
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
WE CERTAINLY DO --
YOU KNOW I THINK WE'RE ALL IN
AGREEMENT ON THE NEED FOR THIS
FISCAL SUSTAINABILITY OF THE
PROGRAM AND FOR THE MOE INFLATOR
TO BE AT 4% --
WHEN IT COMES TO THE TREE
BRINGING THE 7% INFLATOR DOWN
24% I WILL SAY THE FOLLOWING
SINCE JULY TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WHEN THE NEW MARKETING
TOOLS WERE PUT IN PLACE FOR
COUNTIES?
AND FOR YOU D. W. AND SEIU TO
WORK TOGETHER EIGHTEEN
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS HAVE BEEN
REACHED THAT IS THE HIGHEST
AMOUNT OF BARGAINING AGREEMENTS
THAT WE HAVE HAD REACHED DURING
THAT TIME.
AND I WILL SAY THAT THAT DID
OCCUR DURING THE TIME THAT THESE
COUNTIES WERE FACING AS ALL OF
US WERE THESE REALIGNMENTS
SHORTFALLS.
IT IS THIS REDUCED INFLATION
FACTOR THAT IS GOING TO BE THE
RECOGNITION FOR THE COUNTIES
THAT THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF FEDERAL
OVERTIME LAWS.
CAN PROVIDE ASSISTANCE FISCAL
SUSTAINABILITY MOVING FORWARD
WHAT ELSE SAY FROM MYSELF FROM
THE COUNTY OF NAPA WE ARE AN S.
C. I. U. BARGAINING COUNTY.
AND THAT WE HAVE REACHED OUT TO
OUR AYE HSS BARGAINING UNIT A
NUMBER OF TIMES --
AND IT HAS NOT BEEN FOR LACK OF
THE COUNTY TRYING TO TO REACH A
NEW AGREEMENT TO DISCUSS THAT --
FOR WHATEVER REASON AND THEY
THEY HAVEN'T ENGAGED WITH US WE
WILL READ BE REACHING OUT AGAIN --
AS WE DO KNOW THAT IT'S IT'S
DEFINITELY TIME AM I THINK THAT
THESE.
THE BOOK GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
PROVIDES ALL OF US THE FISCAL
SUSTAINABILITY TO MOVE THIS
PROGRAM FORWARD AND CERTAINLY
THE ABILITY TO DO SO.
IN A WAY THAT PROVIDES DIGNITY
NOT JUST TO THE AYE HSS.
SERVICE RECIPIENTS BUT TO THE
WORKERS THEMSELVES SOMETHING
THAT WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THAT
THEY DESERVE THEY DO NEED TO
HAVE THESE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
AGREEMENTS IN PLACE AND REDUCE
LONG WAY TO PROVIDING THAT
FISCAL CERTAINTY TO GET US TO
THAT PLACE.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION.
ACTUALLY --
A MORE SPECIFIC QUESTION CAN THE
ADMINISTRATION RESPOND TO THE
ISSUES TECHNICAL COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING.
AND ANY WAY THAT THE STATE
POLICY CAN BE REVISED TO RESPOND
TO THIS --
STAGNANT SEE.
IN THE ROOM NOT INSURE PITCHER
RECORD WITH THE DEPARTMENT --
I I THINK THERE ARE A COUPLE
DIFFERENT WAYS TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION I MEAN THE FIRST --
AS YOU'VE HEARD ALREADY
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING IN THE I
JUST SAYS PROGRAM IS AN ISSUE
BETWEEN INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES AND
THE REPRESENTATIVE UNION FOR
THAT THOSE COUNTIES --
SO I'M NOT GOING TO OFFER
SPECIFICS OR IN ANYWAY INTRUDE
ON THAT RELATIONSHIP WHAT WHAT I
WILL SAY --
IS THAT THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU --
IS IS ONE POTENTIAL METHOD OF
INCENTIVIZING ACHIEVING AN
AGREEMENT --
THERE ARE PROBABLY OTHER WAYS TO
DO SO AS WELL --
I THINK FROM THE STATE
PERSPECTIVE --
WHAT WE WOULD SAY IS THAT?
OUR GOAL AND THE REASON THAT
THOSE OF US WHO WORK IN THIS
PROGRAM WORK IN A PROGRAM IS
THAT PROTECTING AND SERVING THE
I. H. ASSESS CLIENTS.
PART OF THE JOB OF DOING THAT
DEPENDS ON A STABLE WORK FORCE.
OF PROVIDERS WILLING AND ABLE
AND FAIRLY COMPENSATED TO DO
THAT WORK --
AND CLEARLY ACHIEVING OF
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT --
IT IS PART OF PROVIDING THE
STABLE COMPENSATION.
THAT ENABLES THAT TO HAPPEN SO
WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF OF PEOPLE A
REACHING THOSE AGREEMENTS OF THE
LOCAL LEVEL --
BUT I'M NOT GOING TO PRESENT YOU
WITH POTENTIAL FISCAL OPTIONS
AND WAYS TO INCENTIVIZE THAT.
ALTHOUGH WE'RE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WHEN IT
COMES TO STATE FUNDING DECISIONS.
WELL WHAT ABOUT TWO WHERE THE
PARTY STARTS ON STATEWIDE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AS AN
ALTERNATIVE.
UNDER THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION
AS PART OF THE COORDINATED KAREN
ISSUED IF THERE WAS A STATEWIDE
AUTHORITY CREATED TO DO THAT
BARGAINING FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS I KNOW THEIR ACTUAL
AGREEMENTS WERE ENTERED INTO --
UNDER THE STATE WIDE AUTHORITY
AND THAT STATEWIDE AUTHORITY WAS
THAT AND I WAS SUNSET AND
ELIMINATED --
WITH THE SECESSION.
THE THIS MEDICARE INITIATIVE --
BYE BYE BYE STATUTES SO I I
WOULD TELL YOU THAT IT'S BEEN
TRIED -- AND
AND WASN'T SUCCESSFUL IN THAT
CURRENT LAW CURRENTLY REQUIRES
THAT TO BE A LOCAL COUNTY
DECISION.
IF THAT WERE TO BE RE
IMPLEMENTED LEGISLATIVELY.
WHAT WOULD THE ADMINISTRATION DO
DIFFERENTLY? TO ENSURE THAT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENTS
COULD BE REACHED.
OF FOR THE PROTECTION OF THE
WORKERS AND IN THE END THEY
ALLOW THE THE COUNTIES TO THEN --
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE 4%.
AT THE TIME WE HAD A STATE WIDE
AUTHORITY THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THE BARGAINING LIED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN OR
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES CALLIE CHAR --
I'M NOT FEELING THAT I'M
PARTICULARLY IN A POSITION TO
GIVE YOU ADVICE ON WHAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION WOULD DO OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT TO BE
LEGISLATED.
IF THERE'S CONSIDERATION OF THAT
OBVIOUSLY THE ADMINISTRATION
WOULD WANT TO BE INVOLVED EARLY
IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
THANK YOU.
WOULD ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO
RESPOND.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
THE PILOT TO DO STATEWIDE
BARGAINING WAS I WOULD SAY
ENTERED INTO SOMEWHAT
RELUCTANTLY BY THE PRIOR
GOVERNOR AND IT WAS ONLY IN
SEVEN COUNTIES.
IT WAS A LINK THROUGH TO THE
pWHICH HAD A FAIRLY ROCKY START.
AND FRANKLY TOOK AWHILE TO GET
GOING AND I I THINK WASN'T QUITE
AS SUCCESSFUL AS THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD HOPED IT TO
BE.
SO I THINK THAT THERE'S TWO
THINGS THAT WERE PREDOMINANT FOR
WHY IT WAS NOT SUCCESSFUL
OVERALL.
NUMBER ONE THE COURT NEED TO
KAREN IS I'M BECAME CLEAR WAS
NOT GOING TO YIELD THE STATE
SAVINGS THAT THEY THOUGHT THAT
IT WAS GOING.
TO AND I BELIEVE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ONLY AGREED TO DO
STATEWIDE BARGAINING WITH THE
BELIEF THAT WHATEVER SAVINGS
CAME OUT OF THE CC I WOULD
ACTUALLY BE WHAT THEY USED TO
FUND ANY SORT OF WAGE AND
BENEFIT INCREASE.
AND THEN SECOND TO THAT --
I WOULD SAY IT WAS BECAUSE OF
THE JUST GENERAL INSTABILITY AND
THE FACT THAT THE PER THE LAW
THAT.
CREATED THE STATE WIDE
BARGAINING WHAT WE WERE ABLE TO
BARGAIN OVER WAS ACTUALLY
EXTRAORDINARILY NARROW AND SO
THERE WAS JUST PROBLEMS WITH YOU
KNOW WHAT IT WAS THAT WE COULD
EVEN DISCUSS AT THE TABLE SO.
FRANKLY I WOULDN'T USE THAT AS
AN EXAMPLE WHY IT WOULDN'T BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THE FUTURE I THINK
WITH THE NEW ADMINISTRATION AND
A NEW POLITICAL WILL.
IT WOULD BE A TOTALLY DIFFERENT
SCENARIO AND WE WOULD SUPPORT
THAT A 100% WE JUST HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THE REALITY THAT THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING ANYTIME SOON.
AND SADLY UNTIL IT HAPPENS WERE
WERE OUT WHERE WE'RE AT AND AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY
THANK YOU.
SO ARE MY NOTES CORRECT THAT
W. AND FOURTEEN OF THIRTY SEVEN
S. CI YOU --
COUNTIES DO HAVE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING THE REST DO NOT.
AND I DID GET THE THE PRINT OUT
FOR YOU D. W. I DIDN'T HAVE ONE
FIRST YEAH YOU.
IF THERE IS ONE IT SHOULD BE ALL
FIFTY EIGHT ON ONE DO YOU HAVE
THAT ON THE SECOND PAGE IS JUST
A SMALL COPY OF THE BIG.
THE FRONT PAGE WE WILL GET IT TO
YOU THANK YOU.
LET ME BRING IT TO THE THE
MEMBERS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
MISTER RAMOS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LOOKING AT WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
HERE TODAY AS FAR AS THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL FROM THE GOVERNOR.
IS MONEY FROM THAT PROPOSAL --
COULD BE USED FOR WAGING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
PETE FROM THAT APARTMENT AND I'M
GOING -- TO
TRY TO REITERATE WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE --
CINDY TANIMOTO FROM DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TRIED IT EXPLAINED AS
SHE LAID OUT THE AYE HSS I'M A
WE PROPOSAL.
HE IS SENSUALLY AYE IT JUST SAYS
ADMIN HAS BEEN CARVED OUT AS A
BUDGET ALLOCATION NO LONGER
SUBJECT TO AND I'M A WE
REQUIREMENTS.
AND THE STATE HAS.
BUT WHAT WHAT WE SAY WE'VE
ELIMINATED STATE MITIGATION
FUNDING FOR THE IMPACT OF A
HIGHER AND WE ON COUNTIES WE'VE
DROPPED THE AMMO WE REQUIREMENT
ON COUNTIES --
AND YOU'VE HEARD THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THAT BECAUSE THAT BETTER
ALIGNS THAT AM A WE WITH
AVAILABLE REALIGNMENT --
REVENUES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
THE LOCAL COUNTY BUT WHAT THAT
MEANS IS WHEN THERE'S NO CUT TO
THE PROGRAM TO FILL THE TOTAL
BUDGET.
THERE'S NO SAVINGS FROM OUR
PROPOSAL IN FACT THE STATE IS
PICKING UP SEVERAL HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN COSTS THAT
OTHERWISE IT WOULD HAVE BEEN.
A BURDEN ON COUNTIES IN EXCESS
OF THEIR AVAILABLE REVENUES SO
THERE'S NO SAVINGS BEING CREATED
TO AT THE STATE LEVEL FOR THIS
IN FACT.
IT'S AN ONGOING GENERAL FUND
COMMITMENT TO FULLY MEET THE
COST OF THE I JUST SAYS PROGRAM --
SO I HOPE THAT'S HELPFUL IN
EXPLAINING THERE ARE NO AVINGS
IN THE PROPOSAL THAT COULD BE
USED FOR OTHER PURPOSES.
SO THE PROPOSAL IS JUST
BASICALLY --
TRYING TO CREATE A THE BREAK
EVEN AS FAR AS THE COSTS THAT
ARE OUT THERE NOW.
SO LOOKING AT SOME OF THE AREAS
SHE KNOWS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WE
WENT THROUGH A PERIOD OF WHERE --
WE THOUGHT THAT --
THE STATE WAS GOING TO BE
NEGOTIATED SOME OF THESE THINGS
AND IT DIDN'T HAPPEN NOW IS BACK
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
BUT YOU ALSO SEE WHERE THERE'S
BEEN SOME --
DIFFERENT --
FRACTIONS AS FAR AS TRYING TO
GET CONTRACTS APPROVED AND STILL
NEGOTIATIONS GOING ON AND YOU
SEE --
MINIMUM WAGE YOU SEE SOME OF
THESE THINGS ARE THERE.
AND BRINGING UP SAN MARINO
COUNTY THAT'S BEEN TRYING TO GET --
CLOSURE ON ON AGREEMENT FOR MANY
YEARS AND I THINK IT'S OR FIVE
YEARS.
THAT HAS BEEN THERE AND THE TALK.
AS FAR AS BEING TO BEING ABLE TO
INCREASE THOSE WAGES.
WOULD THAT FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO
COME FROM THE STATE WE'RE
HEARING DIFFERENT SPEAKERS COME
OUT AND TALK ABOUT TIENE SOME OF
THIS --
NEGOTIATIONS TO TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SO IF YOU'RE SAYING
THERE'S NO --
WHERE TO ACTUALLY HAVE AN AN
INCREASE COMING FROM THE MONEY
THAT'S BEING PROPOSED NOW HOW DO
WE GET TO THE POINT TO WHERE WE
CAN START TO DISCUSS?
THE WAGE INCREASES AND FROM THE
STATE COMING DOWN TO THE COUNTY
TO HELP WITH THOSE WAGE
INCREASES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
I'M IN A DEFERRED TO SOME OF THE
OTHER PANEL MEMBERS STATE TO ADD
TO IT TO THAT CONVERSATION AGAIN
THE BARGAINING RELATIONSHIP AS I
COUNTY UNION AND NOT COUNTY
ISSUE DOT FOR THE STATE TO
ADDRESS I I I GET THAT OUT.
WHAT WE BUT THERE'S FUNDING AND
FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS AT THE
STATE COULD ALSO OFFER TO THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT WOULD?
HELP IN SOME OF THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS THAT ARE CONDUCTED
PURELY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF THINGS
LIKE THIS THE STATE COULD
POTENTIALLY OFFER --
OBVIOUSLY USUALLY THE
NEGOTIATION OVER OVER WAGES AND
AND BENEFITS IS IS A FISCAL ONE
LISTEN TO STAKE ASSEMBLY
ALLOCATE GENERAL FUND FOR THAT
PURPOSE.
IT COULD.
DO WHAT THIS PROPOSAL FOR YOU
FROM UT W. AND I SEE I YOU DOES --
WHICH IS KEEP THE COUNTY MO WE
HIRE UNLESS THERE'S A A
BARGAINING AGREEMENT IN PLACE IN
WHICH CASE THE COUNTY YOU WOULD
THEN HAVE A LOWER AND WE AND
MONEY TO PAY FOR IT.
THAT THAT'S ONE POTENTIAL
STRUCTURES WELL I'M RELUCTANT TO
ADVOCATE ANY PARTICULAR SOLUTION
HERE BUT THAT'S ROUGHLY HOW THE
MECHANICS HERE IN IDEAS PRETTY
MUCH.
GETTING A DEPARTMENT FINDS
MISTER TRINKETS RIGHT TO EXTEND
THE IT'S APPROPRIATE THE STATE
WHAT THEY WANT TO USE GENERAL
FUND. FOR JUST PROVIDING --
WAGE INCREASE --
TO TO BE DONE TO BUT WE'RE DOING
IT ON ON ON SIR MACINNES
REWORKED.
PAYING FOR MINIMUM WAGE ALREADY
FOR THOSE FOR COUNTIES OR ARE AT
THE MINIMUM WAGE AT THE MOMENT --
ME BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY
IT'S LIKE THIS PRIORITY RIGHT
RESOURCES ARE FRIDAY REDUCING.
THE MAYBE GOVERNOR HAS ARE VERY --
ROBUST BUDGET INCLUDING A LOT OF
RESOURCES FOR NEW PRIVATE
PROGRAMS AND IT'S APPROPRIATE
AND IN THE DAY SO IT'S IT'S IT'S
JUST.
NOW THAT THE BACK IS THAT THE
BEST WAY TO GO ABOUT WITH THIS.
IF I MAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THAT
WHATEVER THE BAR --
THE COUNTY CHOOSES TO BARGAIN IN
TERMS OF IN A WAGER BENEFIT
AGREEMENT.
THE WAY THAT I JUST AS FUNDING
WORKS IS WHATEVER THE
EXPENDITURE IS SO WHATEVER THE
COST OF THAT WE DO BENEFITING
CREASE IS.
IT'S ACTUALLY MATCHED
OVERWHELMINGLY BY STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDING SO THE ACTUAL
DOLLAR INCREASE THE AMOUNT
COMING OUT OF THE COUNTIES SHARE
IS ONLY SIXTEEN CENTS.
AND THAT'S SIXTEEN CENTS COMES
BACK TO THEM IN THE FORM OF
NINETEEN NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT
SO THAT MAYBE [inaudible]
POINT.
YOU KNOW FIVE CENT ACTUALLY
COMES OUT OF THEIR GENERAL FUND.
SO THERE IS.
ACTUALLY NO REAL REASON WHY
THESE WAGES AND BENEFITS WHAT
WHAT HAPPENS IS WE GET PITTED.
POOR PEOPLE AGAINST POOR PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEN WHAT THEY'LL SAY AS
WELL IF WE PAY YOU.
THEN WE WON'T HAVE ENOUGH
REALIGNMENT DOLLARS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH AND WE WON'T HAVE ENOUGH
FOR CHILD WELFARE AND WE WON'T
HOUND HAVE ENOUGH FOR EVERY
OTHER BUCKET.
THAT FALLS UNDER AYE HSS BECAUSE
LOOK THEN EVERYONE ELSE IS GOING
TO HAVE PROBLEMS WITH WITH
SERVICES THEY'RE NOT RECEIVING.
AND WE REFUSE TO ACCEPT THAT
WE'RE PITTING POOR PEOPLE
AGAINST EACH OTHER FOR PENNIES
PENNIES ON THE DOLLAR THERE'S NO
REAL REASON EXCEPT THAT IT'S A
PHILOSOPHICAL DISAGREEMENT.
WITH WHAT IT IS THAT THESE
WORKERS DO.
AND UNFORTUNATELY SO LONG AS
THESE ARE DECISIONS MADE BY
SUPERVISORS WHO FOR THE MOST
PART DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
FAMILY MEMBER SHOULD GET PAID
FOR TAKING CARE OF FAMILY
MEMBERS BECAUSE LET'S BE REAL
THAT'S WHAT REALLY WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT.
SO LONG AS THAT'S WHO WERE
MAKING THESE AGREEMENTS WITH.
THIS IS WHERE WE'RE AT BECAUSE
IF I WAS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR I
WOULD JUMP AT THE CHANCE THAT
POINT FIVE CENT OF MY INVESTMENT
IS GOING TO YIELD A DOLLAR IN
RETURN.
THAT THEN WILL BE SPENT IN MY
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND IN MY
LOCAL ECONOMY BECAUSE POOR
PEOPLE DON'T PUT IT INTO THEIR
FOUR ONE CASE AND THEY DON'T GO
BUY STOCK OPTIONS.
THEY GO TO THE CORNER STORE BUY
MILK.
AND SO THERE'S NO REASON WHY
THIS IS NOT AN ECONOMICALLY WISE
DECISION TO MAKE.
WE WE WE ARE HERE FOR SOLUTIONS
BECAUSE WE SIMPLY AREN'T ABLE TO
CHEAT THEM LOCALLY.
THANK YOU AND AND ECOGNIZING --
THE CHALLENGES OF THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AREAS DOWN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL --
BUT KNOWING --
FROM MY EXPERIENCE ALSO THE HARD
WORK THAT --
MEMBERS DO IS PARTICULARLY SEIU
IS SEVENTY OF COUNTY IN THE WORK
THAT THEY DO IN CARING FOR THOSE
THAT ARE OUT THERE AND MANY
TIMES THEY ARE FAMILY MEMBERS
MANY TIMES THERE'S NOT BUT THAT
SHOULDN'T BE THE DISCUSSION.
THE DISCUSSION IS YOUR CARING
FOR ECONOMIC VALUE IN OUR AREAS
AND FIRST THAT OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE STRONGER WHEN HOME CARE
WORKERS CONTINUE. TO WORK BUT
THEY NEED TO GET THAT LIVING
WAGE AS FAR AS MOVING FORWARD IN
TRYING TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES AND TRY TO TAKE CARE OF
MANY OF THOSE IN OUR COMMUNITY
WHICH YOU ONLY SEE THE
POPULATION GROWING --
IN THE POPULATION IS GOING TO
NEED THE SERVICES DOWN THE ROAD.
SO I THINK A LOT OF THE TOPICS A
LOT OF THE PUBLIC SPEAKERS IT
CAME UP AS FAR AS TRYING TO
REACH AN AGREEMENT AND PUTTING
THAT INTO ONE OF THE PARAMETERS
OF APPROVING --
A PROPOSAL ORA BILL GOING
FORWARD IS SOMETHING THAT I'M
VERY INTERESTED IN LOOKING AT IN
LEARNING MORE ABOUT WHEN THIS
COMES BACK TO THIS TO THIS BODY.
BUT ALSO --
REACH AN AGREEMENT IN ENSURING
PROPER WAGE FOR COUNTY WORKERS
BUT ALSO FOR COUNTIES THAT
CONTINUE TO NOT COME TO AN
AGREEMENT I THINK THIS IS A A
FAIR.
ASSUMPTION NOW THAT THIS HAS
CAUGHT THE ATTENTION OF THOSE IN
THE COLLEAGUES HERE THAT MAYBE.
SOME OF THAT WORK NEEDS TO
HAPPEN PRETTY QUICKLY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER AHMOSE.
ALL RIGHT SAYING NOTHING FURTHER
I DO WANT TO THANK YOU THIS ITEM
WILL BE HELD OPEN AND IT'S CLEAR
THAT THERE ARE ISSUES THAT THE
THE MEMBERS --
THE ADVOCATES IN THE
ADMINISTRATION I THINK THEY'RE
ISSUES THAT ARE OPEN BUT I THINK
THAT WE ALL NEED TO TAKE --
CLOSER LOOK AT TO TRY TO FIND
SOLUTIONS BECAUSE THIS IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE WE'VE GOT TO FIND A
BETTER WAY TO DO THIS.
AND DO WHETHER IT'S JUST THE
CARROT WITH THE CARROT AND THE
STICK IF THE CARE IT'S NOT
WORKING LET'S FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE STICK IS AND FIGURE OUT HOW
IN THE END.
WE DO EXACTLY AS MISTER RAMOS
SAID WE JUST PROVIDE AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE PROVIDING
PROTECTION FOR THOSE WERE
PROVIDING THE SERVICE.
I THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY THANK YOU.
AND NOW I EIGHT THE NEXT ISSUE
WE'RE GOING WE'RE GOING TO SKIP
OVER. THREE FOUR AND FIVE AND
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE ISSUE.
SIX WE HAVE SOME SO SITE
ADVOCATES.
THAT HAVE TO CATCH A BUS.
AND WE APPRECIATE THAT THEY ARE
HERE.
AND WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT
THEIR TESTIMONY IS HEARD BEFORE
THEY LEAVE.
I ALSO WANT TO KNOW THAT --
ADDED TO THE PANEL LIST IS
BEVERLY WESTBROOK'S WITH
CALIFORNIA FOR SSI.
AND AGAIN I WOULD ELSE THAT THE
TESTIMONY BE GIVEN IN THE ORDER
[inaudible]
NOTED. TWENTY THREE WITH THE
ADDITION OF BEVERLY.
ALSO [inaudible]
SO --
BEVERLY YOUR FIRST GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS BEVERLY WESTBROOK --
I'M IN AMMAN S. S. I AND I GET.
NINE HUNDRED ESSAY ABOUT NINE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS
A MAN. FOR AND THEY TAKE SIX
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE DOLLARS
OUT OF MY OUT OF THAT. FOR RENT.
AND I ALSO HAVE P. G. E. TO PAY.
FOR AND I HAVE A COLD I HAVE A
COLD PAY ALL MY MEDICINE.
AND HAVE TO MAKE A CHOICE
BETWEEN MY MEDICINE.
AND MY P. JEANNIE [inaudible]
AN WE REALLY NEED.
WE REALLY NEED THE INCREASE AND
THE S. S. I..
I SEE -- I
LIVE WITH.
WITH MANY SENIORS.
IN NEED TRYING TO HELP.
AND I TRY TO HELP AS MUCH AS I
CAN.
I HAVE A FRIEND WHO IS DI<c.cyan>.</c>
AND I SPEND MOST OF MY DAYS.
BY HIS SIDE.
BEING HERE'S BEEN HERE TO BEING
HERE TO SPEAK. TO YOU POOR ME
FROM HIS SIDE.
THAT'S HOW IMPORTANT I THINK
THIS IS.
I AM ASKING ALONG WITH FORTY
OTHER ABBY KIDS.
TO URGE YOU TO RAISE THE GRANT.
THANK YOU.
MY CARROLLTON.
MADAM CHAIR --
MY CAROL WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY --
THANK YOU FOR MOVING THIS SO WE
CAN GET HERE FROM THE THE
CLIENTS THEMSELVES AND I'M JUST
GOING VERY VERY SHORT WHICH IS --
WE ARE LOOKING IN THIS BUDGET TO
TRY TO IN STAGES RESTORE THE SSI
GRANT THAT WAS REDUCED --
BACK DURING THE GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER TIME IN STAGES
BACK 21100% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL --
WE'VE HAD A PROPOSAL UNDER IN
PRIOR YEARS TO DO THAT OVER TWO
OR THREE STAGES --
WE ARE STILL IN INTERESTED IN
SOME APPROACH LIKE THAT --
WE THINK THAT IF WE COULD MAKE A
GOOD FOR STEP ON THAT THIS YEAR --
AND I'M JUST KNOW THAT EVEN
THOUGH WE DID CASH OUT LAST YEAR
IN A LOT OF PEOPLE GOING TO
BENEFIT WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT
THAT A LOT LATER ON IN THE
AGENDA.
SOME YOU HAVE ONE POINT TWO
MILLION PEOPLE IN THE PROGRAM.
IF WE DO A GREAT JOB WE GET A
HALF A MILLION PEOPLE SNAP
BENEFITS THAT'S GREAT THEY'RE
GOING TO GET A BOOST.
BUT THAT ALSO MEANS WE HAVE
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
RECIPIENTS WHO WON'T GET AN
INCREASE AND THAT'S WHERE I
THINK WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING ON
THE GRANTS BECAUSE WE HAVE MANY
PEOPLE WHO JUST NEVER BEEN MADE
WHOLE FROM THE CUTS THEY TOOK
MORE THAN A DECADE AGO WITHOUT
ALL.
CLOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AND CHENEY.
THANK YOU AIR INTERCHANGE DOES
MAKE ANY SENSE THANKS AGAIN FOR
MORE YOU KNOW WHATEVER YOU
WHATEVER YOUR NAME IS THAT'S
WHAT I WANT TO SAY.
AND YOU CHANGE WITH THE FOOD
BANKS INCLUDING CONNECTION --
PARTNERSHIP FROM SAMBAR AND YOU
KNOW --
THANKS FOR MOVING THIS ISSUE UP
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF --
I JUST WANNA SAY TWO THINGS YOU
KNOW.
THE THERE'S A VERY HIGH COST TO
THESE LITTLE GRANTS --
FOOD BANKS OTHER PRIVATE CHARITY
PARTNERS HAVE BEEN FORCED TO
FILL IN THE GAPS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND NINE IN ADDITION --
FOLKS ARE GOING HOMELESS --
WE'VE WE'VE HEARD THAT THERE IS
VERY SERIOUS --
FILTER FORSTER LINE EMERGENCY
ROOM SO I AIR TO THE COMMITTEE
NOT JUST TO LOOK AT THE LA OWES
ESTIMATE OF WHAT THE GREAT
INCREASE WILL BE BUT IT THE
HOLISTIC APPROACH OF WHAT WE'RE
PAYING NOW.
BY FORCING PEOPLE TO LIVE IN
POVERTY LET ALONE THE INDIGNITY
THAT CREATES --
AND PEOPLE CAN'T PAY THEIR BILLS
OF FOOD STAMPS YOU TO REALLY
TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW HER NEED TO
PAY RENT FOR P. JEANNIE HUSING
TRADE OFFS BETWEEN FOOD AND
MEDICINE UTILITIES --
AND THAT THAT AND TO CAST IT AND
THE SSI EXPANSION A CAL FRESH IS
ONLY ONE STEP WE HAVE TO ADDRESS
THE GRANTS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
AND FROM.
THE ADMINISTRATION LARRY --
DIRECTOR.
THE CHAIR.
OF THE DEPARTMENT --
WE DON'T HAVE A PROPOSAL FOR A
GRANT INCREASE BEFORE YOU IN THE
BUDGET -- WE
APPRECIATE THE DISPLAY ON PAGES
TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE OF WHAT
THOSE A MAXIMUM GRANT LEVELS ARE --
WE ALSO HAVE PROVIDED THE
COMMITTEE ALTHOUGH WE WON'T GO
THROUGH WITH A POWER POINT SLIDE
ON PAGE SEVEN OF THAT I WOULD I
WOULD CALL OUT NOT ONLY DOES IT.
MY NAME THAT THE MAXIMUM PAYMENT
STANDARDS AS REFLECTED IN THOSE
CHARTS BUT ALSO PROVIDES A TABLE
OF THE ACTUAL AVERAGE GRANTS
RECEIVED BY PEOPLE WHICH IS
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER THAN NOT
MAXIMUM.
AT THE END OF THE DAY GIVEN THE
PRICE TAG HERE IT'S A QUESTION
OF BUDGET PRIORITIES ESTO WHAT
PEOPLE WANT TO DO --
AND WE COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND THE
CONDITION THAT PEOPLE RECEIVING
THESE GRANTS ARE ARE LIVING IN
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THE YOUR
AGENDA DOES REALLY LAY OUT VERY
WELL THE DIFFERENCE --
BETWEEN FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL
AND SSI LEVELS AND THE HISTORY
OF SORT OF THE THE RECENT BRIEF
HISTORY OF UP AND DOWN IN THE US
THIS P. LEVELS IN THE US TO SIGN
LEVELS OVER TIME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SYDNEY TONY MODEL.
JACKIE BOROUGH CHILL --
PLEASE.
YEAH YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE I
KNOW WE HAVE PLAYED A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS ISSUES
FOR THE LAST COUPLE YEARS. TO
THE EXTENT THE LEGISLATURE WANTS
TO MAKE THIS PRIORITY WILL BE
HAPPY TO HAVE THE COST ESTIMATES
FOR THE COST --
RELATING TO THE PROPOSAL'S
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHECK BROS VILLAGE THEY'VE
ANALYST OFFICE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE ANY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT YOU MAY NEED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND NOW I'D LIKE TO OPEN IT UP
TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
THEY SHOULD HAVE. SIX CHAIRMAN.
JEFF HARDY GEAR --
ADVOCATING FOR A THIS TO GO
THROUGH.
IN REMARKS OF A YOU KNOW ARNOLD
AND EVERYTHING ELSE OF BOTH COST
OF LIVING.
AND THAT --
I SEE MANY MANY PEOPLE IN MY
LIVE ON SSI AND ALL OF THE
CHOICES THAT THEY HAVE TO MAKE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RUSSELL RAWLINGS RESOURCES FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING --
YES AS YOU WILL HEAR --
AND HAVE HEARD FROM ONE OF OUR
CONSUMERS --
THESE.
LIVING ON SSI IS A CHALLENGE --
I'VE HEARD QUITE FREQUENTLY YOU
KNOW IT'S IT'S VERY EXPENSIVE
BEING POOR --
IT'S VERY HARD TO MAKE ALL OF
THE APPOINTMENTS --
PAYING FOR TRANSPORTATION MEANS
ESPECIALLY IF YOU HAVE A
PHYSICAL SIGNIFICANT PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES --
IT CAN BE VERY HARD GETTING
AROUND IT'S VERY HIGH.
VERY HIGH COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
OUT.
AND SO WE JUST REALLY --
THINK THAT THE TIME IS NOW TO
BRING FOLKS UP TO THAT FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL.
IT USED TO BE YOU KNOW THAT THAT
THE GRANT WAS CLOSER TO YOU.
A REALISTIC PICTURE OF LIVING IN
POVERTY BUT NOW WE'RE JUST.
AT THE BOTTOM BELOW.
WAY BELOW ALL FOR FOLKS SO I
REALLY ENCOURAGE --
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO TAKE
A HARD LOOK AND DO THE WORK AND
GET US TOGETHER A PLAN THAT CAN
GET US THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
GERRY PASSED MORE.
PRESIDENT THE CONGRESS OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS SIMPLY URGING
YOU TO CONSIDER SOME ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR SSI RECIPIENTS MANY
OF WHOM ARE ENIORS.
AND THEY ARE ACTUALLY AMONG THE
MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TODAY THEY
NEED YOUR HELP.
AND WHEN WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
SPENDING MORE FOR THIS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LEGISLATORS --
MY NAME IS CHERYL MUSLIMS ARE
RESIDE IN SO MUCH CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO.
I'M HERE TODAY WITH OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS FROM THE T. IN DC
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO PROPOSALS
AND AMEND IT FOR THE CURRENT SS
I RECIPIENTS.
WHO WILL BE ELIGIBLE IN JUNE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN FOR THE
CALPERS OR SNAP BENEFITS?
FUNDING SHOULD BE ALLOCATED FOR
THE SS I RECIPIENTS TO RECEIVE
AN INCREASE OF THE POVERTY LEVEL
IS A LOW.
I'M ALSO IN CLOSING I WOULD LIKE
TO STATE THAT THESE PEOPLE THAT
SSI RECIPIENTS WERE ONCE.
IN THE WORKING CLASS BILL AND
ALSO TAXPAYERS I BELIEVE THAT
THEY SHOULD DESERVE SOME TYPE OF
RECOGNITION.
AND I'M ALSO GETTING OLDER AND I
WORK FOR A SENIOR FACILITY AND I
SEE HOW SOME OF THE ABSOLUTE
TORY USES ARE FALLING DOWN
BREAKING DOWN.
SO PLEASE GIVE US A CHANCE AND
VOTE RIGHT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I TRACY PATTERSON CALIFORNIA
FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE S. S. P. GRANT
INCREASE TO ALLEVIATE POVERTY
HUNGER AND HOMELESSNESS IN OUR
STATE.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ANITA MCDEVITT UP
FROM SAN FRANCISCO TNT SEE --
A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER I'M --
SSI RECIPIENT WHO'S BEEN
MENTALLY DISABLED SINCE LIKE
EIGHT FROM BEING SEXUALLY ABUSED
AND THE COST OF LIVING IN SOME
CISCO IS REALLY HIGH AND I'M
JUST ASKING SUPPORTING YOU GUYS
TO HIGHER UP THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
THAT AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
WILLIAM COLLINS FROM SAINT
MARY'S.
AND I'M BECAUSE OF ON THE PEOPLE
THAT CAN DO.
TRY. TO DO FOOT SENIOR.
EVERYONE IN HERE.
WILL BECOME.
A SENIOR [inaudible]
OUR DATA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO YOU CAN.
COME FORWARD YES --
YOU DON'T HAVE TO STAY WITH BACK
THERE YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME IS EITHER
PAYMENT TO ONE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY ON BEHALF
OF FORTY EIGHT THOUSAND PEOPLE
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY WHO RELY ON SS
I SS P.. TO MAKE ENDS MEET EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
AND OR ASK FOR YOU IS THAT YOU
ENSURE THAT THEY LIVE LIVES OF
DIGNITY.
BY RAISING THE GRANT LEVELS ON
SS I SS P. BACK UP 21100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S KERRY I'M AN SS.
MY NAME IS KERRY I'M SSI
RECIPIENT AND A SUPPORT
INCREASINGLY SAYS THAT SO I'M GO
GIVE ME A HAIR CUT.
AND GET ON THE BUS.
AND BECAUSE THE BUS KEEP ONE UP.
IN THE BODY SHOPS THEY GO UP TO
THE FAT ALSO AREA CODE.
THANK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI I'M BEHIND ON BEN'S A MAKE A
SERVICES GO CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M HERE TO US THAT THE
STATE LEGISLATURES.
INCREASE THE PAY OF US THE KERRY.
DUE TO LACK OF FUNDS FOR BARE
NECESSITIES IN FOOD.
I HAVE TO SAY.
THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS KATHERINE
WEALTH AND I'M FROM SAN
FRANCISCO.
I AM A DISABLED SENIOR.
I HAVE DIABETES ARTHRITIS ASTHMA
PTSD AND DEPRESSION AND I WOULD
BEEN FORMALLY HOMELESS I'M
ASKING FOR YOU TO INCREASE.
THE SOCIAL SECURITY.
BOARD THE DISABLED PEOPLE.
BECAUSE WE SPEND MONEY ON FOOD
NECESSITIES PERSONAL CARE
LAUNDRY AND RENT AND UTILITIES
BUT CLOSE ARE ALSO IMPORTANT.
IN A CASE IN POINT THIS IS A
RAIN COAT THAT I GET.
I GET MY CLOTHES FROM A FREE
RESOURCE ARE BY THEM IN AUTHOR
START AS YOU COULD SEE THAT IT
WAS HARDLY.
I CAN HARDLY BUTTON IT.
THIS WAS THE LARGEST SIZE I
COULD FIND FOR MYSELF
[inaudible]
SO HAVING.
AN INCREASE THE MONEY WOULD
ALLOW ME TO BE ABLE TO GO AND
PURCHASE SOMETHING THAT WOULD
FIT WHAT THE WAY IT IS NOW I'M
GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE THIS.
GET SOME FABRIC ADJUSTED SO THAT
IT WILL FIT ME ANYWHERE PROTECT
ME.
IN THE RAIN AND IT'S JUST THE
SAME THING WITH THE SHOES OR
OTHER CLOTHES.
BUT BASICALLY THIS WHOLE OUTFIT
I HAVE A I GOT FROM.
FREE RESOURCES.
THIS.
IS SOMETHING THAT I DON'T MIND
DOING BUT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WHEN WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO GO
AND PURCHASE SOMETHING BRAND NEW
THAT WE CAN DO IT.
RIGHT NOW I CAN'T I'VE HAD SO
SECURITY DISABILITY FOR OVER
EIGHT NINE YEARS NOW.
THIS IS NOT FAIR I'VE WORKED FOR
MANY YEARS I RAISE TWO CHILDREN.
AS A SINGLE PARENT WHY DO I HAVE
TO LOSE MY DIGNITY.
AND TO FEEL BAD BECAUSE I WANT
TO BE.
DRESSED NICELY TO HOW CLOSE THAT
FIT.
WHY DO I HAVE?
TO COME DOWN TO THIS LEVEL.
WHY DO MY KIDS HAVE TO SEE ME
THIS WAY?
PLEASE INCREASE IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M A VOLUNTEER
WITH THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK.
LIKE YOU I AM FORTUNATE TO HAVE
ENOUGH RESOURCES TO PROVIDE FOR
MY FAMILY.
BUT AS YOU'VE HEARD TODAY SO
MANY CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS DON'T
SO I ASK YOU PLEASE TONIGHT WHEN
YOU SIT DOWN TO DINNER WHEN THE
SECURITY OF YOUR HOME WITH YOUR
FAMILY AND ENOUGH TO EAT.
THINK ABOUT THESE PEOPLE THAT
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY AND REMEMBER
THAT YOU ARE IN A POSITION TO DO
SOMETHING.
PLEASE INCREASE THE SSI GRANT
FOR THESE PEOPLE YOU'VE HEARD
TODAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S ROUNDER TAKE A AND
I'M WITH SAN FRANCISCO.
I HAVE CHRONIC PANCREATITIS
LIVER DISEASE TYPE TWO DIABETES
I TREAT YOU TI AND BEEN DENIED
SSI.
APPEAL WILL TAKE SEVENTEEN
MONTHS MEDICATION IN E. R.
SERVICE HAVE BEEN DENIED BECAUSE
ADMINISTRATION GENERAL
CONFIGURATION SECTION.
HAS PRIMARY CONTACT GUARDIANSHIP
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN ALSO
KNOWN AS REAL TIME AB
ADMINISTRATION TEAM NONPROFIT
PROGRESS HOUSE.
OPERATED BY.
LEGISLATORS OF THE STATE SINCE
TWO THOUSAND GEN. FOR PRODUCTION
EXPECTATION OF EVIDENCE AND
INFORMATION THAT MAY LEAD TO
EVIDENCE UPON SWORN AFFIDAVIT.
CIVIL AND CRIMINAL COMPLAINT
FILED WITH CONGRESSWOMAN DOORS
MICHU T. WHAT.
DISTRICT SIX OF CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS I'M THAT
U. S. CITIZEN NEEDED AND THAT ON
GOING INVESTIGATION SPECIAL.
COUNSEL ROBERT MILLER'S
ATTENTION EXTRA JUDICIAL I NEED.
IMMEDIATELY EMERGENCY.
ATTENTION TODAY FOLLOW THE
MOTION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S DAVID BURKE AT
THANK YOU FOR COMING LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN --
IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT ONLY
A DID THAT IT'S ONLY A SIGN OF
THE DECENT SOCIETY --
TO BRING DISABLED PEOPLE'S
INCOME SENIORS.
THE OFFICIAL LEVEL OF POVERTY OR
MORE IN THE U. S. BY INCREASING
THEIR LIFESAVING BENEFITS TO
THAT LEVEL.
LOOK AT THE WAY MOST OF THE
WORLD TRADE TO SENIORS THEY
RIVER REVERE THEM THEY TAKE CARE
OF THEM --
HERE IF THEY'RE NOT WEALTHY
THEY'RE GENERALLY JUST THROWN
AWAY AND THAT'S A DISGRACE --
IN ADDITION BEING DISABLED I'VE
HAD A CHANCE TO STUDY THE
ECONOMIC PROBLEMS AND DANGERS
THAT HAVE BEEN BUILDING UP IN
OUR COUNTRY FOR YEARS AND ARE
NOW REACHING A CRISIS POINT --
BUT AND I'VE STUDIED ALL KINDS
OF THREATS TO OUR MONEY
INCLUDING DISTRIBUTED LEDGER
TECHNOLOGY THAN THE NEW CURRENCY
OF THE OF THE GET LEAVES --
PROBABLY THE MOST DANGEROUS
POSSIBILITY OF ALL OF THESE ARE
ONLY POSSIBILITIES ARE NOT FOR
SURE --
CURRENCY REBOOTS OR RESETS WHICH
ARE BEING MANSION CURRENCY
REPLACEMENTS LIKE A NEW FIAT OR
GOLD BASE CURRENCY.
DEVALUED FIAT DOLLAR A SWITCH
TRONIC MONEY OR A MAJOR LOSS IN
THE DOLLARS STATUS AS THE
WORLD'S RESERVE CURRENCY WHICH
IS ALREADY HAPPENING BIG TIME.
ALL OF THESE ARE REAL DANGERS TO
THE NON WEALTHY AND OUR
POSSIBILITIES.
IF ANYTHING HAPPENS TO CUT THE
INCOME OF THOSE AT THE BOTTOM BY
ANY CHANGE IN OUR CURRENCY.
PLEASE BE READY AND MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE RECEIVING BENEFITS
ARE PROVIDED WITH ENOUGH OF ANY
RE VALUED CURRENCY TO MAKE UP
FOR ANY LOSS IN INCOME OR BUYING
POWER.
BECAUSE BY SUCH A CHANGE.
AS ANY SUBSTANTIAL LOSS WOULD
AND IS GENOCIDE AND WOULD RESULT
IN THE DEATH OF PERHAPS MILLIONS
AND A COUNTRY WITH OLD PEOPLE
HOMELESS ON THE STREET WHICH I
DON'T THINK ANY OF US WANT TO
SEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY TEN THOUSAND
SOCIAL WORKERS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE VERY
SUPPORTIVE.
OF INCREASING THESE GRANTS I
THINK YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THE
NEED TODAY --
IT'S LONG OVERDUE AND THANK YOU
FOR THIS HEARING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SHEILA GUN CUSHMAN OF OAKLAND.
SSI RECIPIENT AS AS TI RECIPIENT.
SECTION.
EIGHT IT TAKES TOO MUCH ENERGY.
WE NEED THE BARE NECESSITIES THE
SIMPLE BARE NECESSITIES WE'RE
TIRED OF THE WORRY M. THIS DRIVE.
WE NEED SUPPORTER OF OUR SAFETY
NET WE NEED THE HELP THAT WE CAN
GET WE NEED THE SIMPLE BARE
NECESSITIES OF LIFE. 70% OF
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES ARE
UNEMPLOYED.
I HAVE BEEN ON SSI MOST OF MY
LIFE IF NOT ALL.
MY MOM TOOK CARE OF IT TILL I
WAS EIGHTEEN I HAVEN'T GOT A
CLUE ABOUT THAT --
I AM ON AS AS TI ON MY OWN
ACCOUNT I WORKED FOR TWO AND A
HALF YEARS.
HAD AN INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTER
I'VE HAD A BUSINESS I WAS A AND
ACCESS TECHNOLOGY TRAINER FOR
SEVEN YEARS IN SACRAMENTO BEFORE
I MOVED TO THE BAY AREA BACK TO
THE BAY AREA --
AND EVENTUALLY GOT SECTION
[inaudible]
EIGHT I A LOT OF US ARE ON A LOT
OF THESE PROGRAMS AND BY THE WAY
SINCE I'M HERE ANYWAY --
WE NEED FOOD STAMPS ASAP --
WE NEED TO SNAP A SAP.
THERE'S A HASHTAG FOR YOU --
AND I I LOVE YOU GUYS BUT I'M
TIRED OF BEING UP HERE.
OKAY.
AND I IT WE I I WANT TO LOOK
AROUND AND GO.
WHERE WE HEAR?
HAVEN'T WE BEEN HERE BEFORE.
HAVEN'T I DONE THIS BEFORE.
I'M HAVING THIS DEJA VU PTSD
THING GOING ON THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOU'VE GOT A NICE VOICE.
TO I THINK IT PARK STATION.
HI MY NAME'S ROB COPELAND A LONG
QUEUE THAT DOG FIGHTS WHICH THIS
BILL IF YOU READ SCRIPTURE IN
SACRAMENTO IN SHOCK WITH THE
HOMELESS RATES GROUP HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
AND THE TWO THOUSAND NINE WE GOT
NINE OH SEVEN AND IF THEIR SIDE
NOW WE GET OUT NINE THIRTY ONE
AND SOME CHANGE.
DO YOU LIVE.
THE FOUR DOLLAR INCREASE OVER
THE LAST TEN YEARS.
I DON'T THINK SO.
THERE'S NO ONE THE POUND SAYS I
KNOW PEOPLE THAT ARE A DEPENDING
LE.
THEY HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
MEDICINE [inaudible]
FOOD ELECTRICITY.
AFTER THEY PAY THE RENT AND
CLOTHING A NEW CLEAN JUST.
A LUXURY FORM.
SO WE NEED THE EVENT CREE
PHILLIES THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL.
AND I AM NOT GOING TO THINK OF
THAT ONE RUN NO YOU ALL OUT HERE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I SAID THANK YOU BUT IT WASN'T
SO THAT YOU WOULDN'T SAYING I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU.
I DON'T KNOW YOU WELL ENOUGH TO
KNOW HOW YOU SING.
HI YES --
HOMELESS IN AMERICA OF SAINT
MARY'S CENTER BUT A HOMES.
AND NOW WE NEED FUNDS TO GET
HELP US TO GET INTO HOUSING OF A
NUMBER JUST ROOM.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH FUNDING AND
I APPRECIATE ONE OF THE SAME
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MAKING THE CHOICES WHICH MAKE
STRESS IN EVERYDAY THING.
A TIE FROM.
THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY.
THIS IS AN ALL DAY HERE.
I MAYBE SIX YEARS OLD I WAS BORN
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
I'VE BEEN HERE WITH BOTH PARTIES
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS.
I HOPE THAT MY PARTY DOES GOOD
FOR ME.
I'M NOT ASKING JUST FOR MYSELF.
I NEED A LITTLE HELP SOMETIMES
BECAUSE I IS THREE MONTHS I HAVE
BEEN GOING TO THE DOCTOR AND I
FOUND OUT.
THAT I CURED MYSELF FROM DIE
PAGES WHICH IS.
I TOOK A CHANCE AND I MADE IT.
AND I TOOK THE CHANCE OF GETTING
MYSELF PREPARE LAST NIGHT
BECAUSE I MEAN I WAS IN PAIN AND
I'M HERE.
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU.
AND I HOPE THAT YOU HELP.
THE OTHER PEOPLE BEHIND ME.
AND TING. TO GET --
AND IT'S SO HARD. TO MAKE THAT
DOLLAR GROW AND WHEN YOU GO TO
GET YOUR TICKETS. FOR A BUS YOU
TAKE IT WAS TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS
I TOOK THIRTY I SAID I GOT FIVE
DOLLARS FOR A DOZEN MY BANKS
EMBRACE.
THEY TOLD ME IT WAS THIRTY
DOLLARS.
SO I WALKED OUT OF THERE AND I
COUNT ON CAL FRAZIER.
BECAUSE THAT'S MY HEALTH I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL OF YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHEN A STATUS SO YOU HAD A
POLICY ASKING?
WHEN I STARTED THIS SO YOU JUDY
MADONNA IS THIRTY TO PRESENT
THEM BINGO IN CORNER THAT LIKE
WHEN YOU THAT THIS SENIOR CENTER?
SO MAYBE SENATE --
I'M JUDY MADONNA AND I COME FROM
WEST OAKLAND ST MARY SENIOR
CENTER.
M..
A. IS DURABLE YOUNG DOOR A TWO
AND WILL NEED AT THE CITY LEVEL.
AB STONE CHAPTERS ON US THE
SHELTER --
YES SHE'S SAYING THAT SHE WANTS
TO SUPPORT ALL THE FOLKS FROM
THAT COMMUNITY SHE SEEN A LOT OF
SENIORS LIVE IN THE SHELTER --
AREAS WHICH HAVE BEEN SON OF
THIS GERMAN CUENTA CORPS OF ACES
CALM WAY YOU'VE PANEL YOU'LL BE
ABLE CALL MICAH.
SOMETIMES I REALLY I SEE A LOT
OF FOLKS EVEN THOUGH I LIVE WITH
MY DAUGHTER.
BUT IT DOESN'T KNOW HOW CITY FOR
YOU SEEN BY THAT VOCAL.
LOCAL COOKING A GETTING A CHECK.
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT STILL FOR
BOTH OF US TO PAY FOR OUR
APARTMENT WITH HOW LITTLE WE
BOTH GET.
IF IT I'M OKAY IT IS A SIGN OF
REFORM THE PARENTAL BUT I'M WE
JUST ASSUME THAT THERE ARE MANY
PEOPLE.
YES THEY WOULD LOVE ESTA SITE TO
BE INCREASED TO RESPOND VERY
QUICKLY BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY
PEOPLE IN NEED.
AND I'M A MUST ADDRESS YOUNG IN
THE SAME SITUATION YEAH.
IS IT IS THE PHONE.
ONLY HAD A LASTING MOTHER.
AND IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S A PITY.
WHICH HAPPENS SO UNLESS IS DONE
THE HIS SIT DOWN WOULDHINT THAT
MEANT THEY COULD NOT DENY YOU
THE KEY IS DONE MOSTLY THUNDER.
BUT AT THE END OF FROM YOU HAVE
GIVEN MOST OTHER LEAH.
IN NATICK DONE THOUGH.
ELEVENTH US WE'LL LET ME SEE
ANNA -- IT.
OWN WHICH OF COURSE THAT COME
WITH THAT FOR ME THERE.
THE FOOD.
THIS MEDICATION MORE SHELTER
MORE HOUSING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WHICH IS
SOME OF THE GLASS IS A YOU CAN
ALSO THROW SPOT --
THEM TO OPINION.
HELLO -- MY
NAME IS JENNY CAN STILL I'M FROM
THE SAME MERRY CENTER --
CENTER IN WEST OAKLAND.
AND I'D LIKE YOU TO THINK FOR
JUST A MOMENT.
HOW QUICKLY MOST OF US CAN SPEND
A HUNDRED DOLLARS?
IT'S LIKE ONE AMAZON CLICK.
I JUST ONE SWIPE OF OUR CREDIT
CARD AND WE SPEND NOT JUST A
HUNDRED DOLLARS BUT A LOT MORE
THAN THAT SOMETIMES.
SO I WANT YOU TO THINK FOR ONE
SECOND.
THERE ARE MANY SENIORS AND
DISABLED FOLKS WHO HAVE TO LIVE
OFF OF THAT FOR MORE THAN THIRTY
DAYS.
BECAUSE THE RENT IS 90% OF WHAT
THEY GET.
AND THEY HAVE TO MAKE THOSE
DOLLAR STRETCH AND I THINK I'M
BEING GENEROUS WHEN I SAY A
HUNDRED DOLLARS I'VE HEARD
STORIES THAT THEY LIVE OFF OF
SIXTY DOLLARS A MONTH. FORTY
DOLLARS A MONTH BECAUSE THEIR
RENT IN THEIR BASIC NECESSITIES
ARE SO HIGH.
AND IN THE CITY OF OAKLAND THIS
IS ARE GOING TO BE MORE
EXPENSIVE AND THAT AFFECTS A
CHECK THAT DOESN'T GO UP.
SO I'D LIKE YOU TO CONSIDER WHAT
HE REALLY MEANS FOR OUR
COMMUNITY TO RAISE THESE GRANTS.
AND THE PLEASE DO THE RIGHT
THING TODAY.
MOVE IN THE GAME OF MOVE IN THE
DIRECTION OF RAISING THESE
GRANTS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BUT I WANTED TO ONCE AGAIN SAY
WOULD LIKE US TO LIMIT IT TO ONE
MINUTE SOME OF YOU'VE GOT A
LITTLE OVER.
WE'RE GOING TO GET.
WE'RE GONNA GET ME NOW I'M
KIDDING.
MADAM CHAIR KERR CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
RESTORATION OF THE S. P..
S. S. B. REDUCTIONS AND ALSO THE
RESTORATION OF THE COLA THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MANAGER AND MY NAME IS PERCY
JACKSON.
ARE FROM SAY MERS [inaudible]
HOMELESS SHELTER.
BROWSE HOMELESS FOR FIVE YEARS.
NOT BEEN HOMELESS --
I'VE BEEN OUT TRYING TO GET FOOD
STAMPS.
AND STUFF IT'S BEEN HARD.
OKAY NOT GET SSI.
BUT NOW SAYS I GOT SSI I STILL
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO PAY
FOR FOOD.
SAGA FOODSTUFFS.
CHARGERS.
ST MARY'S.
FOOD OFF THE STREET FOOD OUT OF
GARBAGE CANS.
WELL BACK IN.
EIGHTY BUT IT'S HARD OUT HERE.
ALL WE ASK FOR YOUR TO DO IS TO
TAKE CARE PEOPLE DID GET TO BE
HELP.
US OLDER PEOPLE AND SENT TO THE
SIGNAL THE BORDER AFTER A MATTER
OF FACT.
YOU KNOW HOW WE ACTUALLY DO IT
JUSTICE.
LOOK OUT RESPECT TO WHAT WE
WON'T.
AND THAT IS A PLACE IN.
VALUE HONEST REESE'S HEART.
NOW MY HOMELESS ADVOCATE.
TO AND I LIKE TO HELP THE
HOMELESS PEOPLE END UP OTHER
ODDS BECAUSE TO LOOK OUT FOR HIM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LIVVIE SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES FOR IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES HERE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FOR THE SS
PICCOLA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI I AM ME HERE WITH SENIOR AND
DISABILITY ACTION --
SO YEAH WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THAT INCREASE AND REMIND YOU
THAT THE FERAL --
POVERTY LINE.
MEANING LESS WHEN YOU LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA.
JUST SAYING YOU KNOW.
THIS IS A VERY VERY EXPENSIVE
STATE AND EVEN IF THEY GET TO
THAT POINT IT'S STILL NOT ENOUGH
SO.
LET'S TAKE THEM TO THE POINT
PLEASE THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD UP THERE NOT MY NAME IS
SAID IF SAY.
A MEMBER OF US IN YOUR DOES THE
SUB THE UPSHOT.
IS NOW OUT TIME THEN PUT IT DA
IS THIS I AND IS.
UP FOR PEOPLE HOLD IT IT.
YOUR LIVING AREA IS MORE
EXPENSIVE THE LIVES.
SEOUL.
THEY WANTED TO DO REAL ART WILL
BE.
PORTIS PRODUCT OF CALIFORNIA
STIMULATE.
THE CALIFORNIA.
MAY CALL FOLLOW [inaudible]
MAY [inaudible]
ALLAH.
OPEN BUS UNIT WITH THE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS GAIL SEE
GRAYSON SAN FRANCISCO AND I'LL
MAKE THIS VERY SHORT I HOPE YOU
CAN SEE THIS BAT.
THIS IS AS THE ONES ON SSI THIS
IS THE POVERTY LINE.
AND LOOK AT THAT AND SADLY I
CAN'T BELIEVE I'M HERE ASKING
THIS.
PLEASE BRING IS TO POVERTY.
TONIGHT THANK YOU.
THE VISUALS ARE VERY GOOD.
HONESTLY.
HI AM CAESAR FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
MY STRUGGLES WITH POVERTY LACK
OF MENTAL HEALTH EDUCATION
HOMELESSNESS AND SURVIVAL SEX
WORK RESULTED IN ME GETTING HIV.
I'M HERE TO DEMAND THAT WE SOLVE
POVERTY AND HOMELESSNESS.
WE CAN EASILY START THIS BY
RESTORING SSI FUNDING TO LIFT
OUR MOST VULNERABLE NEIGHBORS
OUT OF HOME OUT OF POVERTY.
CALIFORNI HAS THE HIGHEST RATES
OF POVERTY OF ALL STATES --
INCLUDE INCLUDING CHILDHOOD
POVERTY --
BY ADDRESSING POVERTY PROMOTING
SOCIAL ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND
CREATING POLICIES THAT PREVENT
EXPLICATED CONDITIONS.
LABOR CONDITIONS --
THIS IS HOW WITH ADDRESS PARTY.
I DON'T QUALIFY FOR SSI BUT I
SHARE THEIR STRUGGLES OF FOOD
AND SECURITY AND EXTREMELY
HIGHER RISKS OF ADDICTION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MARGARITA GLENDALE I'M FROM SAN
FRANCISCO.
I'M BLESSED TO BE SUFFICIENTLY
FITS OF BOTH MIND AND BODY TO
WORK FOR A LIVING THE COST OF
LIVING IN THE BAY AREA HOWEVER
IS VERY HIGH.
GOD FORBID THAT I SHOULD BECOME
BLIND DISABLED OR IN ANOTHER TEN
YEARS REACH THE AGE OF SIXTY
FIVE AND BE UNABLE TO CONTINUE
SUPPORTING MYSELF WITH FULL TIME
EMPLOYMENT.
I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE WE ALL
HAVE A MORAL IMPERATIVE TO CARE
FOR THOSE MOST VULNERABLE AMONG
US AND PROVIDE THEM WITH A
LIVING INCOME.
PLEASE REMEMBER THAT AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED AND TEN
DOLLARS A MONTH WILL NOT LIFT
ANYONE OUT OF POVERTY.
IT WILL LIFT AN INDIVIDUAL UP TO
THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
FEDERAL POVERTY GUIDELINES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS VERY
URGENT ISSUE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
FELICIA SMITH AND I'M FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND WITH TENDERLOIN
HOUSING CLINIC.
AND WELL EIGHT YEARS AGO I WAS
THE ASSISTANT TO THE CHIEF OF
SURGERY AT UCSF.
I WENT THROUGH A VERY VERY BAD
DIVORCE AFTER TWENTY TWO YEARS
OF MARRIAGE.
AND BECAME HOMELESS.
SINCE THEN I'VE BECOME A
HOMELESS ADVOCATE.
I'M A TENANT ORGANIZER AT ONE OF
THE HOTELS IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
I SEE ON A DAILY BASIS AND HAVE
EXPERIENCED IT MYSELF YOU PAY
RENT.
DOES NOT THE LEFTOVER I HAD TO
FOR THREE YEARS I HAD TO GO OUT
EVERY NIGHT.
AND PICK UP BEER CANS
[inaudible]
SODA CANS.
JUST SO I COULD BUY DEODORANT.
TOOTHPASTE THAT KIND OF STUFF
NOW I WORKED SINCE I WAS
FOURTEEN I'VE NEVER BEEN ON ANY
KIND OF GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE
BEFORE.
AND SEEING.
WHAT I GET INTO IT ALL THESE
YEARS IS JUST SHOCKING?
AND I CAN'T BELIEVE I BAGGING
FOR YOU TO BRING IT UP TO
POVERTY LEVEL BUT I AM PLEASE AT
LEAST GET AS THE POVERTY LEVEL.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE FOOD
STAMPS [inaudible]
GIVE.
HI MY NAME'S LUCIA LITTLE I DID
TALK TO THE SENATE THE OTHER DAY
ABOUT THIS --
I WAS ON SSI BEFORE WITH AND I
HAD CHILDREN.
AND I WAS ON SSI.
THIS HASN'T BEEN BROUGHT UP YET.
WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU LOSE A CROWN
AND YOUR ON SSI NOBODY HAS
TALKED ABOUT THEIR TEETH?
YOU LOSE A CROWN YOU LOSE ALL
YOUR TEETH BECAUSE YOU'RE TWO
ONE HOLD ALL OF THEM UP.
SO.
STATE ON THE TOP JUST LET YOU
ALL KNOW --
BECAUSE I COULDN'T AFFORD TO
REPLACE THE CROWN.
SO I LOST ALL MY TOP TEETH.
SO EVERYBODY NEEDS A RAISE ON
SSI IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO LIVE ON
LITTLE LOS LOAN GO TO THE
DENTIST TO GET YOUR TEETH FIXED.
AND SUCH --
MEDI CAL DOES NOT PAY.
FOR ALL THE DENTAL YOU NEED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI GOOD EVENING --
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN MY NAME IS
ON POINT MILLER AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF ST MARY'S.
AND ALL ONE SAY FIGHT THE YOU
KNOW TOO MUCH IS GIVEN MUCH IS
REQUIRED A AND IF IT WAS JUST TO
HELP THE LEAST LITTLE ONES OF US.
YEAH YOU KNOW THE LAW WOULD HELP
US AND WE JUST THINK HOW BLESSED
THIS COUNTRY I MEAN YOU KNOW
THAT THIS COUNTRY AND AND HOW.
BEST CALIFORNIA IS SO LIKE THE
IF YOU JUST GIVE A LITTLE
[inaudible]
THANK POLITICS.
NO ONE OUT TO GIVE A LOT SOLEMN
SANDEL WITH IF YOU DO THE RIGHT
THING BY THE LEAST LITTLE.
ONE ALMIGHTY GOD WILL BLESS US
AFTER THE BUNS AND WE WILL ALL
HAVE.
TO B. R. THANKFUL THAT GOD IS.
MOST GRATEFUL MOST MOST MERCIFUL
I HAVE A COUSIN THAT THEY'RE
VERY WAS BROKE.
WHO HAS SOUGHT CLOSE ME SHE HAS
SHOOK ME UP?
YES REALLY WORK HARD TO GET ME
TO DO THE RIGHT HEY ON HER TO
MISS HIS OLDER THAN ME.
BUT SHE'S GIVE ME A GOOD EXAMPLE.
SO YOU KNOW WE ALL GOT TO DO THE
RIGHT THING FOR YOU TO WRITE
GAME THANK GOD WILL BLESS US ALL
I'M SANTA WITH.
PLEASE DO THE RIGHT THING AND
THEN ARE OUT AND GOD WILL HAVE
MERCY ON US BECAUSE WE ALL.
DID OR DO WRONG THINGS BUT WE
JUST DO RIGHT AND TRY TO HELP
THE LEAST LITTLE ONE UP UP WITH
IN OUR HELP IS ALSO JUST.
PLEASE DO THE RIGHT THING IF YOU
GET A RITE GANG DâN.
YOU KNOW IT BE OUR I FOLLOW THE
SALT.
PLEASE HELP THE PEOPLE.
SPECIAL FOOD CLOTHING SHELTER
BECAUSE GOD BLESSES.
BIRDS HE BLESSES INSECTS
EVERYTHING HAS A PURPOSE SO WE
ALL HAVE A PURPOSE OUR PURPOSE
IS TO HELP ONE OF THE RIGHT NOW
WHAT BEFORE IT'S TOO LATE.
FOLLOWING SANTA WAS BLAZING
JANICE JUST HELP THE POOR HELP
THE LEADING DOLLAR HELP YOU AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
LISTENING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HAVE BEVERLY THANK YOU
FOR MENTORING HIM.
THE NEXT TIME YOU GO TO TELLING
YOU CANNOT DO ONE FORTY FIVE MIN
AND FORTY FIVE ALL RIGHT NEXT.
I'M CALLING ABOUT GOING FROM SAN
FRANCISCO ON I WAS HERE. TWELVE
THIRTEEN YEARS AGO WHEN ON THIS
BODY WAS DISCUSSING WHAT TO DO
DURING THE RECESSION --
IN ORDER --
TO BALANCE THE BUDGET AND WENT
THROUGH THE DETERMINING THAT WE
WERE.
YOU KNOW THAT CUTTING SSI
BENEFITS WAS GOING TO BE PART OF
OUR BUDGET REDUCTION STRATEGY.
WE'RE INDEBTED TO SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITY IN THE
STATE BECAUSE WE BALANCE THE
BUDGET ON THEIR BACKS --
AND WE HAVE SEEN AN ECONOMIC
RECOVERY BUT THEY HAVE NOT AND
IT'S TIME THAT THEY SHOULD.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRPERSON
AND COMMITTEE MY NAME'S MARK
REALLY AFTER SEVERAL CISCO
CALIFORNIA --
I HAD A BUNCH OF NOTES.
LONG STORY SHORT --
I HAVE SEVERAL QUESTIONS FOR YOU.
DO YOU THINK EITHER ONE OF YOU
GUYS TO SURVIVE ON NINE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH.
NOT JUST A YOU HAVE TO EAT --
PAY YOUR BILLS.
WE JUST WANT TO TO ACTUALLY I
WANT TO RAISE.
AS AS I PASSED THE POVERTY LEVEL.
AND WITH THAT I'LL SAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO.
MICHELLE ROSY OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
WE SHOULD DO LIKE VISUALS WITH
THE POVERTY LIKE HERE.
AND WE'RE ALL AFTER IT.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO TO PAY OUR
BILLS AND BE ABLE. TO TO EAT.
I CURRENTLY GO TO THE FOOD BANK
A COUPLE TIMES A MONTH SOMETIMES
MORE GIFTS SO I CAN EAT BECAUSE
I DON'T GET ENOUGH. TO BE ABLE
TO TO A FOOT NEED TO BE ABLE TO
GO TO A REGULAR GROCERY STORE ON
A REGULAR BASIS.
I THINK NOT OF I SHOULD HAVE TO
DO THAT AND ADDS THAT AS A
NECESSITY OF LIFE WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO GO TO THE GROCERY STORE
NOT.
NECESSARILY HAVE EVERYTHING WE
WANT TO THANK YOU.
FOR THANK YOU.
THE THE BILL MILLIKEN.
BERMAN AND THEN.
I'M SASHA BITTNER AGAIN FROM
HAND IN HAND THOUGH YOU'VE MOVED
HERE THE BE IN THAT.
SSI STI RECIPIENT.
GO MULLIN B. BROUGH.
THE GOVERNMENT THEN.
WE WERE WOULD BE YOUR WERE THE
MOVE THEY BURN FOOD.
NO THEY DO LIVE IN.
THEY NEEDED.
WILBUR WON'T DO BURKE BROUGH DO
LIVE WILL.
COME ON PEOPLE THIS IS COMMON
SENSE WE LIVE IN THE MOST
EXPENSIVE STATE AND WE'RE STILL
BELOW THE POVERTY LEVEL NEW MOON
LONG THE ONLY WE'VE BEEN THERE
MAY BE.
TO LIVE BEEN WILLING LIVE THEN
GOOD FOODS GO.
WE'RE IN GOOD GOOD THING THE
JONES. FOR A MONTH --
THE ONLY REASON WHY I'M ABLE TO
LIVE IN WHERE I LIVE IS IN SAN
FRANCISCO IS BECAUSE I LIVED
DOWNSTAIRS FROM MY FAMILY I GET.
VERY LOW RENT I HAVE TO PAY VERY
LOW RENT.
AND MAN.
I AM FELLOW WE DO FAVORITE IN NO
BUENO.
I'M SORRY TO SAY THIS IS A NO
BRAINER.
THE TWO EIGHTEEN TWELVE BRITAIN
ROBO.
JUST BRING US TO FOR CAN POVERTY
LEVEL THE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS --
MIKE BYNUM U. D. W. ASKED ME
LOCAL THEIR NINE THIRTY ON
BEHALF OF OVER A HUNDRED TEN
THOUSAND I JUST AS WORKERS THAT
WE SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I WAS HERE LAST
WEEK AND WHAT I HEARD SFI
THEY'RE CONSIDERING GIVING A
HUNDRED DOLLAR REYES AND TO THAT.
I WAS LIKE ALMOST FELL OFF MY
CHAIR -- MY
WITH NEW THEY WERE GONNA GIVE US
FOOD STAMPS BUT I DIDN'T KNOW
THEY WERE THINKING ABOUT DOING
THAT AS WELL --
I HAVE A FORTY TWO YEAR OLD SON
WHO DID A STUPID THING AT TWENTY
ONE YEARS OLD AND HAD A
MOTORCYCLE ACCIDENT AND DUE TO
THAT FACT WILL ALWAYS HAVE BRAIN
DAMAGE THAT HE HAS TO LIVE WITH
ME.
TELL HE'S GONE --
WE WERE BOTH HOMELESS ALL OF
LAST YEAR BECAUSE OF OF LANDLORD
DIDN'T PAY THE MORTGAGE AND IT
GOT FORECLOSED ON AND SOLD AT
AUCTION.
WE LIVE IN LAKE COUNTY THERE'S A
LOT OF HOUSES LOST OVER THE
FIRES SO ARE RENTS IN LAKE
COUNTY HAVE GONE ABOVE A
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WE FINALLY FOUND ONE ON JANUARY
FOURTH FIRST HOME IN A YEAR AND
IT'S FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH.
NOW I'M AND I HSS PROVIDER AND I
HAVE TO WORK THREE PEOPLE WHY
SIGN INTO OTHERS.
JUST TO MAKE THE MONEY.
UP TO LIVE IN THE MOTEL LAST
YEAR WE DOLLARS A MONTH.
I GOT BEHIND IN MY CAR INSURANCE
I HAD I DON'T HAVE CAR INSURANCE
I NEED TO GET IT.
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT WE
CAN USE THAT HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
AND DEFINITELY RIGHT NOW THAT
HUNDRED DOLLARS OF FOOD STAMPS
WOULD PUT FOOD IN OUR HOUSE
WHERE WE HAVE DONE RIGHT NOW.
SO PLEASE THINK OF THAT IF YOU
HAVE ANY RELATIVES OR FRIENDS
THAT YOU KNOW THAT ARE LIVING ON
SS I OR FOODS AND NEED FOOD
STAMPS.
THEN YOU WILL UNDERSTAND AND
VOTE YES BECAUSE I WAS SCARED
WHEN I HEARD THERE I WAS A
STATIC WITH THERE'D BE GIVEN US
FOOD STAMPS.
BUT I WAS TERRIFIED THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO LOWER THE SSI AND
NOT RAISE IT.
BECAUSE THEY WERE GIVING FOOD
STAMPS.
SO PLEASE DON'T LET THOUGH THE
IDIOTS DO THAT EITHER IF THEY'RE
GONNA GIVE US FOOD STAMPS.
REYES ASIDE.
TO DON'T LOWER US THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING AND I KNOW I WENT OVER
I'M SORRY MADAM CHAIR.
YOU SURE DID BUT YOU KNEW YOU
WENT OVER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TO ALL OF
YOU FOR YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT --
I'D LIKE TO BRING IT BACK.
TO THE MEMBER'S COMMENTS
QUESTIONS.
VERY GOOD I KNOW THIS ITEM WILL
BE LEFT OPEN I KNOW THERE ARE
NUMBER OF THINGS THE BAND
DISCUSSED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION POSSIBLE PHASE
AND LOOKING AT THE BUDGET.
I WANT TO THANK --
BEVERLY WESTBROOK FOR COMING
WITH THE THE FIFTY ADVOCATES AND
I THANK YOU FOR GIVING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE THIS ITEM
FORWARD SO THAT YOU WE COULD GET
YOUR INPUT.
WE'RE GOING TO GO INTO ITEM
NUMBER [inaudible] SEVEN
IMPLEMENTATION OVERSIGHT FOR
EXPANSION OF CALPERS BENEFITS.
TO SS I SS P. RECIPIENTS
GOVERNOR'S B. C. P. AND
ASSOCIATED ADVOCACY PROPOSALS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
WE'RE PLEASED TO PRESENT ON THIS --
AND WITH BEING --
HERE --
INTRODUCED HER JUST MOMENTS CAN
CAN THE COR WAYS --
THE HEAD OF OUR CAL FRESH --
BENEFITS --
BRANCH --
THE VIN TALK ABOUT THE RBC P.
REQUEST IN ORDER TO IMPLEMENT
THE EXTENSION OF CALPERS
BENEFITS TESTS ARE RECIPIENTS
WHICH OCCURRED LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET AND HOW WHAT'S ROLLING
OUT AND HOW WE'RE IMPLEMENTING
IT.
INTEREST ALSO GUESTS PLEASE
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT --
SO.
YES LET'S DO THAT ALL RIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU THANK YOU I
WOULD LIKE A BRIEF UPDATE ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION STATUS OR OKAY
GREAT SO WE ARE THRILLED TO BE --
AS YOU HEARD FROM THE WONDERFUL
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TO BE --
EXPANDING CAL FRESH THIS SUMMER
TWO PEOPLE RECEIVING SSI FIRST
TIME EVER IN HISTORY THE SS I
PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA THE LAST
STATE IN THE COUNTRY TO DO SO.
SO IT'S A MAJOR --
ACHIEVEMENT --
IN POLICY AND NOW IT'S UP TO US
ALL MAKE IT HAPPEN SO BEGINNING
JUNE FIRST WE'VE BEEN PARTNERING
WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY.
HUMAN SERVICE AGENCIES.
AND THE ABBOTT THE COAST A
COALITION OF CLIENT ADVOCATES
CALIFORNIANS FOR SSI TO PLAN
IMPLEMENTATION STRATEGY.
GOT OUT THE GATE EARLY LAST
SUMMER WITH POLICY GUIDANCE IN
THE AUTOMATION WORK BEGAN.
AFTER THAT TURN TO THE
OPERATIONAL PLANNING WITH A
FRAMEWORK INVOLVING ALL
STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT CALL CLICK
COMMAND. TO MAKE SURE LOTS OF
DOORS ARE OPEN FOR OUR TO BUT
ALL LANGUAGES AND ALL
ACCOMMODATIONS READY.
AND WE ARE GETTING READY NOW TO
KICK OFF OUT REACH WILL BE
HAVING OUR BIG KICK OFF DAY IN
ABOUT A MONTH APRIL TWENTY FIFTH.
SPEND THE MONTH MAIN MAILING
PEOPLE ON SSI IN THE BEGINNING
JUNE FIRST BEGINNING TO ACCEPT
APPLICATIONS.
PLANNING HAS GONE WELL WE WILL
BE EXPECTING A SIGNIFICANT
VOLUME --
COME THIS SUMMER SIMILAR TO A CA
HEALTH CARE EXPANSION SO THERE
WILL BE THE CHALLENGES THAT COME
WITH ONBOARDING --
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
TO A NEW PROGRAM IN A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME.
BUT WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING THROUGH THOSE ISSUES
MANAGING THOSE ISSUES AND COMING
OUT THE OTHER SIDE WITH LOTS
MORE NUTRITION AND HEALTH
SUPPORT. FOR OUR STATE AND FOR
OUR NEIGHBORS.
THAT'S THE BRIEF IS UPDATE ON
THE IMPLEMENTATION PLANNING
UNLESS THERE'S QUESTIONS ON THAT
AND THEN I GUESS THERE IS A B.
C. P. TO SUPPORT STATE STAFF.
REALLY IN THREE AREAS THE
CASELOADS GONNA EXPAND BY ABOUT
20% SO THAT COMES WITH
ADDITIONAL MONITORING IN CASE
REVIEWS.
THIS ALSO WAS GOING TO
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE OUR
ELDERLY AND DISABLED --
BECAUSE DEPENDS WHO DO HAVE
SEPARATE FEDERAL RULES THAT
ALLOW FOR HIGHER SHELTER COSTS
AS WE HEARD ABOUT HIGHER MEDICAL
COSTS AND SO THERE'S SOME MORE
POLICY.
TRAINING AGAIN AT A WORK TO DO
TO MAKE SURE OUR PROGRAM IS
MEETING ALL NEEDS.
AND THEN --
THERE ARE TWO NEW STATE. FOR
THOSE FAMILIES WHO ARE ALREADY
ON CAL FOR OCEAN MAKES PERRANCE
A DECREASE OR A LOSS OF CALPERS
BENEFITS.
THIS IS THE SUPPLEMENTAL
NUTRITION BENEFIT PROGRAM IN THE
TRANSITIONAL NUTRITION BENEFIT
PROGRAM ES AND THE T. M. B. AND
DOES REQUIRE SOME NEW STATE
STAFF FOR ACCOUNTING AND
TRACKING --
AT THAT NEW STATE FUNDED
BENEFITS SO.
IN SHORT THAT'S WHERE WE ARE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS LEE SHONDA DAY X. ON HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
SOCIAL SERVICES WHY AM THE CHIEF
OF OUR CALPERS POLICY DIVISION.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY ABOUT
THE COUNTIES IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
OF THE CALPERS EXPANSION PRESSES
AYE RECIPIENTS.
WE HAVE DEVELOPED A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN THAT CONTAINS
A ROLE WITHIN OUR REACH
STRATEGIES AND A ROBUST
COMMUNICATION PLAN TO SUPPORT
CONNECTING SSI RECIPIENTS TO
CALPERS BENEFITS IN LA COUNTY.
WE ESTIMATE THE OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND SS I RECIPIENTS NOW
LAKE COUNTY ARE POTENTIALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR CALIFORNIA SHOULD
BEGINNING JUNE FIRST.
TOTALLY --
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESSES POPULATION
DPSS WILL EMPLOY TARGETED
STRATEGIES FOR THREE MAIN
CATEGORIES OF SS I SS P.
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR CALPRS
BENEFITS THE FIRST CATEGORY
CONSISTED OF APPROXIMATELY FORTY
TWO THOUSAND SS I SS P.
INDIVIDUALS CURRENTLY KNOWN TO
ACTIVE CAO FRESH?
FROM HOUSEHOLD.
SO THESE ARE THE HOUSEHOLDS THAT
AND CAN THE CALPERS CASE. FOR
THESE ACTIVE CALPERS HOUSE SO
THE DEPARTMENT HAS ECSTATIC
SPECIALIZE UNITS IN EACH
DISTRICT OFFICE THAT WILL --
ASSISTANT ADDING THE SS I SS P.
RECIPIENT TO THE COW FIRST CASE
AND EVALUATE THE AMPLE ONGOING
ELIGIBILITY FOR CALIBRATION
DURING YOUR PERIODIC REPORTING
WE VIEW.
THE SECOND CATEGORY IS OUR IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
POPULATION.
OUR DATA SHOWS THAT --
OVER A HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN
THOUSAND OR 74% OF OUR I JUST AS
CASE LITTLE ALSO RECEIVE SS I SS
P..
SO FOR THESE HOUSEHOLDS BUT
WE'RE GOING TO DO IS LEVERAGE
OUR IN HOME SUPPORT IS --
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES WORKERS SO
DURING THE INTAKE IN THE
REASSESSMENT PROCESS THE I JUST
AS SOCIAL WORKERS WELL INFORMED
THAT I JUST AS RECIPIENTS OF THE
NEW -- CASH --
POLICY AND HELP THEM CONNECT TO
CAO FRESH BENEFITS.
SO THAT THEIR MAIN CATEGORY IS
COMPRISED OF SS I SS P.
RECIPIENTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
NOT KNOWN TO OUR SYSTEM.
SO FOR THIS POPULATION WE WILL
FORMULATE AND STRENGTH IN
EXISTING PARTNERSHIPS WITH
COMMUNITY BASED IN PHASE --
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL AS
OTHER COUNTY DEPARTMENTS TO HELP
US GET THE WORD OUT AND CONNECT --
SS I SS P. INDIVIDUALS TO CAL
OUR REACH PLAN WELL AT THE VERY
TOP IN THE CASE [inaudible]
ON WHICH TARGETED INFORMATIONAL
NOTICES --
PASS ALONG CARDS I'LL BONE
BECAUSE IN TEXT MESSAGING SOCIAL
MEDIA AND WEBSITE PROMOTION
INTEGRATED VOICE RESPONSE
MESSAGES ON BE OUR CUSTOMER
SERVICE CENTER.
ADDITIONALLY ALL OF OUR WHICH
MATERIALS WILL BE SHARE WITH THE
COMMUNITY FOR DISSEMINATION
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS WAR GETS OUT --
TO SS I SS P. RECIPIENTS WHO ARE
POTENTIALLY ELIGIBLE.
NOW WHAT ARE THESE EFFORTS --
WILL LIKELY RESULT IN AN
INCREASE IN AND BY YOU ABOUT THE
CATIONS TO ALL OF OUR ACCESS
CHANNELS.
AND WILL HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
WORKLOAD IMPACT FOR OUR STAFF IN
IT WILL REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
STAFFING.
SO SHOULD THESE EFFORTS RESORT
AND I DEPARTMENT HAVING OVER
OVERFLOWING ARE LOBBIES WE HAVE
DEVELOPED A CONTINGENCY PLAN
WHICH INCLUDES --
MAKING SURE OUR OFFICES ARE
PROPERTY RESOURCE STE WE ARE
EXPANDING OUR INTAKE CALL
CENTERS HE WE AUGUST INSTALLING
ADDITIONAL PHONES IN THE
DISTRICT OFFICES SO THAT CLIENTS
CAN CALL THE CALL CENTER.
IN APPLY FOR A CAL FRESH OVER
THE PHONE SO WE DO HAVE A VERY
GOOD PROCESS IN PLACE SO IF YOU --
YOU GO APPLY FOR CAO FRESH OVER
THE PHONE IN THE OF ARE THE
DOCUMENTATION VERIFICATION IS
AVAILABLE WE CAN APPROVE YOUR
APPLICATION THE SAME DAY IN
ISSUE YOU ARE EBT CARD SO THAT'S
A GREAT THING.
SO IN CLOSING I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO EMPHASIZE THAT THIS IS JUST A
SNAPSHOT OF OUR EFFORTS TO OUR
ROLE AS THE SCIENCES PVC PANTS
AND CAL FOR ASH.
AND WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT OUR
OUR REACH EFFORTS IN OUR PLAN
WILL YOU YIELD VERY --
SUCCESSFUL RESULTS.
SO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I'LL BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER.
THANK YOU.
THERE MAY BE SOME LATER.
WE'RE GONNA LISTEN TO ALL THE
PANELISTS FIRST.
AS LAID OUT IN YOUR AGENDA ON
PAGE --
TWENTY EIGHT OUR OFFICE IT SEEMS
LIKE THE DEPARTMENT ALONG WITH
STAKEHOLDERS DONE A LOT WHEN IT
CAME WHEN IT COMES TO PLANNING --
FOR THE EXPANSION OF CALIFORNIA
WE JUST RAISED A NUMBER QUESTION
IN TERMS OF ONCE JUNE FIRST
HEADS WHAT'S THE FOLLOW UP FOR
THE LEGISLATURE THAT
IMPLEMENTATION FOLLOW UP --
QUESTIONS ARE LAID OUT IN YOUR
AGENDA YOUR STAFF COMMENT WERE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOUR STAFF TO
SEE WHAT ROLE WE COULD PLAY.
IN COORDINATING FACILITATING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND STAKEHOLDER WHAT
THAT FOLLOW UP COULD LOOK LIKE
AND THROUGH WHAT AVENUE IT COMES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FRANK MAC
WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION ARE SO SEE
ATION.
HAS BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH CDSS AND THE MANY ADVOCATE
PARTNERS INCLUDING --
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS AND THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN THE
PARTNERSHIP HAS BEEN REALLY
EXCELLENT.
AND THE STATE'S LEADERSHIP IN
THIS REGARD HIS BAND STELLAR AND
SO WE'VE BEEN.
INCREDIBLY PLEASED WITH ALL THE
WORK THAT EVERYONE'S BEEN DOING
VERY COLLABORATIVELY WE'VE ALSO
BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE AUTOMATION CONSORTIA --
THE THE STATE WHAT AUTOMATED
WELFARE SYSTEM CONSORTIA TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE WORKERS HAVE
PROPER AUTOMATION SUPPORT --
IN ORDER TO MEET THE JUNE FIRST
IMPLEMENTATION DEADLINE AND
SUPPORT COUNTY WORKERS.
WE'RE HAPPY TO REPORT SO FAR
THAT IMPLEMENTATION IS GENERALLY
GOING WELL AND WE'VE NOT
ENCOUNTERED.
ANY MAJOR PROBLEMS ARE BARRIERS.
YOU'VE HEARD SO FAR A LITTLE
SNAPSHOT OF THE INCREDIBLE
OUTREACH ACTIVITIES --
THAT COUNTIES IN THE STATE HAVE
BEEN ENGAGE LIKELY BE TO CLOSE
TO THE FOUR ONE POINT TWO
MILLION PEOPLE ON SSI.
BUT BROUGHT OUT REACH IS A
TERRIFIC STRATEGY FOR ENROLLING
ALL ELIGIBLE SSI RECIPIENTS.
BUT ALSO LEADS I THINK TO OUR
MOST SIGNIFICANT IMPLEMENTATION
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGE AND
THAT'S PROCESSING A VERY LARGE
VOLUME OF APPLICATIONS IN A VERY
SHORT.
WINDOW OF TIME --
WE WENT THROUGH US SOMEWHAT
COMPARABLE IMPLEMENTATION WHEN
WE IMPLEMENTED THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT.
AND PUT MILLIONS OF MORE PEOPLE
ON SUBSIDIZED HEALTH CARE THAN
BEFORE ME LEARNED MANY LESSONS
FROM THAT EXPERIENCE.
AND THE BIGGEST LESSON WE
LEARNED WAS THAT THE
UNANTICIPATED VOLUME --
CREATED ARE OUR MOST SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES AND SO THAT LEADS --
TO OUR BUDGET REQUEST ON THIS
REGARD OUR BUDGET REQUEST FALLS
INTO TWO CATEGORIES THE FIRST IS
A ONE TIME ASK A FIVE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS --
TO PROCESS THE APPLICATION
VOLUME.
THE BUDGET CURRENTLY INCLUDES
FUNDING TO PROCESS APPLICATIONS
FOR THE ANTICIPATED THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO WILL BE FOUND
ELIGIBLE.
BUT THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE
FUNDING FOR THE APPLICATIONS FOR
THOSE PEOPLE WHO DO APPLY BUT
WHO ULTIMATELY ARE NOT --
ELIGIBLE AND GIVEN THE EXPANSE
OF AN EXCELLENT OUT REACH WE DO
EXPECT THAT IN CASTING THE NET
AS WIDE AS POSSIBLE THERE WILL
BE A SIGNIFICANT VOLUME FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE ULTIMATELY NOT
FOUND ELIGIBLE.
AND THIS ONE TIME POT OF MONEY
WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
STAFF IN THE ABILITY TO SUPPORT
THE ACTIVITIES LIKE THOSE.
THAT YOU'VE HEARD IN LOS ANGELES
AND SO THAT WE EXTREMELY
VULNERABLE PEOPLE WAITING IN
COUNTY LOBBIES ARE WAITING FOR
SOMEONE TO ANSWER THE TELEPHONE
TO GET BENEFITS THAT COULD
LITERALLY BE LIFESAVING.
THE SECOND PART OF OUR ASK IS AN
ON GOING.
THE FUNDING OF TEN POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND AND
THIS IS A PRETTY SIMPLE REQUEST.
WE CAME TO AN AGREEMENT WITH THE
STATE LAST YEAR TO ESTIMATE HOW
MUCH WORK IS IT REALLY GOING TO
BE FOR COUNTIES ON AN ONGOING
BASIS. TO HANDLE THIS NEW
PROGRAM.
THE JANUARY BUDGET FUNDS THAT
ASSUMPTION.
BUT IT FUNDS IT AS IF IT WERE
THE YEAR.
TWO THOUSAND ONE SO THE UNIT
COST TO THAT THE COUNTIES ARE
BEING FUNDED FOR IS THE ACTUAL
THE FISCAL YEAR TWO THOUSAND TWO
THOUSAND ONE UNIT COST.
THAT IS A VESTIGE OF A RECESSION
ERA.
WE DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT TO DO
ABOUT OUR BUDGET SO WE'RE JUST
GONNA NOT ON THE COUNTIES THAT
THEIR ACTUAL COSTS.
AND IT'S A HOLDOVERS FROM FROM
FROM -- A BY
GONE ERA AND IT'S NOT AT ALL
REFLECTIVE I THINK OF THE
CURRENT COMMITMENT TO EVERYONE
AROUND THIS TABLE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE.
EXPECT FOR US TO IMPLEMENT THIS
PROGRAM CHANGE IF WE REALLY ARE
GOING TO COMMIT. TO IMPLEMENT
THIS BENEFIT IN THE WAY THAT WE
ALL AGREE IT NEEDS TO BE
IMPLEMENTED WE CAN'T FUND 60% OF
THE WORK AND WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION.
AND HELP THAT THAT GETS
ADDRESSED IN THE MAY REVISION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY OUT EARLIER THANK YOU --
MY CAROL AGAIN WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY --
JUST AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR TAKING --
SS I RECIPIENTS AND THE FOLKS
WHO HAD TRAVELED FROM OUT OF
TOWN --
EARLY IN THE AGENDA IT'S GREATLY
APPRECIATED AND SO GLAD THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO HEAR FROM THEM
TODAY -- SO
I'M GOING TO PILE ON ON ALL THE
PRAISE THAT YOU'RE HEARING --
FOR THE WORK OF THE DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES AND FOR THE
COUNTIES --%
IT REALLY HAS BEEN A GREAT
COLLABORATIVE I HAVE BEEN
TEASING MY COLLEAGUE CAM QUITE
WAY THAT WE DON'T WANT THIS TO
GO TO HER HEAD.
SHE YOU KNOW WE STILL HAVE A JOB
TO DO AND AND JUNE FIRST IS
STILL JUNEFIRST SO.
WE'RE ALL VERY HOPEFUL LOW WE
THINK THAT WE HAVE DONE AS GOOD
A JOB IN PREPARATION THAT I'VE
EXPERIENCED IN MY YEARS OF BEING
AN ADVOCATE IN SACRAMENTO AND
WHILE WE ARE.
WE KNOW WE'LL PROBABLY SEE A FEW
GLITCHES WE ARE REALLY HOPEFUL
AND THE RECIPIENTS AS YOU HEARD
MANY OF THEM SPEAK TO IT.
ARE REALLY EXCITED VERY EXCITED
AND VERY GRATEFUL I THINK FOR
THE CHANGE THE LEGISLATURE WAS
ABLE TO GET DONE LAST YEAR IN
THE BUDGET.
SO -- OUR
REQUEST --
ARE IT WHEN WE DID THIS LANGUAGE
LAST YEAR AS THOSE AND WHO WERE
ON THE COMMITTEE AND WORK ON THE
BUDGET NO IT CAME TOGETHER
FAIRLY LATE IN THE PROCESS --
AND THERE WAS A VERY INTENSE
PERIOD OF NEGOTIATION --
IN MAY LAST YEAR --
AND WE WERE ABLE TO GET THE
GOVERNOR THIS PROGRAM SO THAT
WAS THE LINCHPIN OF THE DEAL
COMING TOGETHER WAS TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
NO FAMILY WHO HAD NECESSARY
RECIPIENT WAS ALREADY ON SNAP
BENEFITS --
BECAME POORER DUE TO US
PROVIDING SNAP BENEFITS TO SS
RECIPIENTS AND THAT WAS CRITICAL
TO GETTING THE DEAL DONE.
I'M IN THE NEGOTIATIONS THAT
OCCURRED AROUND THAT THERE WERE
SOME THINGS THAT GOT.
DECIDED ON THAT I THINK IN
RETROSPECT WE MIGHT WANT TO READ
THIS AT ALL FIRST OF ALL WE'RE
VERY EXCITED THE GOVERNOR CAME
RIGHT OUT IN JANUARY.
AND MADE THIS A PER PROPOSED TO
MAKE THIS A PERMANENT PROGRAM.
AND YOU KNOW THAT WAS.
FRANKLY ONE OF OUR MAJOR BUDGET
ASK COMING INTO THIS YEAR AND SO
THE GOVERNOR PUT THAT ON THE
TABLE JANUARY ONE WE CERTAINLY
EMBRACE AND SUPPORT THAT.
WE THINK WITH THAT THEN WE
SHOULD ALSO --
ELIMINATE LANGUAGE FROM THE
STATUTE NOW THAT SAYS THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS NOT AN ENTITLEMENT
BECAUSE THAT IS WHY THAT
LANGUAGE WAS ADDED WAS BECAUSE
THE GOVERNOR WAS ONLY AT THAT
POINT WILLING TO COMMIT.
A POT OF MONEY HOPEFULLY FOR
ABOUT TWO YEARS THAT WOULD DO
THAT SO WE ARE ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE THOSE ABOUT
LANGUAGE OUT ANSWERED OTHER
LANGUAGE.
BUT AS WE HAVE ANOTHER ALL OUR
OTHER PHONE SINCE FOR THE
FAMILIES [inaudible]
TO I'M DID THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
CHANGE IS WE PUT ON VERY
RESTRICTIVE RULES ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS TO FAMILIES WHEN THEY
FALL OFF THE CASE LOAD --
AS WE KNOW AND CAL FRESH ABOUT
25% OF THE OF THE HOUSEHOLD TO
COME UP FOR RE DETERMINATION.
FALL OFF OF THE CASELOAD AT SOME
POINT SO THERE'S A LOT OF
TURNOVER IN THE PROGRAM WELL THE
WAY THIS PROGRAM IS STRUCTURED
ONE OF THEM --
REQUIRES THAT ANYONE A FALSE UP
ONLY GET THIRTY DAYS TO REAPPLY
AND IF THEY DON'T GET HIM IN
THAT.
THIRTY EIGHT THAT'S IT THEY LOSE
THAT CAL FOR THEY LOSE THAT HOLD
HARMLESS BENEFIT FOR EVER --
SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
REALLY WOULD LIKE TO SEE REVISIT
IT AND CHANGE SO THAT THOSE
RULES OPERATE JUST LIKE CAL
FRESH DOES IF SOMEBODY GOES OFF
THEY CAN COME BACK WHEN THEY'RE
READY TO REAPPLY GET READ A TERM
AND GO BACK ON TO THE HOLD
HARMLESS PROGRAMS.
AND THEN ONE OTHER THING THAT WE
ANOTHER THING THAT WE'RE LOOKING
TO GET DONE TO IS --
TO WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THEIR BE
PERSPECTIVE ENROLLMENT FOR THE
SMB IN THE TEAM BE PROGRAMS.
ON THE WAY THE PROGRAMS IS
WRITTEN OF GREAT STATUES WRITTEN
IS IF YOU DO NOT YOU MUST HAVE
AN SSI RECIPIENT IN YOUR
HOUSEHOLD ON JUNE ONE TWENTY
NINETEEN WHEN THE WHEN THE START
DATE IS.
AND IF YOU DON'T ANY FAMILY THAT
COMES AFTER THAT IS BARRED FROM
GETTING THESE BENEFITS SO OVER
TIME WHAT THIS IS GOING TO
CREATE IS A TWO YOU KNOW TO
CLASS SITUATION WHERE YOU HAVE
SOME FOLKS ARE GETTING A LITTLE
BIT MORE.
INCREASED AT AN EXACT SAME
HOUSEHOLD SAME INCOME SAME
CONSTRUCTION OR GET A GET LOWER
BENEFITS SO WE'RE ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO REVERSE THAT AND
TO HAVE JUST OPENED PERSPECTIVE
WE ACTUALLY THINK OVER TIME THIS
WATCH WE SIMPLIFY.
THE ROLE OF THE COUNTIES WHO
HAVE TO MAKE THESE
DETERMINATIONS AND KEEP TRACK OF
WHO WAS ON THE PROGRAM AND YOU
WANT WHO IS NOT ON THE PROGRAM
IN JUNE.
ONE IT'S REALLY A PAPER CHASE
THAT WERE ASKING THE DIFFICULT
THIS CHANGE WOULD ELIMINATE ALL
THE NEED FOR THAT --
AND THEN LASTLY WE WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT WE DID MAKE A CHANGE
ARE GOOD CHANGE LAST YEAR ALSO
WHERE WE ELIMINATED THE TEN
DOLLAR GAP BETWEEN CAPPY AND SS
I SS BE GRANTS --
BUT THERE'S LANGUAGE IN THERE
THAT DOESN'T MAKE THAT PERMANENT
AND WE WOULD PROPOSE THAT THAT
BE MADE PERMANENT IN THIS BUDGET
TRAILER BILL ALSO SO THOSE ARE
THE **** OF A OF THE ADVOCATES.
AS WE GO FORWARD AGAIN THANK IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF THE COUNTIES
FOR ALL THEIR INCREDIBLE WORK --
OVER THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS.
THANK YOU.
AND SHANE THANK YOU SO MUCH
BETTER CHAIR --
SO I DID I'M HERE TO SPEAK --
MORE TO THE THEY CALPERS
EXPANSION SSI SIDE --
FROM THE OTHER PERSPECTIVE I DO
THE WANT TO ACKERMAN ALSO
CELEBRATE THIS IS HER EXPANSION
IT'S ONLY BEEN A PROFESSIONAL
PRIVILEGE OF MINE PEOPLE TO GO
TO CONFERENCES AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
AND REALLY HEAR THE PRAISE TO
THE LEGISLATURE TO THE GOVERNOR
TO THE TO THE DEPARTMENT AND
COUNTIES FOR THE TREMENDOUS WORK
FOR CALIFORNIA TO FINALLY GET
THIS DONE AND TO DO IN A WAY
THAT IS MORE ACCURATE THAN ANY
OTHER SEATED WITH A HOLD
HARMLESS PROGRAMS AND SO I JUST.
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
MESSAGE IS BROUGHT BACK ON TO
THIS ROOM --
SIMILARLY I WANT TO THANK TO
DETERMINE IF COUNTIES AND CAT
AND COUNTY TO WORKING FOR THE
HARD AND ENGAGE AS FULLY AS
ADVOCATES WE HAVE BEEN.
BROUGHT THAT IS A KEY
STAKEHOLDER AND HONESTLY JUNE
FIRST -- GO
LIVE ON THIS AND I REALLY WANT
TO THANK HIM FOR ALL OF THE WORK
AND THEIR ENGAGEMENT ON THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AS CAN
MENTION BRIEFLY HAS PRODUCED A
CLEAR GOAL TO ENROLL 75% OF THE
ESTIMATED.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND OF FOLKS
WILL BE FOUND ELIGIBLE TO THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND I'M OUT
OF THAT OUT A CASELOAD AND A
CLEAR ROADMAP THE FIRST TO GET
THERE WITH SUCCESS --
THE FREE MARKET SOLUTIONS LIKE
ELECTRIC THE ELECTRONIC
SIGNATURE OVER THE PHONE
FLEXIBLE INTERVIEWS AT OTHER
PROVEN SOLUTIONS THAT WILL
BENEFIT NOT JUST FOLKS RUN ASIDE
BUT ANYONE WHO'S APPLYING AND
TRYING TO REMAIN ON THE COVERAGE
PROGRAM.
BUT WE KNOW THAT IN THAT SHORT
YEAR ESPECIALLY AS MIKE
MENTIONED THAT WE INSISTED AS
ADVOCATES UPON HAVING TO TO HOLD
HOMELESS PROGRAMS WHICH ARE
TAKING UP A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF THE AUTOMATION.
TIME AND RESOURCES WE KNOW THAT
IT'S GONNA TAKE TIME TO
IMPLEMENT THAT THAT FRAMEWORK
FOR EXAMPLE MYSTICS MENTION THE
GREAT WORK THAT AT LEAST DOING
TO EXPAND --
ELECTRONIC SIGNATURE OVER THE
PHONE WE KNOW THAT OTHER
COUNTIES ARE LOOKING AT
EMBRACING A CULTURE OF
ELIGIBILITY ETCETERA SOME OF
THOSE TAKE FINANCIAL RESOURCES
AND SOME OF THEM SIMPLY TAKE
TIME TO IMPLEMENT AND TIME IS.
IS REALLY OF THE ESSENCE RIGHT
NOW AT THE SAME TIME YOU YOU
HEARD BRIEFLY ABOUT SOME OF THE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES --
MISTER MIKE WAS TALKING ABOUT
AND I CERTAINLY WE SAW TODAY
EVIDENCE OF THE INCREDIBLE NEEDS
THE BARRIERS FOLKS ARE GOING TO
HAVE AN APPLYING FOR THIS
BENEFIT TRANSPORTATION SOME OF
THE LANGUAGE ACCESS ADA
COMPLIANT IT IS GOING TO BE A
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGE. TO ENROLL
AND PROCESS ALL THESE
APPLICATIONS --
AND SO ARE ASKED TODAY ON ON
THIS SITE ON THE COVERAGE
EXPANSION IS FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO REMAIN ENGAGED WE CERTAINLY
PROVIDED SOME QUESTIONS WHICH
REFLECTED THE LA --
HAS AS WELL --
AND I KNOW THAT THE COUNTIES AND
STATE THAT ROLLS OFF THE GO
THROUGH THIS WHEN I JUNE FIRST
THANK YOU --
TO CALL OF TYLER WOULD SO WE CAN
MAKE ROOM
.
TIGER WOODS PARMA FINANCE I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE A COMMENT AT
THIS TIME AND ON A THE PROPOSAL
SO THE EXTENT THESE BECOME A
PRIORITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
WERE HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN
DISCUSSIONS AND PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
THANK YOU.
AS WE OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC --
THERE'S ONLY FOUR OF YOU.
THEN I'M NOT GOING TO SAY ALL
THE LIMITATIONS I WAS GOING TO
ADD ON WHAT I WAS GOING TO SAY
IS THAT I DOUBTS BECAUSE YOU
GIVE YOU PUBLIC COMMENT BECAUSE
I WANT.
TO BE FAIR TO THOSE WHO HAVE
THEY WANT TO YOU WANT TO BE HERE
BUT YOU WANT TO GO HOME AT SOME
POINT TONIGHT SLEEP IN YOUR OWN
BED.
SO LET'S LIMITED IT IF YOU'RE IF
YOU.
LIKE THIS YOU DON'T LIKE IT --
YOUR NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION.
CHAPTER TO GEAR AN ACTIVE
PARTICIPANT IN THIS FROM THE
START.
AND CONTINUING TO SUPPORT THIS.
AND A GOOD.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S THE WAY TO DO IT.
RUSSELL RAWLINGS RESOURCES FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING WE ARE A CAT
CA FOR SSI MEMBER AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK THAT
THE SS WAS TRYING TO GET US TO
THIS POINT.
WE ARE ALSO PROUD THAT WE WILL
SOON BE A CAL FRESH OF SISTER SO
WE'RE REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
THIS ENTIRE PROCESS WE ALSO
STRONGLY SUPPORT --
MAKING AS ANTEON BE PERMANENT
ENTITLEMENTS AND ALSO THE CAPPY
BENEFIT AND ENTITLEMENT FOR
UNDOCUMENTED BROTHERS AND
SISTERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANOTHER SONG FOR US
NO.
I WAS LOOKING FORWARD TO IT.
I I DIDN'T THINK OF ONE I'M I'M
GETTING TIRED --
I'M SHEILA GUN CUSHMAN FROM --
HE PROBABLY.
A BENEFICIARY OF THIS --
I'VE BEEN FRUSTRATED THAT AS A
SIGN NICKEL AND DIMES US EVERY
TIME WE DO ANYTHING WITH WORK.
AND I HOPE THAT SOMEDAY THAT
CHANGES I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE
FOOD STAMPS BANG THE SNAP
WHATEVER.
I CAN'T KEEP UP WITH IT.
THE CALIFORNIA STAYING.
OUT BUT I AM TALKING ABOUT I AM
ALSO TAYLOR I AM ALSO TERRIFIED.
AND THE REASON I'M TERRIFIED IS
BECAUSE BEING TOTALLY BLIND.
NOT OWNING A PRINTER.
NOT READING PRINT EVER I HSS
ISN'T PAID TO READ PRINT TO OR
TO WRITE PRINT AND THEREFORE TO
LIABILITY FOR ANY WORKER WHO
DOES SO.
AND THEREFORE I DON'T LET THEM.
I AND SS I THE SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION IS SUPPOSED TO
SEND ME BRAILLE LETTERS
SOMETIMES THEY DO SOMETIMES THEY
DON'T.
AS A FOLLOW UP THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO CALL ME.
A SOMETIMES THEY DO SOMETIMES
THEY DON'T I WILL BE GOING.
TO SEE A FOR SSI AND LOOK UP ALL
THIS NEW STUFF TRY TO CATCH UP
WITH IT.
WHAT I AM DEEPLY TERRIFIED ABOUT
IS I'M ALSO A CAL TOOLS PERSON
I'M ON MEDICARE AND MEDICAID
I'LL?
THAT WHOLE PROCESS WAS A NIGHT
MARE.
I DON'T WANT TO RELIVE IT.
I WANT I AM I'M GOING TO DO SOME
MAGIC HERE.
A FULL TRANSITION.
EXCELLENT SMOOTHS SAILING.
FULL EIGHTY A ACCESS WAS
ALTERNATIVE FORMAT DOCUMENTS IN
ELECTRONIC FORMAT.
SECURE WEBSITES WHEN NECESSARY
LOTS OF FOLLOW UP LOTS OF OUR
REACH AND A WHOLE LOT OF CLEAR
INFORMATION.
SO THAT WE CAN RESPOND QUICKLY
AND CORRECTLY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LET ME SANTOS ON BEHALF OF SCA
YOU STATE COUNCIL REPRESENTING
THE ELIGIBILITY WORKERS WHO DO
ALL OF THE ELIGIBILITY WORK IN
ENROLLMENT WORK THAT WILL BE.
UNDERTAKEN WITH THIS HUGE
ENORMOUS UNDERTAKING HERE TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BUDGET
AUGMENTATION REQUEST BY --
CW DA BOTH FOR ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION AN ONGOING
AUGMENTATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE WORKERS THEY REPRESENT CAN
DO THE WORK THAT IS NECESSARY TO
IMPLEMENT THIS NEW WORKLOAD
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR KERR CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA I
JUST WANT TO TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY AS WELL TO THANK THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE COUNTIES FOR
ALL OF THE EFFORT THAT THEY'VE --
MADE THUS FAR IN ROLLING OUT
THIS PROGRAM THERE'S PROBABLY NO --
ISSUE THAT'S MEETING WITH MORE
ANTICIPATION IN OUR OFFICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAN THIS PROGRAM.
SO WITH THAT WE ARE --
PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THE THE ADMINISTRATION'S BCP THE
COUNTIES --
REQUEST --
AND ALL OF THOSE ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED BY THE
ADVOCATES THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANKS TRACY PATTERSON
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES
AS PART OF CA FOR SSII'M JUST
WANT TO SUPPORT ALL OF THESE
PROPOSALS AND AGAIN KEEP ON THE
PRAISE FOR EVERYBODY FOR ALL THE
PLANNING --
AND JUST FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON
THE THE REAL NEED FOR
CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE STATE IN
TERMS OF ACCESS I'M SAN
BERNADINO IT'S BEEN A REAL
LEADER IN THIS AREA.
I'M LOOKING AT THE BAY AREA
THERE'S YOU KNOW SOME SPOTS WERE
ALAMEDA COUNTY WILL TAKE PHONE
APPLICATIONS CONTRA COSTA AND
SELANNE COULD NOT --
AND WE KNOW WORD OF MOUTH IN
PEOPLE'S LIVES DON'T LIVE WITHIN
COUNTY BOUNDARIES AND SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS RECOGNIZE COUNTIES
HAVE DIFFERENT CAPACITY ISSUES
FOR INDIVIDUALS IT'S AN EQUITY
ISSUE.
MOST AS A SITE PLANTS CAN'T JUST
UP AND MOVE TO A DIFFERENT
COUNTY I'M SO WE REALLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS GREAT
FRAMEWORK OF SOLUTIONS AVAILABLE
STATEWIDE MORE EXCITING THAT
EXCITED THAT THE FUNDING WILL
ALLOW US TO ENROLL 75% OF US IS
LIKE CLIENTS.
BY SEPTEMBER.
TWENTY TWENTY THANK YOU --
MULLIN DROP I GOT REAL CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS WHO IS ELIGIBLE IN
WHO IS NOT ELIGIBLE.
BRAK CALIBRATION WHEN IT COMES A
ROLL OUT.
I HAVE HEARD NOTHING ABOUT THAT.
NOW LIKE TO HEAR SOMETHING ABOUT
WHERE IS YOUR WEBSITE I CAN GO.
TO WHO [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO GOOD EVENING I'M IN A WIDER
HER WELL WITH HERE CALIFORNIA.
WE REPRESENT OLDER CALIFORNIANS
AND ON THIS ISSUE ONE OF OUR
CONCERNS IS AN OLDER
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE LOW SOME
OF THE LOWEST TAKE UP RATES IN
TERMS OF CAL FRESH.
SO WE'RE JUST YET OR EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE APPLICATION
PROPOSALS ESPECIALLY ON THE
FUNDING FOR THE RAMPED UP IN
ROME MOMENT THAT WAS JUST
DISCUSSED.
AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR ENHANCED OUTREACHTO
POTENTIAL RECIPIENTS THANK YOU.
THANK THANK YOU.
JUSTIN GARRETT CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT OF THE C. WDAS FOR
INCREASED FUNDING FOR COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION THIS --
INCREASE FUNDING WILL HELP
ENSURE THE SUPPORT INITIATIVE IS
IMPLEMENTED AS EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTS THAT'S THE END OF
PUBLIC COMMENT TO ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MY MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT I WANT TO ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS OF EVERYBODY ELSE AND
TO GIVE SPECIAL THANKS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE DEMONSTRATION
FOR ALL THE WORK YOU'VE DONE TO
PREPARE TO IMPLEMENT THIS
EXPANSION.
OF CALPERS SSI RECIPIENTS. FOR
MANY IN OUR FIELD OF HUMAN
SERVICES THIS IS A PROFOUND
MOMENT AS WE SEEK TO SERVE
SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES.
THERE ARE NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
WE THINK ABOUT IS WERE.
GOING INTO THIS BIG ENDEAVOR AND
IT THERE ARE.
A FEW QUESTIONS THAT HAVE COME
UP IN A FEW QUESTIONS THAT THAT
WILL REMAIN AND I KNOW THAT --
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE
ENGAGED I I DO HAVE ONE AND THAT
IS HOW WILL DSS REGULARLY
COMMUNICATE IMPLEMENTATION
CHALLENGES AND SUCCESSES WITH
THE LEGISLATURE.
SURE -- WE
HAVE --
THREE SYSTEMS IN PLACE RIGHT NOW
WHICH IS THE BI MONTHLY ALL
STAKEHOLDER MEETING THAT WE HAVE
THAT'S OPEN TO ALL ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE SEEM TO BECOMING
THESE DAYS I SUSPECT THE ONE IN
JUNE MIGHT BE A VERY WELL
ATTENDED --
WE ALSO HAVE A MONTHLY WRITTEN
UPDATE I'M AS ROBERT MENTION WE
HAVE A WEBSITE CAL PRECIOUS
ASIDE RIGHT NOW WE'RE THAT THE
MONTHLY UPDATED STATUS UPDATE.
AND I THINK WHAT'S GOING TO BE
VERY INTERESTING FOR ALL FOLKS
IS THE CAL FRESH DATA DASHBOARD
WHICH IS ON THE CDS AS WEB PAGE
NOW AND TRACKS NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS APPROVED
APPLICATIONS PEOPLE SERVED.
WE ARE MOVING TO ADD AN SSI
BUTTON IF YOU WILL TO THAT SO
WE'LL HAVE AS A SITE DATA.
AVAILABLE THE STATE LEVEL AND BY
COUNTY OF COURSE.
THE MONTH OF JUNE WILL KNOW
SOMETIME MID LATE JULY SO THERE
ARE SOME TIMING ISSUES AND
FIGURING OUT WHAT DAY IS
AVAILABLE MONTHLY QUARTERLY AND
ANNUALLY BUT WE ARE ALL VERY
MINDFUL THAT OUT THE EYES.
OF ALL STAKEHOLDERS ALL CLIENTS --
MAYBE SOME OF PEOPLE THE NATION
ARE ON US AND WE'LL BE DOING OUR
VERY BEST TO REMAIN TRANSPARENT
AND ACCOUNTABLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO ASK. FOR
ASSISTANCE FROM THE LA --
ON FOLLOWING UP ON THE QUESTIONS
IN THE ONGOING METRICS THAT WILL
BE USED TO RIP OF THE REPORTING.
AND THE OVERSIGHT I'LL KEEP
TALKING AS YOU'RE WALKING
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU CAN DO BOTH.
SO CAN I ASK THE LA --
TO WORK WITH DSS THE COUNTIES IN
THE ADVOCATES ON SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORT LANGUAGE.
THAT COULD BE ADOPTED AS PART OF
THE 200-019-2000 TWENTY X.
BUDGET.
PROVIDE PARAMETERS FOR NEAR TERM
OVERSIGHT OVER THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE EXTENSION
OF CAL FIRST BENEFITS TO THE S.
ASIDE POPULATION.
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOUR STAFF --
AND FACILITATE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU AND ON
THE ISSUE OF STATUTORY CHANGES
THAT REFLECT THE ONGOING FUNDING.
FOR HOLD HARMLESS.
IF ADVOCATES ALSO CAN PLEASE
CIRCULATE YOUR DRAFT --
TBL AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
REQUESTING FEEDBACK FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION.
AND PROVIDING UPDATED DIVERSIONS
TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE THAT WOULD
HELP TO FACILITATE MAXIMUM
EXPOSURE AND DIALOGUE.
ON THE LANGUAGE PRIOR TO ANY
ACTION THE CAN BE TAKEN --
IT AT THE AT THE MAY REVISE.
WE'D BE PLEASED TO WORK WITH YOU
ON THIS US.
MADAM CHAIR --
AND WE'VE ALREADY BEEN REACHING
OUT TO THE COUNTIES AND OTHERS
AND DISCUSSING OR KILL THE
LANGUAGE WILL BE SITTING DOWN
WITH THE STATE IN SHORT ORDER.
WONDERFUL WELL THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE FEEL GOOD --
TO MOMENTS AND I APPRECIATE ALL
THAT YOU'VE DONE AND YOU COULD
TELL FROM THE COMMENTS THAT.
FINALLY LOOK WE GOT ONE RIGHT
LITTLE LATE BUT WE GOT ONE RIGHT
WE'RE FINALLY CATCHING UP WITH
EVERYBODY ELSE RELATED NEVER
THAT'S RIGHT THANK YOU FOR THE
HARD WORK ON THIS.
ALL RIGHT.
THOSE WERE THE TWO WE TOOK OUT
OF ORDER SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO
GO BACK.
TO ISSUE NUMBER. FOUR THREE
ISSUE NUMBER.
THREE I CHEST IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE ETV THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
EXCUSE ME BEFORE YOU ALL LEAVE --
JOB CAN WE IF THE CALL ON ISSUE
ONE ISSUE.
ONE MR FRAZIER.
MR FRAZIER AYE AND I ALREADY.
THANK CHAIRMAN OF WE DO SORRY.
ALL RIGHT --
DIRECTOR LARRY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FELT WEIRD BERMAN A SOCIAL
SERVICES --
AS COLLEGE SEARCH SITTING DOWN
HERE QUICKLY --
I JUST WANTED TO REITERATE ONE
OF THE ISSUES IF WE START TO
TALK ABOUT THE BACKGROUND FIVE
FOR THE ELECTRONIC THIS
VERIFICATION THAT --
FUTURE VICTIM MENTIONED IN HIS
OPENING REMARKS AND AND THAT IS
SOME CONFUSION THAT WE HEARD A
LOT LAST WEEK DURING OUR SENATE
HEARING --
THERE WAS A LOT OF TREPIDATION
AND AND CONCERN AND FEAR ON THE
PART OF PROVIDERS AND AND
CLIENTS --
ABOUT THIS NEW SYSTEM REQUIRING
PEOPLE TO CHECK IN AND CHECK OUT
EACH DAY AS IF IT WERE A TIME
CLOCK.
AND AND GIVEN THE NATURE OF OF
MY EXPECTATION AND THAT IS NOT.
WHAT THE DEPARTMENT IT'S BEEN
WORKING WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS TO
TRY AND PROPOSED SWITCHES WANTED
TO TRY AND A LAY SOME OF THAT
FEAR THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
CAN BE FILLED OUT ON A DAILY
BASIS OR IF THAT IS NOT A
CONVENIENT OR INAPPROPRIATE OR
OR THAT PEOPLE ARE?
ABLE TO DO THAT THEY CAN DO IT
EVERY TWO DAYS THREE DAYS UP TO
ONCE EVERY TWO WEEKS WHEN
THEY'RE ACTUALLY DOING IT WE'RE
ALSO REALLY TRYING TO CREATE
SYSTEMS THAT ALLOW --
FOR CLIENT AND AND I'M SORRY FOR
PROVIDER FLEXIBILITY TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR THE PROVIDERS TO DO
IT EITHER THROUGH THE COMPUTER
OR BY THE PHONE
AND TRYING TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO
DO THAT AND THE WAY THAT AGAIN
MAKES IT THE EASIEST FOR THEM SO
IF THAT'S DOING IT EVERY DAY.
THAN THAN THAT IS THAT THE BEST
THE MOST APPROPRIATE WAY AND SO
WITH THAT I'M GONNA TRANSFER
THIS TRANSITION BACK TO PETE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEC THANK YOU --
YOU HAVE A A FROM US --
ANOTHER POWER POINT PRESENTATION
ON THE HATCH IS AS PROGRAM I'M
ALSO NOT GOING TO GO THROUGH
THAT ONE FOR YOU BUT I WILL
POINT YOU.
ADD TO THE DISCUSSION THAT
BEGINS ON PAGE SEVENTEEN OF THAT
DOCUMENT.
IT SIMPLY PROVIDES THE ACTUAL
FEDERAL REQUIREMENT FOR THIS --
AND AS DIRECTOR --
ACTING DIRECTOR LARRY SAD SEEN A
PAPER TIME SHEET WITH EITHER AN
INTERNET BASED OPTION OR A
TELEPHONE OPTION FOR THOSE TIME
SHEETS.
THEY'LL BE A MOBILE TELEPHONE
OUT FOR THAT AS WELL --
PAGE EIGHTEEN DESCRIBES THE SIX
DATA ELEMENTS THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REQUIRES --
WERE LARGELY COMPLIANT WITH THAT
EXCEPT FOR THE TWO THAT ARE
ASTERIX --
THEY WANT THE TIME THAT THE SIR --
SERVICES FOR THE DAY BEGAN AND
ENDED AND THEY WANT THE LOCATION
OF THOSE SERVICES --
ARE PROVIDED ALL REITERATE
BRIEFLY --
DID THAT --
AS I SAID IN MY OPENING REMARKS
THAT LOCATION DATA IS THREE
CHECKED BOXES IT'S IN HOME AND
COMMUNITY OR BOTH.
SO WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE NOT ASKING
ANYBODY TO BE TRACKED AND
MONITORED OR FOLLOWED AROUND OR
HAVE SOME.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU GO EXERCISE
AND FALLS WHERE YOU'VE BEEN
THAT'S NOT AT ALL WHAT WE'RE
AFTER HERE.
THERE'S SOME GUIDING PRINCIPLES
ON PAGE NINETEEN THAT HAVE BEEN
PART OF EVERY RIG STAKEHOLDER --
ENGAGEMENT THAT WE'VE HAD --
THAT OBVIOUSLY CONSISTENT --
THAT WE'RE USING OUR EXISTING
ELECTRONIC SERVICES PORTAL --
AND OUR EXISTING TELEPHONE TIME
SHEETS SYSTEM AS THE PLATFORM
FOR COMPLIANCE THESE ARE
FAMILIAR TOOLS THERE WILL BE --
ASKING PEOPLE TO EXPAND THEIR
USE OF WE'RE COMMITTED TO
ADEQUATE TRAINING IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF ALL OF THESE
FUNCTIONALITY IS THERE'S BEEN
HEAVY STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WITH THE
UNIONS AND PROVIDERS.
AND WITH RECIPIENTS --
ALTHOUGH NOBODY WOULD EVERYBODY
I THINK WOULD PREFER NOT TO BE
DOING ANY TV THAT RECOGNIZE THE
GIVEN THE FEDERAL MANDATE WE'RE
DOING THE ABSOLUTE BEST THAT WE
POSSIBLY CAN IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE.
AND WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL FOR
THE PART --
PARTNERSHIP IN DEVELOPING THOSE
PAGE TWENTY PROVIDES A SCHEDULE
OF THE DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES --
WE WILL BE ROLLING OUT WAS
STAKEHOLDERS OUR NEXT --
LARGE STAKEHOLDER MEETING --
IS MARCH TWENTY NINE OF THIS
MONTH --
WHERE WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT AN
IMPLEMENTATION SCHEDULE --
THAT BEGINS JULY FIRST --
WITH WITH THESE TOOLS AND MOVES
THROUGH --
THIS IS GOING TO BE HERE OF A WE
DON IN A ROLLING MANNER ACROSS
THE STATE SIMILAR TO THE WAY
WE'VE DONE MANY CHANGES IN OUR
PROGRAM.
YOU CAN'T DO BIG BANG WITH ONE
POINT THREE MILLION PEOPLE WE
KNOW THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO TRY --
I AM HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS --
THAT OUR COMMITMENT TO
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AS LONG
STANDING ON GOING HERE THIS
NEEDS TO WORK WE KNOW THAT IT'S
A BIG CHANGE FOR PEOPLE IN THE
WAY THAT THE PROGRAM IS DEATH --
HISTORICALLY DONE ITS BUSINESS.
WE THINK THERE ARE SOME SIDE
BENEFITS LIKE TAKING PAPER OUT
OF THE TIME SHE PROCESS IMPROVES
THE SPEED OF OUR PAYROLL PROCESS
FOR EXAMPLE SO THERE ARE SOME
ANCILLARY BENEFITS --
BUT WE'RE ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED
TO DOING THIS IN A WAY THAT
MEETS BOTH THE FEDERAL NEED AS
WELL AS THE NEEDS OF THE
CONSUMERS AND PROVIDERS THAT
RELY ON US. TO MEET THE BASICS
OF THEIR DAILY --
ACTIVITIES [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SYDNEY TANIMOTO.
SENATE HAVE A DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THE MINISTRATIONS PROPOSAL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHECK APRIL.
ZERO NO CONCERNS AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
OKAY CAN WELCOME BEVERAGE THIS
TYPE HI MICHELLE ROSY CONSUMER
ADVOCATE --
EVEY V. OF STATUTORY PROTECTIONS
AND OUTREACH ACTIVITIES THE
COALITION LAST YEAR REACHED
AGREEMENT.
I WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
LANGUAGE OF THE SENATE BILL
EIGHT FORTY TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WHICH INCLUDED REPORT
PROTECTIONS FOR HSS CLIENTS.
AND PROVIDERS AGAINST
UNNECESSARY BURDEN INTRUSION AS
THIS STATE DEVELOPED ITS EBV
PROTOCOLS.
WE RESPECTIVELY --
SOLICITORS TAKE FURTHER STEPS TO
ENSURE THE SAME PROTECTIONS OF
THE WELFARE INSTITUTIONS CODE SO
THAT THEY BECOME PERMITTED.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUZZER POSES. TEN
POINT FOUR MILLION TOTAL FUNDING
FOR EBV OUTREACH ACTIVITIES BY
COUNTY PUBLIC AUTHORITIES
CONSUMER ORGANIZATIONS HSS
UNIONS WE'RE WAITING ON CDS TO
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION OTHER
SECTIONS FOR THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
SO THAT.
WE HAVE SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS
THE WHO ARE BLIND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES TAKE AWAY FROM
HAVING A PAPER SYSTEM.
WILL -- TAKE
AWAY FROM THEIR ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO DO THE TIME SHEETS IN
SOME CASES AND THE CURRENT FUSS
SYSTEM HAS A LOT TO BE FIXED
WHEN IT COMES TO USE IT IF FOR
EASY V..
EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE TAKING AWAY
THE PAPER SYSTEM.
THAT RECIPIENT VITAL STILL HAVE
THE ABILITY TO PRINT PAST TIME
SHEETS AND KEEP THEIR RECORDS.
AND CDS AS HAS MET MOST OF THE
REQUESTED REGARDING COPIES IT
HAD HAD A RECORD DALY TYPE SHE'S
SO FIRST.
FUNDING FOR EDUCATION A SENIORS
AND OTHERS WHO ARE AFRAID OF
COMPUTERS IS GREATLY NEEDED.
I CAN'T EMPHASIZE THIS ENOUGH A
LOT OF OUR SENIORS AND IT NOT
ONLY IN BIG CITIES BUT RURAL
AREAS JUST DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
COMPUTERS.
AND OR A SYSTEM THAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO NOW IMPLEMENT TO TAKE
US AWAY FROM OUR PAPER
IMPLEMENTATION FOR EBV --
SO HOW WE DO OUR OUTREACH TO
THESE GROUPS IS GOING TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT.
THE INFINITE LEVIN IMPLANTATION
OVER ALL OVER ALL HAVING SUCCESS
OUT SUCCESSFUL OUTCOMES FOR
RECIPIENTS AND THE PROVIDERS.
THERE IS GOING TO BE STILL BE
MANY ISSUES THAT WILL NEED TO BE
JOINTLY WORKED OUT WITH CONSUMER
GROUPS -- A
AND I ATE I REALLY WANT TO SAY
THAT THEY REALLY HAVE REACHED
OUT TO OUR CONSUMER GROUPS AND I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THAT.
BUT SO MUCH MORE IS NEEDED AT
THE END I CAN'T THERE'S WE NEED
TO BE THAT WHAT I'VE WHAT
EDUCATION WITH OUR CONSUMERS ARE
PROVIDERS.
BECAUSE WE ARE SWITCHING AWAY
FROM THE PAPER OF OF TIME SHEET
SYSTEM.
THE I CAN'T SAY ENOUGH THAT THAT
THAT REALLY NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
AND IT NEEDS TO HAPPEN IN A
BIGGER WAY THAN WE HAVE EVER
DONE BEFORE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES MS RUBIO I JUST WANT TO MAKE
A COMMENT ON THAT BECAUSE I'M
DRIVING NUMBER LAST YEAR AND I
DON'T MAY MAY NOT HAVE BEEN THE
SAME ISSUE BY.
BUT WE WERE HAVING PROBLEMS WITH
THE THE PAPER TIME SHEETS I
REMEMBER THAT A GROUP CAME AND
THAT THEY WERE SENDING IN THE
TIME SHEETS AND THEY WERE
GETTING PAID FOR A MONTH IN
ADVANCE SOMETIME SHEETS WERE.
YOU KNOW CONSIDERED LATE IT WAS
A BIG --
MESSEL I I AGREE WITH YOU THAT
WE HAVE TO DO THE EDUCATION BUT
I THINK THIS IS A BETTER SYSTEM
BECAUSE I REMEMBER LAST YEAR
THERE WAS A WHOLE BUNCH OF
COMPLAINTS ABOUT.
THE TIME SHEETS NOT ONLY BEING
OUTDATED BY THE FOLKS WERE NOT
BEING PAID ON TIME SO IF WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER ON ON HOW.
TO YOU KNOW STREAMLINED THAT
SYSTEM AND YOU'RE RIGHT EDUCATE
THE COMMUNITY THE COMMUNITY OR
THE FOLKS ARE GONNA BE AFFECTED
BY THE YOU KNOW ON OUR SIDE I
HEARD THE COMPLAINTS ABOUT.
YOU KNOW THE TIME SHEETS NOT
BEING EFFECTIVE AND AND BEING
LOST IN PEOPLE NOT GETTING PAID
ON TIME SO FOR ME THE CONCERN.
IS IS YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY FOR THE
IT COMMUNITY EDUCATION RIGHT
THINK THIS MIGHT BE A BETTER
SYSTEM SO THAT FOLKS GET PAID ON
TIME [inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY ABSOLUTELY.
YEAH.
THEY'RE ALSO TALKING ABOUT A
PHONE SYSTEMS AT THAT TAKING
AWAY FROM THE PLACES THAT
CURRENT FILE SYSTEM IS NOT A
REALLY GOOD.
SYSTEM SO WHATEVER THEY DO AND
WHAT IS THE PROBABLY EIGHTY
MAYBE IT THE PHONE SYSTEM NEEDS
TO BE WORKED ON A FIXED FOR IT
TO BE INCLUDED IN THAT EBV
SYSTEM.
TO SELL IT ALL AROUND IT THERE'S
GONNA BE A LOT MORE WORK TO DO
BEFORE THEY DESERVE TO LIVE.
ABSOLUTELY AND I THINK IF I'M
HEARING YOU TO BE PATIENT
BECAUSE WE KNOW WITH ANY BIG
CHANGES LIKE THAT THERE'S ALWAYS
GOING TO BE PROBLEMS IN THE
BEGINNING AND SO WHEN I DO ASK
IF YOU HAVE PROBLEMS PLEASE LET
US KNOW DON'T LET US HERE.
YOU KNOW ABOUT THE ISSUES YOU
KNOW AND COMMITTEE ON LET US
KNOW KEEP US --
IN THE LOOP ON HOW IT'S GOING
BECAUSE MY LAST THING WE WANT IS
TO BE BE HERE NEXT MARTIN HERE
BUT ALL THESE.
ISSUES NOT BEING ADDRESSED A
GREAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AND NOW I BELIEVE RANDY WOLF IS
GOING TO INTRODUCE CONNIE BARKER.
I BRANDY WILL FIND THE STATEWIDE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR SEIU LOCAL
TWENTY FIFTEEN AS MENTIONED
EARLIER WE REPRESENT ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND I
HSS PROVIDERS IN. THIRTY SEVEN
OF THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES --
CONNIE PARKER IS HERE A PROVIDER
FROM MARIN COUNTY TO TESTIFY ON
THE DVD.
THANK YOU AS WELL.
THANK YOU --
BEFORE'S READING MY PREPARED
REMARKS I JUST WANT TO ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH EVERY WORD SHE SAID
ABOUT PAPER TIME SHEETS AND THE
THE ISSUES THAT THE TRANSIT THAT
THAT TRANSITION IS GOING.
TO CREATE FOR EVERYONE AND ABOUT
THAT THIS FUNCTIONALITY OF THE
CURRENT PHONE SYSTEM --
THE SERVER.
YOU KNOW.
THAT THE THESE ARE WHAT I WAS
PREPARED TO SPEAK ON BUT AS LONG
AS SOMEONE SAID IT I'M GOING TO
SAVE A YOUNG MAN OKAY.
HI -- SO MY
NAME IS CONNIE BURKE FROM AND I
JUST AS PROVIDER IN MARIN COUNTY
ALSO WORK IN SANTA CLARA --
OUR UNION --
AS HE MAINE'S STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO EA VV I WANT TO SAY THAT
FIRST JUST SO THAT THERE'S NO IT
HOME CONFUSION ABOUT THAT WITH
OUR MEMBERS --
BUT WE'RE WELL AWARE OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S ONGOING
REQUIREMENTS ABOUT SUCH
REGULATIONS WHICH UNFORTUNATELY.
A DEPENDING ON HOW THEY ARE
ROLLED OUT CAN VIOLATE THE
PRIVACY OF BOTH HOME CARE
RECIPIENTS AND ALSO PROVIDE
THEIR CARE.
AND WHICH IN MANY PLACES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ARE ALREADY
COMPROMISING THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE PROGRAMS DESIGNED TO MEET
THE PERSONAL ASSISTANCE NEEDS OF
THIS NATION SENIOR SOME PEOPLE'S
WITH THIS A BIT AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
NEEDS WHICH WHICH IT IS THEIR
RIGHT UNDER THE OLMSTEAD
DECISION TO HAVE MET IN THEIR
OWN HOMES. FOR THIS REASON IT IS
VITAL THAT THE PROTECTIONS FOR
CONSUMERS AND PROVIDERS --
AS REGARDING EVEY V. WHICH
CALIFORNIA'S SO WISELY AND
APPROPRIATELY ADOPTED LAST YEAR
AS PART OF THE BUDGET BILL
BECAUSE OF FIGHT INTO LAW THIS
YEAR. TO REVIEW.
THESE PROJECTS --
PROTECTIONS INCLUDED SUCH THINGS
AS SEEN TO IT THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS DEBATE
CONTINUES TO BE DEVELOPED
THROUGH A COLLABORATIVE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
THAT IT BE DONE IN A WAY THAT IS
IS MINIMALLY BURDENSOME AS
POSSIBLE TO PROVIDERS AND
CONSUMERS --
THAT THE RIGHTS OF THE IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES CONSUMERS UNDER
OLMSTEAD ARE ABSOLUTELY REGARDED
AS NON NEGOTIABLE AND THAT NO
PROGRAM IN INCREASE --
IMPLEMENTATION CAN BE ALLOWED TO
INFRINGE THEM PERIOD EVER.
THAT'S JUST BOTTOM LINE --
WE ALSO WANT TO KEEP WITH THE
AGREEMENT THAT GEO TRACKING AND
GPS SYSTEMS WOULD NOT BE USED.
AND THAT THE SYSTEM SHOULD BE
DEVELOPED IN A WAY THAT
CONTINUES --
TO USE MAXIMUM FLEX THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DEFINITIONS OF WHAT
CAN BE TERMED PERSONAL CARE
SERVICES LOCATION OF SERVICES
AND START AND TIME OF EACH
SERVICE.
AS YOU KNOW AS THE DEPARTMENT
HAS ALREADY DISCUSSED.
ADDITIONALLY OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES --
WAS INSTRUCTED NOT TO CREATE
ADDITIONAL VIOLATIONS POLICIES
AS PART OF EBV.
AND AND AGREED THAT --
INDIVIDUAL CONSUMER ASSESSMENTS
WOULD CONTINUE TO BE DONE
ANNUALLY BY SOCIAL WORKERS AND
THAT INFORMATION FROM ANY IN PVP
SYSTEMS WOULD NOT SUBSTITUTE FOR
HUMAN VISITS AND WOULD NEVER BE
USED TO REDUCE THE CONSUMERS
HOURS.
NOW AS I SAID CALIFORNIA'S
ACOSTA COURSE NOT THE ONLY STATE
DEALING WITH THESE ISSUES AND A
LOT OF THOSE PROTECTIONS ARE IN
THERE BECAUSE OF WHAT WE'VE SEEN
GOING ON IN OTHER STATES AND OUR
DESIRE TO AVOID THOSE PROBLEMS
HERE.
BUT STATES ACROSS THE NATION AS
THEY GRAPPLE WITH THIS ARE
CONTINUING TO LOOK TO US TO SET
A STANDARD AN EXAMPLE TO FOLLOW
AND AGAIN THE WE REMAIN
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO FIGHTING
EBV AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
IF CALIFORNIA IS FORCED
IMPLEMENTED ON SCHEDULE THESE
STRONG PROTECTIONS WILL NEED TO
BE IN PLACE TO PROVIDE A MUCH
NEEDED MEASURE OF PROTECTION FOR
THE PROGRAM. FOR THE CONSUMERS
REQUIRE ITS CARE AND FOR THE
PROVIDERS TO MAKE THAT CARE
POSSIBLE THEREFORE CODIFYING
THEM INTO LAW NOW IS A NECESSARY
STEP.
AND ONE THAT THE STATE SHOULD
ABSOLUTELY SHOULD TAKE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I THINK THATEM STAFF'S
RECOMMENDATION --
DOES CALL FOR THE PROTECTION AS
YOU NOTED TO THE CONSUMERS AND
THE PROVIDERS.
THE PRIVACY --
I'M GLAD THAT YOU'RE BRINGING
THIS UP I'M GLAD THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE PROBLEMS WITH
THE CHANGING FROM THE PAPER.
TO TO THE COMPUTER --
IT ISN'T TO FAIL PROOF METHOD
AND AS MS RUBIO IS INDICATED
THAT SOMETHING THAT WE WILL GO
THROUGH BUT I DO WANT.
TO THANK THE DEPARTMENT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION EFFORTS MADE.
ESPECIALLY IT INVITING AND
INCLUDING THE STAKEHOLDERS --
IT WAS IMPORTANT TO HAVE THEM AT
THE TABLE ON THIS PARTICULAR
SUBJECT.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT STARTED
LAST YEAR AND HAS BEEN ONGOING.
I WANT TO THANK YOU AND I I
THINK WE CAN ALL APPRECIATE THAT
THIS.
WHEN YOU BRING STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER TO ENHANCE IS THE
IMPLEMENTATION WORK FOR MAJOR
PROGRAM CHANGE THAT WAS THAT
CREATED AT FIRST A LOT OF?
UNDERSTANDABLE APPREHENSION AND
STILL SOME APPREHENSION RIGHT.
DID FOR FOR WHAT MY OWN OPINION
I WISH IT WAS NOT IMPLEMENTED
HERE CALIFORNIA.
YEAH.
IN ORDER THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE THOáT DOES FACILITATE OUR
COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL LAW.
AND I THINK THAT'S THAT'S THE
REASON FOR ALL OF THIS --
WELL NOT CAUSING A WE'RE TRYING
TO DO THE BEST WE CAN THE
DOESN'T CAUSE UNDUE HARDSHIP TO
THE OVER ONE MILLION PEOPLE
INVOLVED WITH AND IMPACTED WITH
THIS PROGRAM.
THE THE ISSUE RELATES ALSO TO
ISSUE NUMBER ONE THAT WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER IN SOME WAYS
ADDRESSING THE IMPORTANCE OF
CODIFYING STATE POLICY WHAT
MAKES SENSE TO DO.
AND IN THIS CASE TO IN TRYING
CALIFORNIA'S APPROACH EVD --
AT ONE QUESTION FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION IS WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS.
ON THIS CODIFICATION APPROACH.
OF A COUPLE COMMENTS IF I IF I
MAY FIRST TWO A GOOD ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION WE HAVE NO OBJECTION TO
THE CODIFICATION OF THE POLICY
PRINCIPLES THAT HAVE GUIDED OUR
WORK WE HELPED IN THE DRAFTING
OF THEM LAST YEAR IN THE BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE AND WE HAVE NO
OBJECTION. TO CODIFYING THAT --
WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK ON
LANGUAGE UNDERSTAND A REQUEST IS
BEEN MADE --
FOR FOR ONE OF THE GROUPS
INVOLVED.
TO WE'RE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
WORK AND DEVELOP THAT LANGUAGE
OF THOSE PRINCIPLES ARE
IMPORTANT THEIR STANDARD CONTENT.
MISSION --
IS ROSY HAVE.
ARTICULATED THEM WHILE AND AND
WE AGREE THERE IN OUR SLIDE DECK
AS WELL SO HAPPY TO DO THAT.
ON THE ISSUE THE PHONE WE KNOW
IT'S NOT WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE
OUR FOCUS HAS BEEN ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE ELECTRONIC
SERVICES PORTAL ONCE THAT HAS
WORKED ITS WAY OUT THAT IS THE
MODEL FOR THE FUNCTION THE ORDER
OF QUESTIONS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT.
THAT WILL LEAD NOT JUST TO THE
PHONE BUT TO THE MOBILE APP AS
WELL.
AND ADDITIONALLY RECOGNIZING THE
POPULATION WERE SERVING THERE
ARE STILL IN THE PROGRAM ABOUT --
FOUR HUNDRED RECIPIENTS AND THAT
DON'T HAVE OF EVEN A TELEPHONE
NUMBER ON FILE WITH US SO THERE
WILL NEED TO BE A SYSTEM.
OR SOME MECHANISM TO TO ENSURE
THAT THEY'RE STILL ABLE TO
APPROVE THE TIME SHEETS OF OF
THE PEOPLE THAT WORK FOR THEM.
SO WE'RE COGNIZANT OF THOSE
ISSUES WERE COMMITTED TO WORKING
THROUGH IT THAT WILL BE AN
ONGOING PARTNERSHIP.
AND THE PHONE IS JUST BEHIND THE
ELECTRONIC SERVICES PORTAL.
WE'VE HAD AN EXTENDED --
NOT TO GET TOO FAR AHEAD OF
MEETING WITH STAKEHOLDERS AT THE
END OF THE MONTH BUT WE HAVE AN
EXTENDED PILOT PERIOD WHERE WHEN
WE GO TO IMPLEMENT.
NOT ONLY TESTING BEFORE THAT
PILOT AND MAKING SURE THINGS
WORK BUT LEARNING FROM OUR PILOT
EXPERIENCE.
THE WAVES THAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER WILL BE ABOUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE AT A TIME.
WHICH IS A REALLY BIG NUMBER.
BUT THAT INITIAL PILOT WILL BE A
COUPLE MONTHS SO THAT WE COULD
WORK OUT THESE KINGS AND ENSURE
THAT SUBSEQUENT WAVES.
DON'T EXPERIENCE.
IN ANYTHING THIS BIG WE EXPECTED
NOT TO BE COMPLETELY CMOS AND WE
WANT THE CHANCE TO MAKE IT AS
SMOOTH AS POSSIBLE.
WONDERFUL WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I APPRECIATE THE
COLLABORATION WITH STAKEHOLDERS
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT. TO MAKE TWO
MORE VERY QUICK FOR MARCH IS A
BUDGET HEARING AND I THINK LIKE
DID THE INSTRUCTION.
THERE'S A B. C. P. LISTED HERE
AS WELL REQUESTING SOME STAFF
RESOURCES TO ACTUALLY DO THE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT WORK WORK
WITH OUR I. T. VENDOR. TO MAKE
THOSE MODIFICATIONS ON THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS WE OBVIOUSLY
SUPPORTER PROPOSAL BUT ALSO ONE
OF FLAG YOU THAT IT'S THERE.
AND THAT THE FUNDING FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION V. V. V. AS
NINETY TEN NINETY FEDERAL TEN
STATE --
IT'S A BUDGET HEARINGS AFTER THE
CATCH RIGHT ON THE RECORD THAT'S
THE CATCH YOU ONE OR 10%.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'D LIKE TO
CALL FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
ON ISSUE NUMBER.
THREE DIRECT THEM AND I WILL
[inaudible]
REITERATE.
WHAT HE WANTS TO GO ALSO WITH
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE IT'S
ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE GOOD ISSUES
BECAUSE WE'VE MADE GREAT
PROGRESS WITH ALL THIS THE
COLLABORATION WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS?
SO IF YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION.
AND IF.
BRIEFLY OF FOR THIS IS IF THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT TO YOU ARE OR
THE GREEN AT WITH.
OR NOT I'M SHEILA GUN CUSHMAN
FOR THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE.
I'M WITH THE ETV STOPPERS WERE
MOSTLY IN EAST BAY GROUP BUT
THANK YOU CONNIE AND MACHEL --
I PRETTY MUCH WANTED --
EVERYTHING THAT THEY SAID BUT I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE
THINGS.
I'M IN THE UNENVIABLE POSITION
OF BEING A PERSON WHO HATES
PAPER ANYTHING SAYING WE NEED
PAPER.
THIS WILL ONLY HAPPEN ONCE.
IT'S THE UNICORN.
TAKE A SELFIE WHILE YOU CAN --
BECAUSE I AM STILL STUCK ON A
HORRIBLE.
TELEPHONE TIME SHEETS SYSTEM
IT'S HORRIBLE.
I'M I AM ONE OF THREE BLIND
PEOPLE THAT.
THE BECAUSE THE STRUCTURE
NEGOTIATION.
WITH P. R..
AND DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
THAT WORKED WITH THE STATE THAT
MADE THAT THING POSSIBLE AND I'M
ASHAMED OF IT.
WHEN WE FIRST ROLLED IT OUT EVEN
BEFORE THE PILOT I TOLD THEM
THERE WERE PROBLEMS THOSE
PROBLEMS STILL EXIST?
THIS MORNING I LOOKED AT THE NEW
TIME SHE NOT KNOW IF I'M
SUPPOSED TO SAY ANYTHING OUT
LOUD EXCEPT WHEN I WILL SAY IS
[inaudible]
NOT ENOUGH.
NOT NEAR FAR ENOUGH.
AND YOU AREN'T READY.
AND YOU BETTER HURRY DAM UP
QUICKER YOU WON'T BE READY BY.
TWENTY ONE AND WHAT I WILL ADD
TO THAT.
THEY TELL ME THAT I WILL BE ABLE
TO GET TO THE E. T. S..
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER.
BUT AS THINGS NOW STAND.
MY AYE HSS PROVIDER.
IS WHAT'S HOLDING ME IN THE
PAPER WORLD AND IN THE TT S.
WORLD.
THEY WON'T LET ME GET TO THE ETS
AND TEST IT SUCCESS ABILITY OR
LACK THERE OF UNTIL MY PROVIDER
GOES THERE.
THIS IS NOT OKAY.
MY PROVIDER SHOULD BE ABLE TO BE
WHERE SHE NEEDS TO BE FOR HER
COMFORT AND ABILITY.
AND I SHOULD BE WERE I NEED TO
BE FOR MY COMFORT AND ABILITY
AND EFFICIENCY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR THAT
IMPORTANT INSIGHT QUITE FRANKLY.
IT'S IT IT IS.
IT'S A VOICE WE NEED TO HEAR.
TIRED OF IT.
DOING THIS FOR THIRTY YEARS BOTH
EIGHTY EIGHT PASSED IN.
NINETY BUT I'M GLAD YOU'RE HERE.
A MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CRISTINA BOSS HAMILTON
WITH YOU D. W. SUPPORTING THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR KERR CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA I
WON'T MAKE A HABIT OF THIS BUT
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THE COLLABORATIVE --
APPROACH THEY'VE HAD TO WORKING
ON THE V. V. INTO PRINT AND
IMPORTANTLY WORKING IN
NEGOTIATING THESE PRINCIPLES
THAT WE DID LAST YEAR AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY STAYING TRUE TO
THOSE PRINCIPLES WERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
LIVING CENTERS ON BEHALF OF
CAPITAL FOR H. US US IN SUPPORT
OF THE CODIFICATIONS OF THE V.
PROTECTION.
THANK YOU.
DIANNE WHERE WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AS
HAS BEEN NOTED THIS IS OF
SIGNIFICANT NEW REQUIREMENT --
FOR CONSUMERS AND PROVIDERS
COUNTY --
SOCIAL WORKERS WILL HAVE A ROLE
IN SUPPORTING CONSUMERS AND
PROVIDERS IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS --
WE WANT TO JUST KNOW THAT WE
APPRECIATE THE TEN POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS --
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET --
AS AS A IN SUPPORT OF COUNTY
WORK STILL HOWEVER WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION TO UNDERSTAND
HOW THE ROLE THAT WILL OCCUR AND
WHAT THE IMPACT WILL BE ON THE
WORKLOAD AND SO WE WILL COME
BACK TO YOU WHEN WE HAVE FURTHER
UNDERSTANDING AND ACKNOWLEDGING
OUR UNDERSTANDING.
OF WHAT WHAT WILL BE ENTAILED IN
THAT WORK THANK YOU THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON TO ALL AS MY
NAME IS DOLLY KHI BàN DAY I'M
HERE AGAIN.
I THINK IT ALL OF MY SISTER
FLOOR.
NOT ALL OF THE REAL THING PEOPLE.
THIS TWENTY FOUR SHE SIXTY NINE
THIS AB.
ELECTRONIC VISIT VERIFICATION.
IS TRULY GET WILL GIVE US AND
YOUR HARD TO HAVE DIFFICULTY EAT
THIS LIKE THIS SAYING.
I SHOP I'M NOT REALLY THERE.
I KNEW NOT TO WEAR WENDY DID
FAIL TO DUCK.
PROVIDERS TO THE HOME CARE
GIVERS.
THAT'S THE WAY THE EYE ROLL FELL
DOWN.
WE WOULD LIKE THE CALIFORNIA.
LEGISLATURE TO HELP US MAKE THE
EVE V. V..
YOU SEE HERE.
LIKE US SENIOR CITIZENS I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT COMPUTER WHAT'S MORE
MY SISTER.
AND THIS IS LIKE REALLY A
DISCRIMINATION BECAUSE LIKE OKAY
ALL LEAD THE MID THE GUN FIND
DEAD PEOPLE ON WILL HEAD THIS
EBV.
NOT THE END.
WORKERS OF AMERICA [inaudible]
UC [inaudible]
IT'S DISCRIMINATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU FLOOR.
HI AGAIN MY NAME IS STEVE AT
YOUR VALLEY I'M FROM LAKE COUNTY.
AT ALL I HAVE TO SAY ABOUT EVE
V. V. AS I AM TOTALLY
[inaudible]
AGAIN SET.
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE FIGHTING THE
FEDS AND TALENT TO GET RID OF
THIS PROGRAM AND THE MONEY THAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO PUT INTO IT
THAT IS GOING TO COST TO PUT IT
IN PLACE.
SHOULD BE USED TO GIVE ME A
RAISE AND BENEFITS BECAUSE ALL
THIS IS IS ANOTHER WAY OF OF
CHECKING ON ME.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
DON'T LET IT GET THAT LOCKED IN
THIS HAS ANYTHING TO DO WITH
GOING FROM PAPER CHECKS SELECT
PRODUCTS BECAUSE IT DOES IT.
THEY'RE PLANNING ON PUTTING A
TAB ON THE ELECTRONIC REPORT
I'LL FOR ME TO CHECK ON BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE HERE IS I'M GOING TO
BE HAVE TO TELL THEM IF I'M IN
THE COMMUNITY OR IF I'M AT HOME
TAKING CARE OF MY PERSON.
WHAT IS THAT?
THAT IS CHECKING ON ME AGAIN.
WE ALREADY HAVE A CHECK WE GET
WE FINALLY WON OVER TIME.
WHAT DID THEY DO THEY PUT A CAP
ON IT WE COULD MAKE SIXTY SIX
HOURS A WEEK THAT'S IT?
DOES OTHER PEOPLE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THEY GET OVERTIME
EVER CAP PUT ON IT PROBABLY NOT.
AND THIS EVENING THE THING IS
NOT IT'S HUMILIATING TO ME
BECAUSE THAT'S ANOTHER THING
WHERE THEY'RE SAYING WE DON'T
TRUST YOU.
AND WE WANT YOU TO CHECK IN
WHERE YOU'RE AT WELL.
WHO THE HELL ARE THEY?
WHY ARE THEY GOING AFTER ME WHY
IS IT I HAVE TO KEEP COMING TO
THE COMMITTEES TO FIGHT FOR MY
LIFE?
I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER PROFESSION
HERE.
FIGHTING ALL THE TIME TO GET
WHAT WERE YOU THE TITLE TO AND
WE'VE HAD TO WAIT YEARS TO EVEN
GET CLOSE.
TO AND I THINK IT'S WRONG AND
I'M NOT MAD AT YOU GUYS BECAUSE
I KNOW YOU'RE JUST DOING WHAT
THE FEDS ARE GOING TO MAKE YOU
DO.
BUT WHAT I'M GETTING AT AND MY
BIGGEST POINT IS WE NEED TO TELL
THOSE FEDS TO BACK OFF GET RID
OF THE PROGRAM USE THAT MONEY TO
HELP MAKE US BETTER NOW.
AND NOT KEEP COMING AFTER US
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I KNOW IT'S GETTING LATE.
BUT YOU CAN.
USE THE HANDS BUT I DO ASK THAT
THAT THAT WOULD NOT. TO THE WHO
WHO'S.
THANK YOU HELLO EVERYBODY --
ALSO PROVIDER HOME CARE PROVIDER
FOR A FAMILY MEMBER ALSO IDEA
VOLUNTEER A LOT FOR SCA YOU.
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND I BE NOT
TALKING TO A LOT OF PROVIDERS
FOR THE LAST SIX MONTHS AND
PROVIDERS ARE TERRIFIED
ESPECIALLY THE ONES WHO DON'T
SPEAK ENGLISH AND I HAVE TO
TRANSLATE FOR THEM.
SO I THINK --
YOU BUT YOU B. B. R. EIGHT A LOT
OF MONEY TO TRAIN THE PEOPLE AND
HIRE A LOT OF TRANSLATORS. TO
YOU KNOW EXPLAIN TO THEM HOW TO
USE THE EASY AND A LOT OF THEM
THEY FEEL LIKE IT'S A INVASION
OF PRIVACY AND EXTRA WORK FOR
THEM YOU KNOW THEY'RE ALREADY
STRESSED OUT.
WORKING ALL THEY WAS IS SOMEONE
IT WAS DISABILITY YOU KNOW IT'S
JUST ONE MORE WORK FOR THEM --
ALSO THESE --
YOU KNOW ELECTRONIC BOXES JUST
LIKE ON CELL PHONES THE GOING TO
BE OP.
GONNA NEEDED TO BE UPDATED --
YOU KNOW GO OUT OF STYLE OR YOU
KNOW IT'S OTHER CHRONIC IT
BREAKS DOWN --
IN THE IF THE PROVIDER HASN'T
CHECKED IN --
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IS THERE
GOING TO BE VIOLATIONS IMPOSE ON
THAT PROVIDERS BECAUSE YOU KNOW
OF A SYSTEM BREAKDOWN THOUGH
MAYBE A NO.
A THEY HAD A DIFFICULT THEY AND
THEY FORGOT TO CLOCK IN AND
CLOCK OUT SO.
THOSE ARE IN NO A LOT OF
PROVIDERS SO THAT I'VE SPOKE TO
THEIR AGAINST.
E. V. V. N. --
I SUPPORT THEM WE DID NOT ONE
EBV IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI.
IT SOLUTION LITTLE AGAIN I WORK --
FOR SEIU AND I HSS EXCUSE ME.
WITH THE UNION SEIU LOCAL TWENTY
FIFTH WE KNOW THAT.
THIS NO MATTER WHAT THIS IS
ALREADY.
A FEDERAL LAW THAT WE HAVE TO
FOLLOW.
WE DON'T HAVE A CHOICE.
IT'S ALREADY GOING TO GO INTO
EFFECT -- WE
JUST NEED TO CODIFY AND MAKE
SURE THAT ALL THE PROTECTIONS
ARE IN PLACE FOR US SO WE DON'T
GET THE VIOLATIONS SO AM.
WE ALSO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYBODY IS EDUCATED
CORRECTLY ON SO WE DON'T GET
VIOLATIONS AND SO WE KNOW HOW
EVERYTHING IS DONE AND IT'S DONE
RIGHT FROM THE BEGINNING SO.
BEFORE IT IS IMPLEMENTED WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY IS AT
EDUCATED CORRECTLY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME SHERRY
BILLIONS ON FROM S. YEAH YOU
TWENTY FIFTEEN ON THE IN HOME
SUPPORT FIGHTER ON THE LIVING
CARE PROVIDER.
SO HOUSE EDP CONNECTED INTO THAT
CRITERIA.
I WORK AND WHEN MY MOM GETS SICK
AT THREE O'CLOCK MONUMENT MAKE A
CALL ON INTEREST SYSTEM I GOT UP
AT THREE O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING
TO TAKE CARE OF HER. TO TURN ON
OX MACHINE BECAUSE P. JEANNIE
WENT OUT.
I MEAN SOMETHING HAS TO CHANGE
SOMEWHERE THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MERELY MARTINEZ
AND I'M A PROVIDER AND ALSO A
MEMBER OF A SAY --
TWENTY FIFTEEN A HERE.
A TO ASK YOU PLEASE S. TEN AND
SUPPORT OUR CONSUMERS AND ALSO
ALL OF US ARE SO WORKERS.
PLEASE OPPOSED TO THIS THAT THIS
SHOULD NOT BE HAPPENING.
WHAT AT THE THINKING ABOUT
IMPLEMENTING AND EVEY V.?
I WE IT RICH ARE WE MAKING
ENOUGH MONEY TO GET THAT SO ON A
SMARTPHONE OR COMPUTER TO BE
DOING THIS.
SOMETIMES WE NOT EVEN CAN AFFORD
TO PAY OUR MONTHLY BUILT ON OUR
PHONES. TO KEEP UP SO.
WHAT ARE THEY THINKING ALL THIS
AND THIS TEN WE DOES IN SUPPORT
ALL OUR CONSUMERS AND ALSO I
SAYS TO WORKERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH?
THANK YOU.
SUSAN DALY GLENN COUNTY I JUST
AS PROVIDER.
I APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU
ALL HAVE DONE --
TO ON THE LANGUAGE FOR THE
PROTECTIONS FOR THE CONSUMERS
AND THE CLIENTS WE REALIZE THAT
THIS IS.
A FEDERALLY MANDATED THING AND
UNTIL WE CAN FIND IT AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WE ASK THAT YOU
PUT IT INTO LAW FOR THOSE
PROTECTIONS.
THANK YOU WE ARE --
MY NAME IS RACHEL CAMPBELL I'M A
PROVIDER INTO HIM COUNTY --
AS THIS IS A FEDERAL REQUIREMENT --
I WOULD ASK YOU GUYS.
MAKE IT AS AS THE LEAST INVASIVE
AS POSSIBLE TO OUR CONSUMERS --
THEY ALREADY HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE
POKING IN THEIR LIVES IN
DETERMINING YOU KNOW THE CARE
THAT THEY NEED AND HOW MANY
HOURS THEY GET.
SO.
FOR THIS TO BE ONE MORE THING
ADDED TO THEM AND TO OUR WORK
LOAD THAT TAKES AWAY FROM THEIR
QUALITY A CARE.
GIVER.
THANK YOU.
HEY LETICIA SANCHEZ --
I WORK FOR US YEAH YOU LOCAL
TWENTY FIFTEEN BUT I'M ALSO I'M --
CARE GIVER AT NIGHT FOR MY DAD.
AND I JUST ALSO MASKING FOR
THEIR SAME PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
THAT ARE LISTED IN THE ARM.
IN THE THE BILL THAT THEIR
PROPOSED THE LESS BLOOD THE
LEAST INVASIVE AS POSSIBLE.
THEY ALREADY HAVE ENOUGH WORK TO
DO DURING THE DAY THEY DON'T
NEED ANYTHING EXTRA ADDED TO OF
THEIR DAILY TASKS.
AND PLEASE LOOK AT THE
PROTECTIONS BECAUSE THAT'S THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING RIGHT NOW
WE KNOW IT HAS TO BE IMPLEMENTED --
BUT WE JUST ASK THAT WILL IT WAS --
COLLABORATION OF OF ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS MEDIAN SO PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES THE UNION MEMBERS
PEOPLE THAT ARE PROVIDING THE
SERVICES PEOPLE THAT ARE
RECEIVING THE SERVICES.
THAT HAD --
ALL THE THAT PUT THE INPUT IN ON
ALL THE OF OF THE BUT YOU GUYS
ARE TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION SO
I JUST ASK THAT YOU WOULD
RESPECT THAT.
AND LISTEN TO YOUR PEOPLE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS A MERRILEES
GROSS I AM WITH A C. I. TWENTY
FIFTEEN UNION AND I AM A FORMER --
I. H. S. S. PROVIDER.
I BECAME A MEMBER OF THE UNION
BECAUSE I WAS PROVIDING CARE FOR
MY MOTHER.
MY BROTHER AND MY STEPFATHER.
MY MOTHER LIVED TO BE A HUNDRED
AND ONE YEARS OLD.
JESUS DIED THIS PAST MARCH.
AND SO I DECIDED TO GO WORK WITH
THE UNION BY WORKING WITH THE
UNION BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THE
HERE.
AND THEY WANT TO HELP PROVIDERS
AND PEOPLE WERE ON THAT ARE --
ON I. H. S. YES.
NOW WITH THIS PROGRAM THE CVV
PROGRAM BECAUSE WE DO WANT TO
IMPLEMENT.
THIS IS GOING TO BE VERY BASIC I
CAN CURL ALL THAT'S BEEN SAID
ALREADY.
AND WE DO KNOW THAT IT'S GOING
TO TAKE PLACE BECAUSE IT COSTS
IN CALIFORNIA LOT OF MONEY IF IT
DOESN'T TAKE PLACE.
HOWEVER THERE ARE STIPULATIONS
THAT NEED TO BE PUT ON THIS YEAR
WE ALSO KNOW THAT ANYTIME YOU
DEAL WITH ANY TYPE OF LIKE
TRONIC.
US TO A SYSTEM WHATSOEVER.
YOU SAY IT'S GOING TO IN THE
STATE.
THANKS.
A LOT OF SOCIAL MEDIA ONE MINUTE
TO WIN HIM AND WE THINK OF WHAT
HAPPENED THOUGH SO PLEASE BE
CAREFUL.
AS TO WHAT YOU SAY AND MAKE SURE
THAT THIS DEVICE IS GOING TO DO
WHAT YOU SAY IS GOING TO DO AND
NOT DO SOMETHING THAT'S GONNA
CAUSE MORE PROBLEMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I WANTED TO NOTE SOMETHING ABOUT
THE PANELISTS I WANT TO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU TURN TO YOUR SEATS. TO
FACE ALL OF THE POPE THOSE WHO
PROVIDED PUBLIC COMMENT TO GIVE
THEM THE THE THE ATTENTION AND
THE DIGNITY THAT THEY ABSOLUTELY
DESERVE.
BECAUSE THEIR COMMENTS ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND JUST AS
YOU HAVE BROUGHT ALL THE STAKE
HOLDERS TOGETHER AND PUT
TOGETHER THAT COLLABORATION. TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
THOSE WHO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
I DON'T SEE THAT IN ALL OF MY
COMMITTEES.
I WANT TO THANK YOU BECAUSE IT
WAS ALMOST AUTOMATIC THAT YOU
ALL DID THAT THANK YOU FOR FOR
THANK YOU FOR BEING THERE FOR
FOR BEING THOSE HUMANS.
THAT.
I LOVE WORKING WITH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
I'D ASK IF THERE ARE ANY
COMMENTS FOR OUR QUESTIONS FROM
MIKE MY COLLEAGUES THERE'S NO
ONE HERE TO ASK A QUESTION.
SO THAT ITEM IS ALSO SCHEDULED
TO BE HELD OPEN.
THANK YOU TO ALL THE PANELISTS.
ISSUE NUMBER.
FOUR THE GOVERNOR'S PEAK
BASICALLY ON STATE
ADMINISTRATIVE OR VIEW AND DATA
ANALYSIS.
AGAIN WILL TAKE IT IN THE ORDER
LISTED.
ALL RIGHT.
PETER BACK AGAIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT --
I'M GONNA BE INCREDIBLY BRIEF
WE'VE HAD TO LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS IN OUR DEPARTMENT
DOING A VARIETY OF WORK THEY
STARTED OUT WITH THE UNIFORMS
SUSSMAN TO ALL THAT WAS A
FEATURE.
OF COORDINATED CARE INITIATIVE --
THEY'VE BEEN RENEWED FOR OTHER
PURPOSES PREVIOUSLY AND NOW WE
ARE ASKING THAT SOME ONGOING
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH DATA
REQUESTS AND STATE
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW OF
OVERTIME VIOLATIONS BE MADE
PERMANENT.
THESE ARE EXISTING POSITIONS
WITH EXISTING PEOPLE IN THEM
THEY'VE BEEN LIMITED TERM THEY
EXPIRE JUNE THIRTY MORE SIMPLY
HERE WITH A B. C. P. ASKING THAT
THEY BE MADE.
HERMAN ON AN ONGOING BASIS THANK
YOU.
SENATE HAMMER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I JUST NOTE THE REQUEST
IS FOR TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NO CONCERNS AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO OPEN IT UP
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
SAYING NO PUBLIC COMMENT NO
COMMENTS FROM THE DíAS.
ALL RIGHT AND THAT ITEM WILL BE
HELD OPEN AS WELL [inaudible]
ITEM [inaudible] FIVE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE PUBLIC AUTHORITY
ADMINISTRATION FUNDING AND
ADVOCACY PROPOSAL.
LIBERTY CENTER IS THE WILL BE
SPEAKING.
NOW YOU'RE ON THIS SITE.
IT'S VERY EXCITING BEING ON THE
SIDE.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR --
STAFF --
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF THIS IS
LIBERTY SANCHEZ REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES FOR IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HEARING
THIS --
ISSUE AREA REGARDING OUR PUBLIC
AUTHORITY ADMIN FUNDING
SHORTFALL --
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO SAY I'M
MUCH APPRECIATION TO STAFF FOR
THE LOVELY ANALYSES AS ALWAYS --
WHICH REALLY KIND OF HIT ON ALL
OF THE POINTS I WAS GOING TO
RAISE ALL JUST GIVE YOU A COUPLE
OF HIGHLIGHTS --
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO EXPRESS
APPRECIATION TO THE DEPARTMENT
FOR ONGOING CONVERSATIONS WE'VE
BEEN HAVING WERE GUARDING THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND WHAT WE BELIEVE TO
BE ABOUT A FIVE MINUTE MILLION
DOLLAR SHORTFALL --
FOR PUBLIC AUTHORITY ADMIN
FUNDING --
WE BELIEVE THAT AS WAS POINT OF
CALCULATIONS THAT WERE RELIED
UPON THAT ARE NOT ACCURATE
CALCULATIONS FOR THIS PURPOSE
THE FIRST.
ONE HAD TO DO WITH THE NUMBER OF
BACKGROUND CHECKS THAT WERE
ASSUMED AN AG ANY GIVEN YEAR THE
ASSUMPTION WAS ABOUT FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN D. O. J.
NUMBERS.
THERE WERE ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND UNDERTAKEN
WERE CONTINUING TO DO INTERNAL --
DETERMINATIONS TO FIND OUT --
COUNTY BY COUNTY BY COUNTY --
HOW MANY BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR
UNDERTAKEN BUT WE DO THINK
THAT'S ABOUT RIGHT AND THERE IS
ABOUT A 30% TURNOVER RATE --
IN AYE HSS PROVIDERS AND ANY
GIVEN YEAR.
SO WITH THE FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
ASSUMPTION THAT REALLY WAS
BASICALLY LIKE ONE HALF T. E.
PER LIKE NINETY FIVE HUNDRED
CASES WHICH IS.
INSUFFICIENT STATEWIDE SECONDLY
THE OTHER ASSUMPTION THAT WAS
POINTED OUT IN THE ANALYSIS MY
AND ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT --
HAD TO DO WITH REFERRALS AND
BASING IT ON ABOUT 8% OF
CONSUMERS WHICH REALLY RESULTED
IN HAVE TV'S.
OF ABOUT THIRTY TWO POINT SIX
THREE STATE WIDE AND GIVEN THAT
WE HAVE. FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
AND FIFTY SIX PUBLIC AUTHORITIES
AMONG THOSE COUNTIES THAT'S NOT
EVEN. ONE ONE PERSON TO DO THE
WORK THAT IS AN ENORMOUS
UNDERTAKING AND WORKLOAD SO WE
THE THE ANALYSIS I WE THINK
WE'RE SHORT WE THINK IT'S ABOUT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS WERE DOING
A LITTLE BIT MORE FINE TUNING.
BUT WE THINK IT'S AROUND THERE
WE ARE CONTINUING TO HAVE A
DIALOGUE WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND
APPRECIATE THEIR WILLINGNESS TO
HAVE THESE ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
AND ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
YOUR HEARING OUR FLEET.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LIKE TO OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT.
I'M SORRY WE STILL NEED SOMEBODY
ELSE.
OF THE REACTION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE AN
ADMINISTRATOR AT WERE CONTINUING
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THE NUMBERS CORRECT.
WONDERFUL BECAUSE THAT IT IT TO
TELL YOU THE TRUTH.
I HAVE PUT A LITTLE NOTE HERE
JUST CAP EXPRESSES GRATITUDE FOR
THE WORK DONE BY DSS ON A NEW
BUDGET METHODOLOGY FOR PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES.
IT BELIEVES A PUBLIC AUTHORITY
ADMINISTRATION REMAINS UNDER
FUNDED AND MY LITTLE NOTES SAID
BY HOW MUCH.
SO YOU HAVE GIVEN US A NUMBER
AND I I APPRECIATE THAT I KNOW
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT --
WILL BE YOU'LL CONTINUE TO HAVE
THE DISCUSSIONS ON THEM.
THE ITEM IS SCHEDULED. TO BE
HELD OPEN BUT WE HAVE --
TWO PEOPLE AND WE DO HAVE TO
PEOPLE UNDER PUBLIC COMMENT.
ARE YOU READY.
WHERE IS MICHELLE ROSY OF FROM
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I'VE?
BEEN WORKING WITH MY LOCAL
PUBLIC AUTHORITY FOR MANY MANY
YEARS I WOULD SAY PROBABLY.
MORE LIKE FIFTEEN YEARS NOW ON
AND OFF --
BUT ANYWAY --
I URGE YOU TO TO REALLY DO LOOK
AT THE FUNDING AND THAT THE
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES USE AND AND
TO INCREASE IT TO WHAT THEY NEED
BECAUSE IT'S A IT'S IMPORTANT
ROLE THAT THEY DO.
FOR AND ALL OF US CONSUMERS
BEHIND THE SCENES MAY NOT
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE ROLE OF
THE WHAT THE PUBLIC AUTHORITIES
ACTUALLY DO --
BUT I AS A CONSUMER WHO IS HAS
IT INTRICATE ROLE OF WORKING
WITH THE CLOSELY WITH THE FATHER
THIRTY I UNDERSTAND THEIR ROLE I
UNDERSTAND THE THE WORK THAT
THEY DO AND I UNDERSTAND.
THE TECHNICAL THINGS THAT THEY
DO AND THEY WORK WITH OUR
PROVIDERS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
GET BENEFITS LOCALLY.
AND THEY DO A LOT OF THINGS THAT
WE AS CONSUMERS AND PROVIDERS
DON'T NECESSARILY UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY DO.
AND SO I REALLY WOULD HOPE THAT
YOU WOULD BRING UP THEIR FUNDING
TO WHAT THEY NEED.
OF IT IT'S AN INTRICATE ROLE
THAT THEY DO FRAZIER SAYS IT'S
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT THEY
COUNTIES DO --
THE PUBLIC --
STORIES ARE VERY.
THEY THEIR WORK IS JUST AS
IMPORTANT AS WHAT THEY'RE THE
COUNTY CITATION SAYS PROGRAM
THEY WORK CLOSELY TOGETHER AND I
URGE YOU TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
FINDING THIS WHOLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
JUSTIN GET CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES JUST
ALSO ONE EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
APPRECIATION FOR THE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN CAP AND
CDSS ON THE AMOUNT OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITY FUNDING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THAT CONCLUDES PUBLIC COMMENT TO
NO COMMENTS FROM [inaudible]
MY COLLEAGUES.
SO LET'S GO TO WE'VE ALREADY
COMPLETED.
ISSUES SIX AND SEVEN SO LET'S GO
TO SUCH SUCH ISSUE NUMBER.
EIGHT GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
REGARDING THE HOUSING.
DISABILITY ADVOCACY PROGRAM.
HELLO I SAID AS HE IS AS HOUSING
WITH THIS AND CIVIL RIGHTS
BRANCH CHIEF --
I AM JUST GOING TO GIVE A QUICK.
OVERVIEW OF HOW THE PROGRAM HAS
BEEN IMPLEMENTED THIS FAR AND
THEN IF THERE ARE QUESTIONS JUST
LET ME KNOW --
BUT AS A QUICK REMINDER THIS
PROGRAM WAS FUNDED AT FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS WITH THAT ONE TO
ONE DOLLAR MATCH FROM COUNTIES --
IT'S A THREE YEAR PROBE COUNTIES
THAT COMPETED FOR FUNDS AND WERE
APPROVED THOSE FUNDS RE
ALLOCATED ALL I'M ALL FUNDS ARE
ALLOCATED FROM NOVEMBER TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THROUGH APRIL OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BOTH ON A NEED
AND A COMPETITIVE BASIS --
WE'VE BEEN DOING QUITE A FEW IN
PERSON LEARNING FORUMS GONNA AND
ON SITE VISITS HAD QUITE A FEW
WEBINARS TO GET FOLKS UP AND
RUNNING --
THIS PROGRAM IS TAKEN AS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME TO
GET FULLY IMPLEMENTED IT IS A
REALLY COMPLEX PROGRAM FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS.
BUT WE REALLY ARE SEEING SOME
IMPROVE IMPROVEMENTS IN SOME
PRETTY QUICK --
AI INCREASING NUMBERS EVEN FROM
THAT THE FACT SHEET THAT WE
HANDED OUT IN JANUARY THERE'S
BEEN A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE PARTICULARLY AND
DISABILITY APPLICATIONS --
SUBMITTED SO --
WE ARE IN IN THE MIDST OF
WORKING WITH COUNTIES ON ON
GETTING UP AND FULLY RUNNING AND
WE ARE SORT OF IN THE MIDST OF
TALKING THROUGH THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR --
PROPOSAL FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AS WELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OUR OFFICE PROVIDED INITIAL
COMMENTS IN FEBRUARY REGARDING
THIS PROPOSAL WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH THAT BUT THE
PROGRAM AGED AT BEING ONGOING WE
DID REYES JUST SOME TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS AROUND --
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS --
AROUND HOW MUCH OF THE INITIAL
FORTY FIVE MILLION WAS EXPENDED
ALSO IN STATUTE THERE ARE
CERTAIN DATA ELEMENTS --
THEIR OF DEPARTMENT WAS REQUIRED
TO REPORT BACK ON IN OCTOBER --
IN OUR CONVERSATIONS IT SEEMS
LIKE SOME OF THE SOME OF THOSE
DATA ELEMENTS ARE MORE
CHALLENGING THAN OTHERS SO IT
JUST IN CONTEXT OF THIS PROGRAM
BEING ONGOING ARE WE THEN
MONITORING PERFORMANCE --
ON AN ONGOING BASIS AND TEND TO
REFLECT THAT JUST GETTING MORE
INFORMATION IT SOUNDS LIKE SOME
PROGRESS IS MADE IN ANSWERING
SOME OF THESE QUESTIONS BUT
RECEIVING A FORMALIZED RESPONSE
JUST TO GET A BETTER SENSE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL --
BY SPRING.
WE WOULD.
THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA.
I WOULD THE L. REQUEST FOR A
MORE FORMALIZED FOR A FORMALIZED
RESPONSE --
TO THE QUESTIONS TO THE COMMENTS
AND I WOULD ASK THAT IT BE
PROVIDED TO THE AND COMMITTEE
STAFF [inaudible]
AND AND THE LA --
BY APRIL TWENTY SECOND WE'VE GOT.
WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO GET THE
INFORMATION BEFORE THE MAY
REVISE THIS DISAGREEABLE.
OKAY WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
NO NO ALL RIGHT PUBLIC COMMENT.
ADDRESSING A CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SEEN NO PUBLIC COMMENT
NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT THIS
ITEM IS SCHEDULED TO BE HELD
OPEN.
ISSUE NUMBER.
NINE ADVOCACY PROPOSAL REGARDING
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES AND
PUBLIC ADMINISTRATOR GUARDIAN
CONSERVATOR TRAINING PROGRAM
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
ELLISON YET [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
JUST A MOMENT LET ME SIT DOWN.
THE FIND MY SEAT HERE.
OKAY HOW WOULD SOMEONE.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON AND EARLY
EVENING.
TO CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
MY NAME IS ALLISON HAMPTON I AM
A PROGRAM MANAGER --
OVERSEEING THE ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM FOR MONTEREY
COUNTY.
I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
TO CONTINUE AND GROW THE
TRAINING PROGRAM FOR A PS SOCIAL
WORKERS.
AND PUBLIC ADMINISTRATORS
GUARDIANS AND CONSERVATORS.
OUR BROAD COALITION IS
REQUESTING FIVE POINT SEVEN FIVE
MILLION STATE FUNDS OVER THREE
YEARS.
THIS WORKS OUT TO BE JUST UNDER
TWO MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR.
BUT IT LEVERAGES ANOTHER FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDS. FOR TOTAL
INVESTMENT OF TEN FIVE MILLION.
UNTIL THREE YEARS AGO THE APEC
APS TRAINING PROGRAM WAS
SUPPORTED BY A MERE EIGHTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN STATE FUNDS.
THIS WAS NOT ENOUGH TO MEET JUST
MY OWN STAFF TRAINING NEEDS LET
ALONE THE TRAINING NEEDS OF ALL
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES WORKERS
ACROSS THE STATE.
THERE WAS NO TRAINING TO ONBOARD
NEW SOCIAL WORKERS OR NEW
SUPERVISORS AND NO ADVANCE
TRAINING TO ADDRESS THE VERY
COMPLEX AND DIVERSE TYPES OF
ABUSE AND NEGLECT THAT WE
RESPOND TO ON A DAILY BASIS.
WITH THE ONE TIME THREE MILLION
DOLLAR A PS TRAINING INVESTMENT
WHICH GREW TO SIX MILLION
DOLLARS WITH FEDERAL MATCH OVER
THESE PAST THREE YEARS.
WE WERE ABLE TO TRAIN OUR SOCIAL
WORK STAFF TO BETTER PROTECT
OLDER ADULTS.
AND VICTIMS OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT.
FOR EXAMPLE MY STAFF NOW HAVE
INCREASED THEIR KNOWLEDGE AND
SKILLS TO CONDUCT INITIAL
INVESTIGATIONS ASSESS CLIENTS
FOR DECISION MAKING ABILITY.
COMPLETE FINANCIAL ABUSE
INVESTIGATIONS ANSWER VICTIMS
WHO HAVE MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE NEEDS.
WE BELIEVE THE TRAINING PROGRAM
IS CRITICAL AND PREPARING OUR
APS WORK FORCE TO PROTECT AND
SERVE OLDER ADULTS.
AS THE DEMAND FOR OUR SERVICES
CONTINUES TO RISE AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT.
AND I'LL DO THIS. FOR THOSE WHO
ARE IN THE BACK OF THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SCARLETT HUGHES.
YES MA'AM GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
SORRY HE'S I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATORS PUBLIC GUARDIANS
AND PUBLIC CONSERVATORS.
AND OUR ASSOCIATES SO THAT ON
YOUR BUSINESS CARD.
THE ACRONYMS EVEN WORSE --
AND OUR ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS
ALL THE PUBLIC ADMINISTRATOR
GUARDING THING CONSERVATIVES AND
THEIR STAFF AND ALL THE COUNTIES.
WHERE THE CERTIFYING BODY
LEGALLY --
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR
ACCREDITATION.
OUR MEMBERS ARE APPOINTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA SUPERIOR COURTS TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE MOST
IMPAIRED ADULT CALIFORNIANS AND
THEY'RE A STATES.
I TOO AM REQUESTING YOUR SUPPORT
TO CONTINUE THESE FUNDS PRIOR TO
THREE YEARS AGO.
OUR MEMBERS NEVER RECEIVED ANY
TRAINING FUNDS OF ANY KIND.
EVEN THOUGH CERTIFICATION IS
LEGALLY MANDATED.
TRAINING WAS LIMITED TO ONE
THREE AND A HALF DAY CONFERENCE
HERE AND MANY MEMBERS COULD NOT
AFFORD TO ATTEND REGULARLY.
THE TRAINING FUNDS ALLOWED US TO
DELIVER THIRTY ADDITIONAL
TRAININGS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND PROVIDED OUR MEMBERS WITH A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ADDITIONAL
CERTIFICATION HOURS.
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVING THEIR
KNOWLEDGE AND ABILITY TO MANAGE
THE RISE IN EXTREMELY COMPLEX
CASES.
OUR MEMBERS ARE APPOINTED BY THE
COURT PERSONAL DECISION MAKING
FOR OUR CLIENTS WHO'S RIGHT TO
SELF DETERMINATION IS REMOVED BY
THE COURT WHEN WERE APPOINTED.
AS A RESULT OUR MEMBERS MUST BE
TRAINED IN A WIDE RANGE OF
TOPICS COVERING ALL ASPECTS OF
LIFE INCLUDING DECISIONS.
CONCERNING PSYCHIATRIC AND
MEDICAL CARE PLACEMENT
MEDICATION END OF LIFE TREATMENT
ANYTHING THAT YOUR DISABLED
GRANDMOTHER YOUR DISABLED
BROTHER YOUR DISABLED CHILD
MIGHT NEED WE GET APPOINTED AND
WE TAKE CARE OF OUR MEMBERS ARE
ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR MANAGING
THE CLIENT'S PERSONAL INCOME.
AND ALL THEIR STATE ASSETS
INCLUDING SELLING HOMES SELLING
CARS SELLING PERSONAL PROPERTY
MANAGING ALL THEIR STOCKS THEIR
BONDS MAKING ALL THE STATE
DECISIONS.
THE TRAINING PROVIDED BY THESE
FUNDS INCREASE OUR MEMBERS
KNOWLEDGE OF CURRENT LAWS AND
REGULATIONS AND PROVIDED THEM
WITH THE BEST PRACTICE
GUIDELINES.
WITH CONTINUE TRAINING FUNDS WE
WILL BE ABLE TO ENSURE A STRONG
TRAINING CURRICULUM THAT WILL
SUPPORT OUR PUBLIC ADMINISTRATOR
GUARDIANS AND CONSERVATORS.
IN DELIVERING THE BEST SERVICES
POSSIBLE TO THE MOST VULNERABLE
OF OUR STATES IMPAIRED ADULTS
CITIZENS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DIRECTOR LARRY POSTERS SURE
BANKER.
IS THERE ANY RESPONSE --
WHAT'S THE ADMINISTRATION'S VIEW
ON THE TRAINING NEEDS.
IN A YES --
SO I THINK THE COMMENT THAT WE
MAKE HERE IS THAT IT'S NOT
INCLUDED IN IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WHAT I WILL TELL YOU IS
THAT IN THE POWER POINT THAT WE
PASSED OUT TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES WE GO
OVER BUDGET CASELOAD TRENDS AT
SUCH A ON PAGE. ELEVEN OF THAT --
REFLECTS THE OUTCOMES OF THE
THREE MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
THAT WAS MATCHED WITH FEDERAL
FUNDS TO BECOME SEX --
AND THAT'S DISCUSS THEIR PRETEND
I HAVE MORE EXPERTISE THAN THEY
DO ABOUT THE VALUE IN THE NEED
FOR THIS.
THANKS THANK YOU.
SENATE HAMMER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO THE EXTENT THIS IS
IDENTIFIED AS A LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITY WERE HAPPY TO REVIEW
THE PROPOSAL AND PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
ALSO HAPPY TO READ ANY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IF NEEDED.
THANK YOU NOW LET'S OPEN IT UP
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER I'M SORRY NO MEMBERS ARE
HERE MADAM CHAIR AND STUFF ON
THE CANNELLA REPRESENTING THE
KIND OF ALAMEDA MORE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
CAROL SO REPRESENTING CO SPONSOR
ORGANIZATIONS THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING AND THE
CALIFORNIA OLDER JUSTICE
COALITION.
WE WE'RE THRILLED WITH THE
RESULTS OF THE THREE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WENT INTO TRAINING
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS.
THERE WERE NEW TO NEW --
NEW COMPONENTS CREATED THEIR
WORDS ONLINE TRAINING FOR
MANDATED REPORTERS --
IT'S AN INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WILL
BE LOST IF THIS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING ISN'T MADE AVAILABLE FOR
THE NEXT THREE YEARS SO WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING LISA COLEMAN
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION WE STAND
IN SUPPORT OF THIS AND ASKS.
WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT WE
IMPOSSIBLE WHEN THEY WERE SPACE
AVAILABLE LOCAL OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAMS ALSO GOT TO BENEFIT
FROM THESE TRAININGS AND THE
CURRICULUMS AND THE ONLINE.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF THE STATE
USING A DOLLAR AND IT TURNS INTO
THREE OR FOUR DOLLARS DOWN THE
ROAD BECAUSE OF THE OTHER
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS THAT
BENEFIT FROM THIS KNOWLEDGE.
SO WE ENCOURAGE THE STATE NOT TO
LOSE THE GROUND THAT WE'VE MADE
AND TO CONTINUE INVEST IN THE
TRAINING.
THANK YOU.
GARY PASSED MORE CONGRESS OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS WE STRONGLY
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS PROPOSALTHANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING THE HARTWELL AARP
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I AM AWARE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF
OF ALL FIFTY A COUNTY SUPERVISOR
THAT TWENTY FOUR SEVEN OUR
RESPONSE TO THIS REPORTS OF
ABUSE AND NEGLECT FOR A VERY --
EXPONENTIALLY GROWING RATE OF
OUR SENIOR POPULATION WE ARE AT
YOUR SUPPORT.
THAT'S PRETTY POWERFUL ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR DEVIN
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CEMETERY COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
LIVVIE SANTOS ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING A PS
SOCIAL WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT
ALSO ON BEHALF OF KAPPA FOR IHS
DUSTIN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JUSTIN GET CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES WITH OUR
GROWING SENIOR POPULATION THIS
FUNDING IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER TIME WE SO WE SUPPORT OF
THE CONTINUATION EXPANSION OF IT
TO INCLUDE PUBLIC GUARDIANS AS
WELL I'M ALSO LOS ANGELES COUNTY
ASSET I SHOW THEIR SUPPORT AS
WELL.
THANKS THANK YOU --
CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WHERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HELLO SUSAN TO MORRIS ON BEHALF
OF THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO AGAIN CRISTINA BOSS
HAMILTON YOU W. IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
I THINK WE GOT THROUGH ABOUT --
TWENTY PUBLIC COMMENTS IN TWO
MINUTES.
THAT'S RIGHT I'M I'M WITH YOU
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
AND THAT THIS ITEM IS.
ALSO AN ITEM FOR TO TO BE HELD
OPEN.
AND NOW --
FOR OUR LAST DISCUSSION ITEM
ISSUE NUMBER.
TEN ADVOCACY ADVOCACY PROPOSAL
FOR AN ACTUARIAL STUDY FOR LONG
TERM SUPPORTS.
AND SERVICES FINANCING AND
SERVICE OPTIONS.
ALL RIGHT LET'S BEGIN WITH NAY
NO WIDER HARWELL.
THAT IS CORRECT AND GOOD EVENING.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US HERE
TONIGHT I NEED A WHY THE
PARLIAMENT ASSOCIATES STATE
DIRECTOR FOR EUROPEAN CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE A MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION
THAT REPRESENTS CALIFORNIA'S
FIFTEEN OVER WE HAVE NEARLY
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA.
TODAY I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
OUR PARTNERS.
AT THE CALIFORNIA AGING AND
DISABILITY ALLIANCE ARCADIA WE
ARE TWENTY MEMBER COALITION.
COMPRISED OF ORGANIZATIONS THAT
REPRESENT OLDER CALIFORNIANS
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES.
PROVIDER ORGANIZATIONS IN LABOR.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING TOGETHER
FOR NEAR NOW TO DEVELOP
THOUGHTFUL SOLUTION FOR
CALIFORNIANS LOSE CALIFORNIA'S
LOOMING LONG TERM CARE CRISIS.
MANY AGING OR DISABLE
CALIFORNIANS STRUGGLE TO AFFORD
THE SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THE
NEED TO LIVE WITH DIGNITY AND
INDEPENDENCE.
OFTEN THEY OR THEIR FAMILY
STRUGGLE TO PAY OUT OF POCKET
FOR LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS OR LPS AUS.
A. R. P. RESEARCH FROM THAT JUST
CAME OUT LAST FALL.
SHOW THAT THE AVERAGE COST FOR
NURSING HOME CARE AND EVEN HOME
CARE IS BEYOND THE MEANS OF THE
MEDIAN OLDER CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLD.
OUR RESEARCH ALSO FOUND.
THAT THE TYPICAL CARE GIVER.
OF AN OLDER INDIVIDUAL SPENDS
NEARLY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR OUT OF POCKET. TO CARE FOR
A LOVED ONE AND IT'S OVER TEN
THOUSAND IF CARING FOR SOMEBODY
WITH ALZHEIMER'S OR OTHER
RELATED DIMENSIONS.
AND OF COURSE IS ISSUE WAS
COMPOUNDED.
BY THE AGING OF OF CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION AND THE INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES.
AT THE SAME TIME THAT THIS AGING.
WAVE IS COMING WE'RE ALSO GONNA
SEE A TREMENDOUS DECLINE IN THE
NUMBER OF AVAILABLE PAID AND
UNPAID CARE GIVERS.
IN TWENTY TEN THE NUMBER WAS.
SEVEN TO ONE BY TWENTY FIFTY TO
BE THREE TO ONE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO DO SOMETHING TO CONFRONT THE
CHALLENGE NOW WHEN WE DO BELIEVE
WE HAVE TO START NOW.
WE MUST FIND A SUSTAINABLE
CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC SOLUTION FOR
THE CHALLENGES THAT ARE MIDDLE
CLASS FAMILIES FEES.
AND CARING FOR THEIR LOVED ONES
AS WELL POWER AGING AND DISABLE
CALIFORNIANS TO LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY IN THE COMMUNITIES
WHERE THEY WANT TO BE.
THE FIRST STEP IN DEVELOPING THE
SOLUTION IS TO DO WHO TO
DESCRIBE HIS TO TURN.
IS TO DETERMINE WHO WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE WHAT BENEFITS WOULD BE
PROVIDED HOW MUCH.
A NEW PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE MY
COST THE ACTUARIAL STUDY FUNDED%
BY THIS ONE MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET REQUEST BEFORE YOU TODAY
IS A CRITICAL STEP. TO
DEVELOPING A SOLUTION. FOR
EXAMPLE AN ACTUARIAL STUDY CAN
EXPLORE AND PROVIDE GUIDANCE ON
THE DAILY AND TOTAL BENEFIT
AMOUNTS.
THE SCOPE OF SERVICES
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA INCLUDING
THE LEVEL OF INDIVIDUAL NEED TO
QUALIFY.
PROJECTED COST ESTIMATES.
PROJECTED SAVINGS TO STATE
FUNDED PROGRAMS INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO MEDI CAL AND I H.
US US.
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTRACT WITH A
QUALIFIED AND CITY FOR A
FEASIBILITY AN ACTUARIAL STUDY.
AN ANALYSIS OF A POTENTIAL LONG
TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
BENEFIT.
ALONG WITH THE OPTIONS FOR SUCH
A BENEFIT AND POTENTIAL
FINANCING THAT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE FOR CALIFORNIA GOING
FORWARD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO -- WE'VE
WE'VE HAD A COUPLE OF VERY BRIEF
MEETINGS SOME WITH SOME MEMBERS
OF THE OF THE COALITION THUS FAR
WE NEED TO LEARN A LOT MORE
ABOUT THE PROPOSAL IT'S
OBVIOUSLY A VERY BIG IDEA --
WE'RE NOT SURE THERE WERE THE
RIGHT PLACE BUT CERTAINLY A LOT
OF THAT THE CONCEPTS THAT ARE
TOUCHED ON HERE OR ISSUES.
CLIENTS IN POPULATIONS WE CARE A
LOT ABOUT FROM IN HOME CARE TO
OUT OF HOME CARE.
AND SERVICES FOR SENIORS SO WE
WILL PLAN TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE COALITION.
THANK YOU.
WE'RE ALSO IN THE PROCESS OF
LEARNING MORE ABOUT THE
ACTUARIAL STUDIES THE SCOPE THE
QUESTIONS --
AND HAPPY TO PROVIDE ANY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO STAFF
AND MEMBERS OF NEEDED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'LL ECHO THE SENTIMENTS MY
COLLEAGUES HAPPY TO FRY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
MR TRIPPING BECAUSE YOU HAVE
NOTHING TO ADD.
ALL RIGHT SIDE JUST WANT TO BE
SURE NO I MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS THE LAST CHANCE.
ALL RIGHT PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE.
I COULDN'T MOVE ABOVE THE BED
NOVEMBER AND THE MAN.
THE BILL MAHER THE DIGGER MOVE
THE MEN WERE HI AGAIN AT SASHA
BITTNER WITH HAND IN HAND THE
DOMESTIC EMPLOYERS NETWORK.
AND THE BALLROOM GOOD.
I A VIVID THIRDS --
MOLD BERMAN ROAD TO WAR WE A
BOAT.
WE WERE CAREFUL NINE BERMAN.
FIFTEEN FOR ALL THE PROBLEMS OF
AYE HSS.
I'M NOT SO WORRIED ABOUT MY CARE
I'M WORRIED ABOUT THE CARE OF MY
PARENTS AS THEY AGE MY NAME
BURGER WITH THEM WE'RE DOING
GROWN.
THEY MAKE PRETTY GOOD RUMORED I
MEAN --
WHERE WOULD BE BROUGH BROUGH?
THEY THEY MEAN NO PLEA BROUGH.
DO OF BULLDOZED TO GO DO YOU
MEAN NEEDED THE MY PARENTS ARE
MIDDLE INCOME --
THEY MAKE PRETTY GOOD MONEY BUT
THEY PROBABLY WON'T BE ABLE TO
AFFORD THE CARE THAT THEY'LL
NEED AS THEY GET ON AND WITH THE
BABY BOOM MOVES.
RULING THEN DO.
HEY DO JUDY THE GROUP THE GROUP.
THERE WE HAVE DID STOOD DE
[inaudible]
DO.
MAIN GEAR WILL BE BREWING DUONG.
THEN. FOR GROWTH.
OLDER DOES THEN BRING YOUR AND
GO BE BOOSTED THE BREWING THE
THOUGH YEAH WE WERE IN.
CAN LIVE WITH BORN PER DAY THE
VICE.
SO AS THE BABY BOOMERS BOOM INTO
THE INTO THE WORLD --
IT'S ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL THAT WE
DO THE STUDY BECAUSE IT WILL AND
UNABLE AS TO CREATE A PLAN SO
THAT EVERYONE CAN AGE --
WITH DIGNITY AND LIVE A FULL AND
PRODUCTIVE LIFE BOTH SENIORS AS
WELL AS ON YOUR YOUNG PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES.
AND THING DO YOU.
AND BRING YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I THINK SASHA ADEQUATELY
REPRESENTED HAND IN HAND THE
DOMESTIC EMPLOYERS NETWORK BUT
I'M ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WORKERS
COALITION --
WHICH IS A BROAD COALITION IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT IS
LED BY DOMESTIC WORKERS MAINLY
IN THE PRIVATE MARKET.
OF WHICH IS ABOUT [inaudible]
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND ESTIMATED --
AND MANY OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
DOMESTIC WORKER COALITION ARE
DOING IMPORTANT WORK --
PROVIDING LONG TERM SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES PERSONAL CARE
ATTENDANTS.
TO OTHER INDIVIDUALS AND THEY
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR OWN
FUTURE AND WHO WILL SUPPORT THEM
AS THEY AGE OR HAVE AN INJURY
AND TO DISABILITY --
SO AGAIN ADD THIS IS OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE FEASIBILITY STUDY SO WE CAN
MAKE A PLAN THANKS SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S RIGHT.
FOR LAST OF THE MOHICANS.
SHEILA GUN CUSHMAN MAYBE I'M NOT
THE LAST I DON'T KNOW ANYWAY --
HAND IN HAND --
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT STEPHANIE
M. AND LISA SEE.
THEY ARE BOTH PEOPLE WHO.
ARE NOT ON SSI.
LEASES ON MEDI CAL I DON'T THINK
STEPHANIE IS.
STEPHANIE IS A JAPANESE AMERICAN
BORN IN HAWAII --
RIGHT AT THE END OF WORLD WAR
TWO OR AFTER THE END OF WORLD
WAR.
TWO I CAN'T REMEMBER WHICH BUT
HER GRANDFATHER HER FATHER.
WAS INVOLVED THEY THEY THEY WILL
WANT TO THE I WAS GET THESE
WRONG THEY GET THEY WENT TO THE
INTERNMENT CAMPS.
AND SO SHE'S AT BEEN A PART OF
THE RESTORATION OF ALL THAT
SHE'S BEEN VERY IMPORTANT IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
SHE'S A PERSON WITH A DISABILITY
POSTPONE AND I WISH I THOUGHT TO
GET A PHOTO BUT IT DIDN'T --
AND LEASES TOTALLY BLIND AND SHE
WORKS AS A STATE WORKER IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION.
AND THESE FOLKS ARE PEOPLE WHO
NEED L. T. S. S. --
STEPHANIE IS NOW EXPERIENCING
DEMENTIA.
AND HER COMMUNITY OF ASIAN
AMERICAN FOLK.
ARE HELPING HER AND THERE'S AN
IN THE THERE'S A RESOURCE.
WHOSE NAME I DON'T REMEMBER AND
I'M SORRY.
SHE LIVES IN BERKELEY --
AND THEY'RE JUST PUTTING STUFF
TOGETHER.
AND SHE SHE DOESN'T QUALIFY FOR
MEDI CAL BUT SHE CAN'T.
GET THE LTO SESSION NEEDS.
THIS STUDY WOULD HELP.
PROVE WHAT WE ALREADY KNOW THAT
PEOPLE.
AREN'T ABLE TO DO WHAT THEY NEED
TO DO AND I'M.
I JUST WANNA HARKEN BACK TO
SOMEBODY MENTIONED DENTICLE I
LOST A TOOTH WHEN WE DIDN'T HAVE
DONE TO CAL FOR A FEW YEARS.
AND I SAY WE I MEAN THEY TOOK
AWAY AT THE STATE LEVEL THE
DENTAL STUFF.
AND I'M STILL HAVING TO IS
PROBLEMS BEHIND IT.
AND THE DENTIST CAL IS NOT
PAYING A HIGH ENOUGH RATE I HSS
HOURS ARE NOT WHAT THEY NEED TO
BE WAGES AREN'T WHAT THEY NEED
TO BE TASKS AREN'T.
GAUGED BY REAL TIME.
THE ASSUMPTION OF MULTI TASKING
ISN'T ALWAYS TRUE WE NEED WE
NEED L. T. S. S. THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYBODY OR AS MUCH OF
EVERYBODY AS POSSIBLE.
AND WE NEED ARE DOLLARS TO GO AS
FAR AND AS LONG AS WE ARE IN OUR
COMMUNITY WE ARE LESS EXPENSIVE
THAN IF YOU THROW US IN
INSTITUTIONS.
AND IF YOU THROW SINCE TO
WILL -- NOT
LIVE VERY LONG OR VERY WELL.
BECAUSE OUR COMMUNITIES KEEP US
STRONG AND BY THE WAY.
IMAY BE VULNERABLE UNDER SOME
[inaudible]
WHATEVER'S.
BUT MY COMMUNITY IS NOT ABOUT
VULNERABILITY UNLESS ITS
VULNERABILITY TO EACH OTHER AND
HELPING EACH OTHER [inaudible]
WERE RESILIENT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE USERNAME ORGANIZATION TELL
ME IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT FOR
FEASIBILITY STUDY.
GARY PASSED MORE CONGRESS OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS WE HAVE BEEN
STRONGLY STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THE OF THE CAT A PROPOSAL.
ON AND JURORS ADOPTION OF IT
THANK YOU OF THE SAME QUEST
THANK YOU.
RANDY WOLF SEIU LOCAL TWENTY
FIFTEEN ALSO ON BEHALF OF UT AT
UT W. ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY CRISTINA LEFT TO PUT OUR
KIDS TO BED.
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU FOR STICKING WITH US THANK
YOU FOR HEARING ALL THE VOICES-OF OUR MEMBERS TODAY.
GREAT JOB ON YOUR FIRST HEARING.
THANK YOU.
AND CONTROLS THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR PRESENTING.
TWENTY YOU INDEPENDENCE --
TO LIVING CENTERS LOCATED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT WE ALSO
CATER MEMBER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JUNIOR RESERVATIONS AS PROVIDER
AND HE W. MEMBER LOCAL THIRTY
NINE THIRTY ON THIS DAY WILL
PROVIDE INSIGHT JOBS YOU
AFFECTED WE DEAL WITH THE LONG
TERM CARE CRISIS.
WE NEED TO PLAN FOR THE INFLUX
OF ON AGING BABY BOOMERS.
THEY HAVE A HOST OF MEDICAL
PROBLEM FOR THAT HOUSE NUMBERS
OF DEMENTIA.
IS BECOMING AN ISSUE THAT IS
DEFINITELY THERE IS EXPLORING.
VERGE OF HIS LOVED ONES AND
PROVIDERS ARE RELYING ON LIFE
JUST AS THE MEDI CAL.
ON FOR DIRECTION HOW TO HANDLE
THIS INEVITABLE CRISIS THIS
CONDUCT A STUDY.
TO THIS COLLECTION SO YOU'RE
FINE VIABLE WAYS ON PLANNING FOR
THE SITUATION AND MAKE A CRISIS
AND TO A SOLUTION.
I THE SUPPORT TO MILLION DOLLAR
I YOU JUST AS MUCH AS CHAIR IS
STUDY AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU AND THAT WAS ONLY
FORTY SECONDS THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING SUSAN TO MORRIS
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE TWO POINT
THREE MILLION CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE.
THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION IS A
MEMBER OF KATE AND WE SUPPORT
THE ONE MILLION DOLLAR ACTUARIAL
STUDY THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU.
HER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIAN A MEMBER OF THE
ALLIANCE AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S COLORADO CAMERINO I
HOPE YOU'RE NOT TIMING MAY
BECAUSE IF I GET RUSHED I TEND
TO TALK AND FILIPINO.
BUT I KNEW I AM AN A. R. P.
VOLUNTEER LET'S GET AN
INTERPRETER RIGHT NOW.
HI I'M AN AARP VOLUNTEER AND I
STRONGLY ENDORSE --
A OUR PEACE EFFORTS --
TO COME UP WITH THE LPS AS
SUPPORT LONG TERM SUPPORT
[inaudible]
AND I JUST WANNA MENTION THAT MY
MOTHER LOS A DEATH ANNIVERSARY
IS A ONE YEAR DEATH ANNIVERSARY
WAS IN DECEMBER.
HE PASSED AWAY OF PANCREATIC
CANCER.
AND MY MY DAD'S ONE YEAR
ANNIVERSARY IS COMING UP IN TEN
DAYS HE WAS NINETY ONE YEARS OLD.
AND IN THE WANING YEARS OF THEIR
LIVES WE YOU WE THE FAMILIES OR
THE CARE GIVERS WITH THE CARE
THEY'RE NEEDS GROW THEM TO THEIR
APPOINTMENTS WHAT'S WERE NO
MURDERS.
AND I ESTIMATE.
THAT AT WHEN THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
SO -- AND
THROUGH THIS EXPERIENCE WE WOULD
HAVE BENEFITTED.
FROM RESOURCE THIS AND THE
SERVICES THAT WE THERE'D BE NO.
EXCESS THAT ARE WE WEREN'T
WEREN'T AVAILABLE TO US.
A A RP HAS BEEN IN THE FOREFRONT
OF ADVOCATING FOR A FOCUS LPS A
STUDY.
AND THIS WILL BENEFIT FAMILIES
LIKE MINE THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING.
THANK YOU I'M SO SORRY FOR YOUR
LOSSAND I THANK YOU FOR ALL
THOSE YOUR GOOD SON.
ALL THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU DID.
YES ROB WIDE AND THERE ARE
PEOPLE I WENT HERE.
A A RP STANDS IN SUPPORT OF THE
AGING AND DISABILITY ALLIANCE WE
STAND WITH OUR PARTNERS ON THIS
BUDGET REQUEST FOR THE ONE
MILLION DOLLARS.
A. R. P. S. NEARLY THREE POINT
THREE MILLION MEMBERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA NEARLY ALL
OF THESE MEMBERS ARE AFFECTED BY
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
THAT'S WHY A R. P. STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ARE WE MUST FIRST FIGURE OUT HOW
MUCH IT'S GOING TO COST WHO WILL
BE ELIGIBLE HOW LONG THEY'RE
GOING TO BE ELIGIBLE.
AND ALL THOSE THINGS HAVE TO BE
FIGURED OUT THAT'S WHAT THE ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IS.
FOR A. R. P. DID A CONDUCTED A
STUDY IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
AND IT REVEALED THAT MOST
CALIFORNIANS CANNOT AFFORD THE
HIGH COST ASSOCIATED WITH LONG
TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
SO WE HAVE A LOT OF CALIFORNIANS
OUT THERE THAT ARE VULNERABLE TO
THIS TYPE OF EXPECTS THAT CAN
COME UP ANYTIME. ONE EXPRESS A.
R. P. STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE L. T. S.
S. FEASIBILITY STUDY.
THANK YOU VERY KINDLY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
GOOD EVENING.
CHAU CAN SIGN WITH THE STATE AND
PUT A LIVING COUNCIL.
OF REPRESENTING --
DIVERSE DISABILITY COMMUNITY
AGENCIES TWENTY EIGHT
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS
ACROSS THE STATE.
AND WE ARE A MEMBER OF KEITA AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS.
LEGISLATION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CAROL SO FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING WERE ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE CATO ORGANIZATION
AND OUR STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU JUST IN THE NICK OF
TIME.
LIZA COLEMAN CALIFORNIA LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION
AND AM VERY PROUD NUMBER OF KATE
AND I'VE I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT.
I ALWAYS COME BEFORE YOU ASKING
FOR MONEY TO DO WORK AND SO THIS
IS ODD FOR ME TO ASK FOR MONEY
TO DO THINK TANK STUFF.
BUT THIS IS A STEP ONE THAT
LEADS TO A STEP TWO WE NEED THE
STATE TO COLLECT THE DATA.
SO THAT THEN THE COMMONWEALTH OF
NEW HAMPSHIRE I THINK IS THE
ORGANIZATION THAT KATE HAS
SECURED WILL BE DOING THE NEXT
STUDY.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO HAVE THIS
INFORMATION BEFORE YOU GO TO THE
NEXT STEP.
AND KATIE DID TRY TO FIND PUBLIC
FUNDING FOR THIS STUDY WE DID
LOOKING TO GRANTS WEEK.
WE COULDN'T FIND AN ENTITY THAT
WOULD GIVE US THIS MILLION
DOLLARS AND WE DON'T HAVE THE
TIME TO WAIT.
SO SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE ASKING
FOR THIS.
A PART OF THE THIRTY FIVE ALMOST
PROGRAMS TO SEE FAMILIES AND
HEAR FROM THEM.
WITH GROWING URGENCY HOW ARE WE
GOING TO CARE FOR OUR LOVED ONES
IF WE DON'T WANT TO IMPOVERISH
AND GO ON TO MEDICARE OUT BUT WE
DON'T HAVE THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH TO PAY FOR
SYSTEM LIVING.
GOOD NIGHT.
THANK YOU AND GOOD NIGHT.
I THINK THE THE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S --
STATE OF THE STATE ADDRESS HE
TALKED ABOUT TO THE MASTER PLAN
ON AGING.
AND I JUST A RHETORICAL QUESTION
HOW CAN THIS FIT INTO THE
GOVERNOR'S PLANNED FOR A MASTER
PLAN.
I THINK IT'S SOMETHING TO THINK
ABOUT WITH THIS ITEM IS --
THAT -- TO
TO TO HOLD OPEN AND SO WE WILL
CONTINUE OUR DISCUSSIONS ON IT I
DO THANK YOU. FOR PRESENTING IT.
NOW WE HAVE THE LAST TWO THIRDS
ITEMS ARE NON DISCUSSION ITEMS.
IS THERE ANYONE WISHING.
TO OFFER COMMENT ON THESE
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
THIS HEARING HAS CONCLUDED